On the 13th of October, 1989, the town of
Danner, Wisconsin, was shaken by a seismic
event unlike anything they'd ever experienced.
This might have been written off as an earthquake,
were it not for one disturbing factor - the
ground shaking event was accompanied by a
huge spike of radioactivity.
With the strange phenomenon happening a month
before the Berlin Wall was torn down, during
a period of the Cold War that historians call
“The Year of Crisis”, it’s easy to understand
why the people of Danner immediately assumed
the worst.
But the huge eruption they felt wasn't the
result of a nuclear bomb going off.
The SCP Foundation was alerted to the event
in Danner when they picked up a series of
radio transmissions coming from just outside
the town.
When they arrived, they found something incredible,
like something out of a sci-fi movie.
Standing at the quake's epicenter, was a creature
that looked to be from another world.
Standing 2 meters tall and weighing almost
300 kilograms, the being was green and brown
in color, with a bulky, humanoid body.
It’s head was a different story though,
and resembled a gigantic housefly, with a
proboscis and huge, stereoscopic eyes.
Surprisingly, the strange creature did not
immediately go on a rampage.
Instead, the being - designated SCP-2273 - appeared
to be exhausted, injured, and extremely malnourished.
It offered no resistance at all to the Foundation
containment team and it was taken to Site-17
without conflict.
While the SCP Foundation is no stranger to
visitors from other worlds, there was something
especially unusual about this supposed alien
invader.
The doctors who examined the creature and
treated its injuries found an appendage that
seemed to function as an organic radio transmitter,
and large open wounds on its shoulder blades
and forearms where further appendages had
been ripped off.
Additionally, while its insect-like exoskeleton
was mostly a uniform green and brown pattern,
the creature's upper arms and torso were dotted
with a variety of scars and markings that,
on closer inspection, looked like military
badges.
Was this some kind of wounded intergalactic
soldier who had been stranded on Earth?
If it was, then how were the organic badges
on this alien's exoskeleton a near perfect
match to military badges worn by soldiers
in the Soviet Union?
Even if they did reference a unit that didn’t
officially exist within the Soviet army.
The scientists were sure, this alien wasn't
an alien at all… underneath its exoskeleton
was a non-anomalous human being.
If that was true, then this was even more
terrifying than an extraterrestrial visitor.
The scientists were sure the USSR had developed
a new kind of organic armor, and this anomaly
showing up in Wisconsin was the result of
a test on US soil that had gone wrong.
If that was the case, then there was no telling
how many more of these exoskeletons were out
there and would need to be contained.
The Foundation had to act quickly and find
out more.
While SCP-2273 was recovering, they called
in Dr. Friedritch, an on-site psychologist
who could speak several languages including
Russian.
Dr. Friedritch would be tasked with interrogating
the SCP on his origins and the nature of the
suit.
The interview was conducted via AM radio from
a separate observation chamber, as the biological
transmitter seemed to be SCP-2273's only method
of communication.
The interview began with Dr. Friedritch speaking
to SCP-2273 in Russian, only for 2273 to respond
that Dr. Friedritch’s accent was atrocious
and requesting he use German instead.
SCP-2273 who, according to the organic military
patches on his body, was named Major Alexei
Belitrov, initially resisted being interviewed.
He believed that he was a prisoner of war,
being held by the American military.
According to him, he had been in the middle
of battle, and that the Americans had killed
his men and left him for dead in the wilderness.
Nothing that Dr. Friedritch told him - that
there was no war, or that the Foundation was
not affiliated with the US government - could
convince him otherwise and he refused to talk
further.
Before a second interview was conducted, Belitrov
was given an old copy of the Level 1 Researcher
General Debrief, as a way of helping him further
understand the nature of the Foundation and
his containment.
Belitrov was more co-operative after that,
though the realization that he would most
likely be kept in containment for the rest
of his life caused him great distress and
he was unwilling to speak to Dr. Friedritch
for another three days.
Dr. Friedritch didn’t give up though, and
when Belitrov finally opened up to the doctor,
he began to tell him more and more.
Belitrov told the doctor that when he was
a child, Russia was hit by an American nuclear
warhead, and that the Soviet Union immediately
retaliated.
The resulting nuclear conflict, which Belitrov
called The War to End the World, caused massive
devastation and left most of the planet dangerously
irradiated.
That’s why he had the exoskeleton.
It was to shield him from the radiation and
allow him to survive above ground.
Unfortunately, Belitrov knew very little about
how the suit was made or how it worked, saying
that it was built by “the engineers”,
and that it grew naturally over a period of
several years.
But Belitrov hadn’t made the decision himself.
It was his parents who had volunteered him
as a test subject for the exoskeleton suit
program when he was still young, hoping it
would give him a better chance at survival.
The process of bonding the exoskeleton to
the human body was extremely painful, but
according to Belitrov, its advantages far
outweighed the pain.
The suit not only helped him survive in a
nuclear wasteland, but made him a better soldier.
The suit allowed him to lift and carry up
to 1200 kilograms, gave him stereoscopic vision,
and the organic radio transmitter allowed
him to communicate with other soldiers across
long distances, as well as listen in on encrypted
enemy transmissions.
The wounds on his shoulders and arms, where
it looked like appendages had been ripped
out, were where his weapons and supply packs
had previously been mounted.
Belitrov had been stationed with his men in
the area he was discovered when they were
attacked by American soldiers.
The soldiers had ripped off Belitrov's weapons
and supply pack, and did the same to all of
his men as well.
They were all shot, with Belitrov being spared
for the moment only because the Americans
had identified him as the commanding officer.
Suddenly, there was a bright flash of light,
and the American soldiers vanished.
Not only that, but the landscape changed - where
there had been a post-nuclear wasteland before,
now there were lush green trees.
Injured and disoriented, Belitrov began sending
distress signals, only to have those signals
intercepted by the SCP Foundation.
The most interesting part of Belitrov's story,
as far as the Foundation was concerned, came
during his fourth interview, when Dr. Friedritch
asked him about the engineers who had designed
the exoskeleton suit.
In Belitrov's own words - “They weren't
truly known to Man until the years of the
Great War and the Revolution.
The French found them, in buried cities where
the Western Allies were digging their trenches.
Eventually, they were made to build weapons
for the war, by both sides.”
By his description, these engineers didn't
sound human, but they were by no means unknown
to the SCP Foundation.
Belitrov described the engineers as humanoid,
nocturnal, covered in fur, and possessing
technology and intelligence far beyond that
of any human.
Those familiar with the Foundation's history
might already know the engineers by their
Foundation designation of SCP-1000, or their
more commonly known name - Bigfoot.
A quick rundown: SCP-1000 are a species of
intelligent humanoid primates that lived alongside
humanity in highly advanced cities until their
own technology was turned against them.
Not only were their cities wiped off the face
of the earth, but 70 percent of their population
was slaughtered, and the survivors were driven
mad to the point that their mental faculties
were no higher than those of a chimpanzee
or gorilla.
The SCP Foundation is tasked with keeping
them away from human contact, in fear of what
the creatures would be able to do to humanity
if they ever regained their memories and full
mental function and rumors have been spread
about them possessing deadly anomalous properties.
But evidently, the destruction of the SCP-1000
species never occurred in Belitrov's universe,
or if it did, it wasn't nearly as complete.
In that timeline, humanity regained contact
with SCP-1000 after discovering their underground
cities sometime during World War One.
After this discovery, both the Allied and
Axis powers began recruiting them to build
weapons, and their weapons played a role in
both the Russian Revolution and the second
world war.
It was because of these technological advantages
that the Cold War escalated into what would
become the war to end all wars.
Both sides were armed with not only nuclear
warheads, but highly advanced, radiation-proof
exoskeleton armor that allowed the conflict
to continue even after the total destruction
of the planet.
While the humans fought above ground, life
continued as normal for SCP-1000 in their
underground cities.
As Belitrov noted, they never wore the armor
themselves, as they had no need to venture
above ground.
“Only soldiers wear armor, and this is not
their war.”
Belitrov continued to adjust to life in containment
and sitting for regular interviews with Dr.
Friedritch.
He was given the rations provided for humanoid
anomalies, but in much larger quantities,
as the suit required him to eat around 8000
calories a day to keep it functioning.
Belitrov also began taking advantage of his
ability to access the Foundation's library
- he would often read, or listen to classical
music, particularly by the Russian composer
Tchaikovsky.
He seemed especially fond of reading The Time
Machine by HG Wells, no surprise given he
was able to directly relate to the experience
of living through an apocalypse and being
transported to a strange timeline with no
way to return home.
But with little else to occupy his time, Belitrov
began to display symptoms consistent with
post-traumatic stress disorder, reporting
in his now regular interviews with Dr. Friedritch
that he was constantly reliving memories of
the battles he'd fought and the lives he had
taken in combat.
The suit was making the problem worse too,
it seemed.
It was as if he could never forget, as one
of its features was an ability to store and
replay memories.
This feature was intended as a strategic aid
that would allow commanding officers to more
effectively gather and process information
about their surroundings, but outside of combat,
this only served to force Belitrov into reliving
his most painful memories again and again.
Every night as he tried to sleep, he would
see the faces of his men, their weapons torn
from their exoskeletons, laying in the dirt
after being gunned down by the enemy.
Like many veterans, Belitrov was being hit
all at once with the harsh realities of war.
Now that his brain wasn't solely focused on
keeping him alive, it had time to process
all the horrors he'd experienced.
He told Dr. Friedritch- “I trained alongside
these men for years before they put us back
on the surface, since we were all young children.
We were brothers.
And I gave the order to surrender, and…
got them killed.
I should have died with them.”
While the story of SCP-2273 ends here, the
story of Alexei Belitrov, SCP-2273-1, continues.
In 2018, Belitrov was allowed passage to Volgograd,
Russia, as part of an Anomaly Reintegration
program.
While he was unable to secure employment within
the Russian government as he had hoped, he
eventually was taken in by a monastery and
continued to write letters to Dr. Friedritch
until Friedritch's eventual death from lymphoma-related
complications.
There’s plenty more on the monastery, the
Anomaly Reintegration program, and what happened
to Major Belitrov when he returned to Russia,
but that'll have to be a story for another
day.
The year was 1857, and the Second Opium War
was raging between China and the combined
forces of the English and French. It was one
of the many bloody colonial wars fought over
resources like tea, sugar, and the intoxicating
opium poppy. It was a war fought by peasants
and noblemen alike. One of these aristocratic
soldiers was the noble Lord Theodore Thomas
Blackwood, the quintessential English gentleman
and explorer. While his fellow soldiers cowered
behind cover, Lord Blackwood charged into
the fray, shouldering his rifle and firing
his pistol into the crowd of opposing soldiers.
It was the Battle of Canton, one of the most
crucial battles of the entire conflict. The
French and English were laying siege to the
city of Canton, also known as Guangzhou, to
prove their military dominance and capture
an important Chinese government official.
Lord Blackwood led the charge on horseback.
Every bullet seemed to find the heart of a
foe. He was a true hero among men; a gentleman
warrior with class, refinement, and style.
And it would be thanks to his expert leadership
and marksmanship on the field that the allied
European forces won the battle decisively.
Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood is a name that
deserves to be counted among Lord
Horatio Nelson, Sir Francis Bacon, and Sir
Walter Raleigh. In addition to being a skilled
and honorable fighter, Lord Blackwood is an
consummate explorer, naturalist, and frontiersman.
During his heyday, he traveled perhaps further
than any man across the known and unknown
corners of the globe. He made scientific,
biological, and anthropological discoveries
that should have reset the course of society
forever. And yet, you won’t find any records
in the history books of Lord Theodore Thomas
Blackwood. Nor will you find any grand oil
paintings, or dedicated wings in British museums.
This is because Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood…
is a four and a half inch, telepathic neon
sea slug. And he’s known to the SCP Foundation,
as SCP-1867.
While he would never admit to it, Lord Blackwood
belongs to the species Nembrotha kubaryana,
also known as the variable neon slug. He’s
kept in a standard aquarium in a Foundation
containment site, and is physically no different
to any other member of his species. What makes
Lord Blackwood unique is his powerful telepathic
abilities - specifically, the power to communicate
by speaking directly into people’s minds.
And what’s more, he’s extremely talkative.
But to what extent is anything that this anomalous
sea slug says true? Or is he just like SCP-082,
Fernand the Cannibal - a creative and pathological
liar.
It isn’t committed to record how exactly
the Foundation discovered Lord Blackwood.
Perhaps a local aquarium worker worried they
were going insane when they heard the voice
of a nineteenth century English nobleman ringing
in their ears whenever they were cleaning
algae out of the tank. Maybe Lord Blackwood
was found by SCP Foundation divers, who are
constantly combing the ocean for anomalous
creatures and activity. What we do know is
that Lord Blackwood is an incredibly strange
and mysterious individual. He claims to have
visited locations all around the world, and
encountered rare societies and creatures.
The Foundation was skeptical about a number
of Lord Blackwood’s more outlandish claims,
on account of him being a sea slug, but he
does appear to have the knowledge to back
up his supposed experience. Interviews with
Lord Blackwood have shown that he’s extremely
knowledgeable in the areas of geography, zoology,
botany, archaeology, anthropology and linguistics
relating to his claimed regions of exploration,
as well as more esoteric fields such as obscure
mythology, mysticism, and cryptozoology. In
other words, if Lord Blackwood hadn’t gone
on his escapades around the globe throughout
history, how would he come to possess this
wide variety of information?
The Foundation was getting frustrated, and
began to probe further into the personal life
of the most interesting gastropod in containment.
Lord Blackwood, under questioning, was always
polite and amicable with Foundation staff.
He seemed to display no real knowledge of
the fact that he himself was a sea slug - going
as far to accuse other people of being crazy
or drunk when they brought the fact up to
him. While none of Lord Blackwood’s tall
tales ever extend past the year 1910, he told
fanciful stories of exploring the Americas,
and of his involvement in the Second Opium
War on the side of the English.
Naturally, the Foundation wanted proof. When
they pressured Lord Blackwood on this, something
even stranger happened: He gave it. The Lord
told his interviewers that he would happily
donate his collection to them, if it gave
them cause to believe what he was saying.
He gave the baffled Foundation researchers
the address of a cottage in England where
they could find the secrets to his bizarre
and mysterious past, and local agents in the
area followed up on the information.
Upon investigation, Foundation Field Agents
did indeed find the cottage that Lord Blackwood
had specified. It was being maintained by
an extremely old woman. When questioned about
her presence there, she said that she was
“keeping the house for Lord Blackwood”,
and gave no more useful information. Incidentally,
it appeared that this singular purpose was
all that this old woman was living for. She
abruptly passed away from heart failure five
days after the Foundation commandeered the
cottage. Whether anything truly anomalous
caused this, we still don’t know.
At first, the cottage seemed normal, until
the Field Agents discovered a secret basement
housing Lord Blackwood’s “collection.”
They were amazed at what they saw: The basement
consisted of zoological and botanical specimens,
over three thousand artifacts, a library containing
over five thousand items, and a functioning
1800s scientific laboratory. It took around
three weeks for Foundation agents working
round the clock in shifts to remove all the
items from Lord Blackwood’s mysterious collection,
and what they found raised even more questions.
The collection included, but was by no means
limited to: 116 unknown species of plants,
107 unknown species of insects, 28 unknown
species of lizards, 23 unknown species of
fish, 14 unknown species of amphibians, 12
unknown species of mammals, Fossils pertaining
to 8 unknown species of dinosaur, Fossils
pertaining to 12 unknown species of prehistoric
mammal, and Artifacts belonging to 29 unknown
indigenous societies. That’s a lot of unknowns!
But wait, there’s more! His collection also
contained a collection of seemingly unknown
firearms, including three wide-bore muskets
marked as “Dr. B. T. Moth’s Effective
Particle Destabilizers.” Detailed globes
of Mercury, Venus, Mars, and the Galilean
moons, accompanied by notes detailing possible
paths of surface exploration. A heavily modified
carriage, containing instruments of unknown
purpose. A note attached to the door reads
“On the fritz. Speak with Henry.” And
a highly dangerous and seemingly anomalous
machine that killed four Foundation Field
Agents before it was destroyed on site. And
when questioned about this little fiasco,
Lord Blackwood responded:
“I did warn you to be careful around my
collection. That bloody thing nearly took
my head off back in ninety-seven when I found
it.”
However, there was one thing recovered from
Lord Blackwood’s collection that was perhaps
more interesting than all the others: 35 hand-written
journals containing recordings of events described
by Lord Blackwood in his grandiose tall tales
to the Foundation researchers. The accounts
are generally identical to the stories he
had told, save for some slight variations
and exaggerations on the part of Blackwood
in the re-telling. Most interestingly of all,
all of these journals have been dated to the
appropriate time period of the events described
by Foundation scientists.
While his stories are too numerous to all
be shared here, there’s one that perfectly
sums them all up: Lord Blackwood’s account
of a possible encounter with SCP - 1000, also
known as Bigfoot, in Seattle during the mid-1800s.
Lord Blackwood, seeking to explore the so-called
“new world” of North America, embarked
with an assistant and an indigenous American
guide to the Pacific Northwest, in search
of the legendary Sasquatch. The trio was headed
for Mount Rainier, then known as Tahoma. During
the journey, Lord Blackwood found a young
fox caught in a trap that had been set by
a local tribe. He took sympathy on the animal
and freed it, allowing it to run away to safety.
That night, he and his assistant met up with
the rest of his guide’s tribe, and they
settled down for the evening. However, things
took a disastrous turn when the camp was raided
by a rival tribe. Almost everyone was slaughtered
in the process, and Lord Blackwood and his
two companions were hauled away by the enemy
tribe for a sinister purpose: Sacrifice to
a violent local deity.
As it turns out, the creature that this tribe
worshipped was the very same one Lord Blackwood
and the others were trying to find: A particularly
large and aggressive Sasquatch. Each night,
a different sacrifice was made to the Sasquatch.
The victim would be placed near a forest clearing
while the tribe played a primal song, and
the Sasquatch would emerge from the trees
to devour its prey. The first night it ate
the assistant, the next night it ate the guide.
And then, it became time for the sacrifice
of Lord Blackwood himself.
As Blackwood was presented for sacrifice,
he accepted his fate. But instead of the Sasquatch,
a legion of woodland animals emerged from
the trees - foxes, elks, raccoons, and more
- themselves painted with tribal symbols.
The animals seemed to be on Lord Blackwood’s
side, and attacked the tribespeople who had
been holding him captive giving Blackwood
the chance to flee into the forest during
the chaos. Later, these same animals would
find Blackwood again, and present him with
the things his captors had stolen from him.
An elder fox also gave him a letter, proclaiming
him a knight of their people now. He was allowed
safe passage back to a nearby settlement,
at which point he wrote to his financiers
back in England, explaining the situation
and asking for more money to perform further
expeditions into the Tahoma region. The whole
incident had only increased his thirst for
adventure and exploration.
Whether this tale is actually true, or just
a bizarre, colonial fantasy from the pathological
mind of a telepathic sea slug, we may never
know - but it doesn’t make it any less interesting.
To this day, Lord Blackwood continues to be
a perplexing but fascinating anomaly. He may
not be the most dangerous, and he may not
be the most useful, either, but there’s
no denying that perhaps we’d all like to
sit next to his tank for a couple hours one
day, and hear him spin a good yarn over a
warm cup of tea.
Welcome back, Comrade.
The case of SCP-2273 - also known as Major
Alexei Belitrov - has sparked your imagination,
and you need to know more.
But even if you’re not familiar with the
Major, his story, all you need to know is
that it’s one of war, tragedy, and alternate
dimensions.
He first appeared in the town of Danner, Wisconsin,
on the 13th of October, 1989, during an unprecedented
seismic event.
When he was first discovered, the Foundation
researchers assumed that he was an extraterrestrial
being, on account of his advanced organic
exoskeleton.
In a surprising move for such an imposing
creature, Belitrov gave himself up to Foundation
Agents without a fight.
Major Belitrov was then impounded in Foundation
containment Site 17, where he was interrogated
thoroughly.
Over a series of interviews, the Foundation
ascertained that Belitrov came from an alternate
timeline where Russia and the US are locked
in a so-called “War To End The World”,
thanks to advanced military technology given
to them by SCP-1000.
Belitrov had narrowly escaped execution at
the hands of American soldiers, and appeared
in our timeline.
Now, he’s a prisoner of the advanced suit
that formerly kept him alive.
But his story isn’t over.
This last remnant of a cold-war-turned-hot
has plenty left to teach us.
Something that you need to understand about
the SCP Foundation before we go any further
is that it doesn’t only exist in every nation
across the globe, it also exists in every
splinter-reality across the multiverse.
And these splinter realities offer a countless
multitude of tales - of different places,
different people, and different times.
Today’s tale concerns Major Belitrov’s
future, in a universe where the secrecy of
the Foundation is broken, and the anomalous
world needs to find a way to fit in with our
own.
The year was 2018.
Like many humanoid anomalies that the Foundation
was holding in this timeline, Belitrov was
released from containment.
He was no longer an SCP, he was now a mere
Person of Interest, free to move around as
he pleased.
But this didn’t mean Belitrov was about
to enjoy a quiet life on easy street - he
was still an inter dimensional refugee from
a broken alternate world.
Thankfully, there was a certain group willing
to help: The Manna Charitable Foundation.
This anomalous charity has been involved in
a number of strange cases investigated by
the Foundation before, and now, they were
going to lend a hand to Major Belitrov.
Thanks to their Anomaly Reintegration Project,
Manna was able to transport Belitrov back
to his home of Volgograd in Russia.
There, he became something of a national celebrity,
making headlines across the country, sitting
down for interviews on every Russian talk
show, and even being offered book deals.
But as a former military man, Belitrov was
eager to return to government life and run
for a government position.
However, this ambition didn’t go far.
Belitrov was rejected by all the government
bodies he applied to: Even Vladimir Putin
wasn’t eccentric enough to want an insectoid
cyborg from another dimension in his cabinet.
Belitrov endured a rough two years in Volgograd.
He was treated more like a sideshow freak
than a human being - people didn’t want
to rent apartments to him, and he was never
able to find permanent employment.
Even entry level jobs rejected him.
Nobody wanted to get food served to them by
what looked to be a seven foot monster, and
he seemed equally ill-suited to helping Russian
women find the right perfume in department
stores.
In April of 2020, Belitrov had finally had
enough.
He contacted the Manna Charitable Foundation
once again and asked to be relocated.
They told him that some religious institutions
in the area, including the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodox Church, were accepting and housing
anomalous refugees.
Not long after this, Belitrov truly fell off
of the SCP Foundation’s radar.
But one former Foundation operative was well
aware of Major Belitrov’s fate.
It’s 2021.
Dr. Friedrich, the Site-17 Anomaly Psychologist
who’d conducted all the initial interviews
with Belitrov all the way back in 1989, started
receiving letters from him.
There was no indication as to his true location,
and they appeared to have been handled by
a Manna Charitable Foundation Mail Carrier
in Russia, but Dr. Friedrich was happy to
hear from an old friend nonetheless.
Due to a career of working near highly radioactive
anomalies like Belitrov, Dr. Friedrich was
suffering from terminal lymphoma.
It seemed almost like an act of divine providence
that Belitrov’s letters would come to him
so close to the end.
The two began a correspondence, and it was
only after Dr. Friedrich’s eventual death
that the letters came to the SCP Foundation’s
attention.
It was from this final correspondence that
the Foundation was able to answer the big
question: Whatever happened to Major Alexei
Belitrov?
In his first letter to Dr. Friedrich, Belitrov
thanked him profusely.
He knew that Dr. Friedrich had been a crucial
part of him gaining freedom from the Foundation,
and credited the therapeutic techniques taught
to him by Dr. Friedrich with keeping him alive,
and sane, to this day.
Belitrov expressed a mix of amazement at this
brave new world and a sense of profound weariness.
As a man eternally locked into a weapon of
war, he felt unsuited to a world in peacetime.
He almost missed the scorched, irradiated
Russia of his home dimension.
But most of all, he missed Site-17.
He missed Dr. Friedrich.
He missed some of his fellow anomalies, like
SCP-507, the Teleporting Man, and SCP-163,
the Space Crab.
He even missed the simplicity of being contained.
He hoped that Dr. Friedrich would write back.
In his second letter, Belitrov began detailing
his experience with the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodox Church.
Despite growing up in a highly atheistic Communist
environment, Belitrov became enamored with
the ways of the Church.
He found them to be highly accepting of him,
in spite of his unfortunate circumstances.
They displayed a freedom in their faith that
Belitrov had never encountered before, and
he was eager to be a part of it.
With the help of Dr. Friedrich, Belitrov was
also sending letters to some of his fellow
freed anomalies.
He signed off by saying that he had even started
praying - something he’d never even considered
before.
The next letter, sent in 2027, struck a much
more somber tone.
It was sent shortly after Belitrov discovered
Dr. Friedrich’s diagnosis.
He wanted to return and see the doctor one
more time, but the Manna Charitable Foundation
wouldn’t allow him to return to Site-17
- believing he had been abused during his
time there.
Belitrov gave Friedrich his prayers and well-wishes,
and asked for a number through which he could
contact his ailing old friend.
By the time the next letter arrived in 2034,
Belitrov had become a fully-fledged member
of the Eastern Clockwork Orthodox Church.
He referred to the other monks at the monastery
as his brothers and sisters.
He seemed to have finally found a true home
there, and the others fondly referred to him
by the nickname “Father Anvil.”
But the true heart of the letter is Belitrov’s
deep concern for Dr. Friedrich’s health.
Notably, in this letter, he often refers to
Dr. Friedrich by his first name, Thomas, as
though to emphasize the urgency of the message.
After the deaths of several of the anomalies
that Belitrov considered friends, he stated
that he couldn’t handle losing anyone else.
His letter ends with a poignant passage:
“You may be unmarried, Doctor Friedrich,
but you are not unloved.
You have to be strong for me.
You have to be strong for yourself.
If you're ever worried that you cannot find
the strength to continue, think of the garden
you'll plant this spring.
I'd like to share gardening photos with you
again.
Not many of my brothers and sisters here appreciate
the simple beauty of a flower bed or the effort
that goes into growing a patch of vegetables.
It's a beauty I'd like to continue to share.
Trust in the power of our Lord, Thomas, and
trust in the power of modern medicine.
God is smiling on you.
Please, be strong.
With Love and Prayers,
Alexei Belitrov”
This letter arrived on the 15th of February,
2034.
Sadly, Dr. Friedrich had already passed away
four days earlier.
He never got to see Alexei’s final letter.
And it truly was his final letter - with nobody
left for him in the world, Major Belitrov
stopped sending any correspondence.
What we know about the final years of Belitrov’s
life all comes from a few scattered journal
entries, translated from Russian after his
passing.
They provide clues as to the kind of life
he lived during the 29 years the Foundation
could not account for his whereabouts and
actions.
The first entry, written on January 7th, 2035,
paints a grim picture of Belitrov feeling
broken and isolated inside the monastery.
He wrote:
“Today is the day that our monastery celebrates
the birth of our Lord.
However, I feel no desire to celebrate.
All of my friends in this world are dead.
My brothers and sisters are partaking in some
celebration outside my dormitory; all of the
required ceremonies are complete, and neither
they nor whatever is happening out there now
will lighten my mood.”
Belitrov also wrote about losing the comfort
he once had in his faith, and his doubts about
whether he would ever be able to recapture
that comfort.
But he had survived greater traumas than this,
and he would continue to press on.
As the months turned to years and the years
turned to decades, Belitrov climbed through
the ranks of the monastery.
Seeing as the Eastern Clockwork Orthodox Church
practically worshipped the concepts of industrialization
and mechanization, the fact that Belitrov
was permanently encased in a biomechanical
exoskeleton probably made him seem even more
pious to his holy brethren.
The final piece of evidence collected by the
Foundation into the life and times of Alexei
Belitrov came just over twenty years later,
in a final address written to comfort his
followers in preparation for his own death.
Belitrov recounted the details of his own
life: Being born into a world of fire, death,
and mushroom clouds.
Then his life being suddenly saved by forces
beyond his control, only to place him into
containment for almost thirty years.
It was only after accepting the teachings
of the Church, and accepting the Clockwork
Goddess, that he felt he was truly free from
his past.
In this final note, Belitrov lays out some
of the teachings of his new religion: The
belief in a great mechanized Goddess who planned
all of reality.
According to Belitrov, everything in her design
fits together perfectly like cogs in a machine,
turning and twisting in unison to create an
ideal world.
He hoped to be forgiven for the many violent
sins he committed in his military life, and
that his contributions to this new world were
valuable.
At the very end of his final address, Belitrov
wrote:
“I do not believe that my time in this world
is much longer.
Brothers and Sisters, when my time of Judgment
comes, do not mourn me.
I would rather you remember these words: the
Goddess is most pleased with those who seek
kind, non-violent resolution to their problems,
because a machine whose gears grind against
each other is a machine that cannot work.
Seek truth, but also compassion.
The Words are only words.
Seek out the Truth within them.
God bless you all.
Father Anvil.”
A month after authoring this statement, records
indicate that Alexei Belitrov was found dead
in his room, having passed away peacefully
in his sleep from natural causes.
He lived a warrior’s life but died a humble
priest’s death.
The true tragedy in the strange life of Major
Alexei Belitrov is how little choice he had
in his circumstances, but thanks to this tale,
we know that he did what he could with the
life he was given.
His remains lay within the graveyard at the
Eastern Clockwork Orthodoxy monastery where
he spent the last years of his life.
With a life as difficult as his own, we can
only imagine he’s glad to finally rest.
Some of the anomalies the SCP Foundation deals
with are dangerous, with the most powerful
able to end all life and even reality as we
know it.
Others pose no threat at all, and seem content
to simply exist.
Still others are something else entirely.
SCP-4999 is a humanoid entity, though its
appearance seems to fluctuate between manifestations,
with the only unchanging detail being that
it is always dressed in dark formalwear.
Originally thought by many to be an urban
legend, local tales of SCP-4999 are what initially
tipped the Foundation off to its existence,
and further research indicates that there
are accounts that may be referring to the
appearance of 4999 throughout recorded history.
Strangest of all though, is the consistency
with which it appears, or rather the consistent
situations and types of people it appears
to.
From the data available, it seems that SCP-4999
only appears to people in a very specific
type of need.
As you’ll see in the case of a subject named
Alex Hereford and the fateful night he experienced.
The road was slippery, and Alex was driving
too fast.
He knew this of course, but it's a different
matter altogether to know a thing, and to
care about it.
Rain hammered on the front windshield, the
weak headlights of his 2005 Honda Civic barely
punching into the thick, black night ahead
of him.
Winding through the mountain side, the road
was mostly empty, save for the very occasional
twin beams of light blazing past him due to
his high speed.
It was hard to hear the honking of angry horns
over the heavy pounding of the rain.
Then, it happened.
In a way, Alex knew it was inevitable.
His tread-worn wheels finally lost contact
with the ground, thick layer of rainwater
between them and asphalt betraying his speeding
vehicle's grip on the road and sending it
careening out of control.
He had expected fear, but instead felt...
nothing really.
A slight sense of anticipation, like wincing
right before a punch lands in that childhood
game of hitting each other on the arm.
It wasn't that the world had slowed down,
but perhaps his brain was simply working at
a much greater velocity now, recognizing its
own impending death.
His speed of thought seemed magnified to the
point of slowing his perception down.
He'd heard of soldiers in war zones experiencing
the same phenomenon as they felt sure that
in the next few seconds, they'd be dead.
Alex wondered, would he smash into a tree?
Go over a cliff's edge?
He could hardly see the forest or the terrain
beyond in the thick rain and dark of the mountain.
Though he'd traveled this road a million times
before, he had no idea where he actually was
tonight.
He supposed it wouldn't really matter which
it was.
As usual, his thoughts turned to her.
Or rather, they had simply run their course
and returned to the one place they always
did.
It wasn't like there were many other people
to think about in Alex's mostly empty life.
There was, and always had been since the moment
he'd met her, mostly just her.
But even Alex's heightened state of mind couldn't
delay the inevitable for long.
It would be a cliff after all, Alex thought
curiously, catching a glimpse of town lights
far away and below.
The car spun 180 degrees out into empty air,
then came crashing down with a horrible roar
of shattered glass and tearing metal as it
tumbled down the hillside.
Even over the torrential downpour the noise
of Alex's crash was significant- had anyone
been around to hear it.
Finally, after over a hundred feet down a
steep incline, the car smashed into a single
thick oak tree, bringing the disaster to an
end.
As if on cue, the rain began to let up.
Slowly at first, then all of the sudden in
that peculiar way that Northwest torrential
downpours tend to do, as if the sky had at
last finished emptying itself all at once.
Inside the shattered vehicle, Alex was- incredibly-
alive.
At least for the time being.
The airbag deployment had spared his face
the worst of it, and the sturdy aluminum frame
of the vehicle had given its all in protecting
Alex's body from the downhill crash.
But even post-modern vehicle engineering has
its limits.
His breath came in slow, ragged gasps, difficult
at first but gradually steadying.
Not an improvement in his condition, but rather
his body dedicating the rapidly dwindling
resources at its disposal into keeping vital
functions going as long as possible.
Opening his eyes, Alex was surprised to find
himself right side up, less surprised to look
down at the shattered mess his limbs and lower
body had become.
Gradually, Alex's thoughts cleared, his sense
of self returning after the bone-jarring drop
down the steep incline and sudden stop at
the end.
Looking to his right, he could see the trunk
of the tree that had stopped his out of control
tumble.
Despite himself, Alex laughed- a weak, gurgling
chuckle.
So, it was the cliff and a tree after all.
He focused on breathing, letting the waves
of pain wash over him until his brain eventually
canceled them out by injecting his broken
body with adrenaline and chemicals.
Everything was quiet and still after the crash
and the rain, but to his surprise he realized
he could hear... something.
It was faint at first, just a soft crunch
of footsteps on gravel, but the sound grew
louder and louder until at last, it came to
a stop outside Alex's window.
With every ounce of effort, Alex turned his
head towards the sound- a rescuer?
No, impossible.
Nobody was up on this mountain, and nobody
could possibly have reached him here so quickly
even if there had been.
He supposed he should have been surprised,
yet almost from the moment that his eyes fell
on the tall, handsome figure with the casual,
yet fashionably cut black suit, Alex accepted
him for what he was.
There was no shock, no confusion, for the
second time tonight, just a calm sense of
acceptance.
The man, probably somewhere in his mid thirties,
leaned down to peer in through the window.
He said nothing as he casually observed the
extent of Alex's injuries.
Satisfied, he laid a hand on Alex's shoulder.
The grip was firm, but not painfully so, just
strong enough to communicate, “I am here
with you.
Things'll be alright.”.
After a slight squeeze, the figure reached
inside his jacket and produced a pack of cigarettes,
packing the tobacco with swift taps against
his palm before removing two cigarettes and
offering one to Alex.
Alex nodded his head, a very small motion
that exploded pain across his shattered body.
“Nah, thank you, but that stuff will kill
you.”
Alex smiled.
The man paused for a moment, the ghost of
a smile showing on his face for just a moment
before disappearing.
Returning the offered cigarette, the man took
his own and lit it, giving Alex a good look
at his face in the light of his cigarette
lighter.
Alex had been right, the man appeared to be
somewhere in his mid to late thirties.
Handsome, but not cover model so, just pleasing
to the eyes.
He sported short hair, carefully combed and
perfectly neat, completely unaffected by the
slight drizzle that still fell.
The more Alex looked at him though, the less
he could remember about the man's exact features.
It wasn't that they changed in any way, but
rather that he simply couldn't hold on to
any details for more than a few seconds.
“I'm dying, aren't I?”.
The figure didn't speak, nor did it nod or
make any form of verbal or bodily communication.
He simply looked, and Alex understood.
Alex had never been particularly religious
or spiritual, but in that look he understood
that there was a world beyond, and one that
he would very quickly be entering into.
It was as if for the first time in his life,
he was able to probe that world, reality peeling
away just enough to glimpse what was beyond.
Twisting paths though planes of shadow and
light both, shuffling figures along each,
and at the very center of it all- a light?
No, a feeling.
Love.
Pulsing forth like the beating heart of it
all.
The saints had their angels.
The wicked, their demons.
But everyone else in between the two, they
had him.
A guide, someone to watch over them on the
final journey.
Alex coughed.
It was ending soon.
The man took a drag from his cigarette and
removed a handkerchief from another hidden
pocket, carefully dabbing away the blood around
Alex's chin, then returned to his silent smoking.
His vision was beginning to dim around the
edges, the noises of the forest growing more
and more distant.
Alex knew it wouldn't be long now, but he
had just one final thing to do.
As he always knew they would, his thoughts
returned to her here, at the end.
Once more he turned his head towards the passenger's
side seat, pain exploding across his body
with the motion.
There, just on the far edge of the seat as
his phone, having miraculously survived the
crash.
It was no good though.
Even if he'd been able to move his shattered
right arm, he could never reach it with his
fading strength.
The smoking man took one final pull of his
cigarette, putting it out on the side of the
vehicle and pocketing the stub.
Then he reached in through the broken driver's
side window, Alex catching a slight whiff
of cigarette smoke blended with an unrecognizable,
but pleasant cologne.
The man reached across Alex and grabbed the
phone, pulling back and looking down at Alex's
shattered right hand.
After a moment, he reached down once more
and put the phone in Alex's left hand.
“Thank you.”
The words were barely a whisper.
He had to concentrate now, willing the pressing
darkness to part just long enough for one
final task.
The man once more placed his hand reassuringly
on Alex's shoulder, and the darkness parted
slightly- just enough for what Alex needed
to do.
He worked the phone awkwardly with his left
hand, gritting his teeth through the pain
of broken fingers.
Opening a new message, he scrolled down his
contacts...
G...H...I...J... finally, K. He found her
name at last, then began typing out a message.
I still think about you every time it rains.
He moved his thumb to press send, but that's
when Alex's body failed him at last, the phone
tumbling out of his grasp.
But the man was there to catch it, moving
blindly fast he snatched the falling phone
up and held it carefully up to Alex's yes
before pressing Send.
He held the phone there for Alex to see through
his fading vision, until at last, Message
Sent confirmed successful delivery.
The rain began once more, temperamental as
it always is in the Pacific Northwest.
Fat, heavy rain drops fell on the scene of
a terrible accident, the victim seemingly
having died on impact.
On his lap though lay his phone, and somewhere
far away and far below this dark mountain
side, a message notification chirped on a
distant phone.
SCP-4999 manifests to only one person at a
time and only when they are alone.
All subjects to date have been in the final
stages of a terminal illness, suffering from
a life threatening injury, or otherwise on
their deathbed.
It also appears that all subjects have personalities
and lives that could be described as nondescript,
insignificant, or otherwise unremarkable.
No testing of SCP-4999 has been authorized
by the Foundation due to both the difficulty
in predicting where it will appear as well
as the fact that observation seems to prevent
the anomaly from appearing.
There are also ethical concerns, since many
in the Foundation feel that SCP-4999 is providing
an important service to humanity, even if
it is only for those on the margins of society,
and it is debated whether this should be one
anomalous creature that is allowed to continue
its existence, and its work, without interference.
What makes someone a hero?
There is never just one answer to that question.
Some will tell you that it’s selflessness,
putting other people before oneself that makes
someone heroic.
Others believe that heroism takes someone
with a clear sense of morality, the ability
to tell right from wrong with absolute certainty.
Perhaps a hero should also be a symbol, a
paragon of hope and virtue for all of society
to look up to and aspire to be.
And then there are those who would argue that
a person can’t possibly be a hero, unless
they possess one key trait.
Whether that comes as the result of a freak
accident, gamma radiation exposure, or mutated
genes, being blessed with extraordinary powers
and the will to use them for good might just
be what elevates a moral, selfless and symbolic
hero into something more.
A superhero.
It is rare that the SCP Foundation encounters
an anomalous creature or entity that it considers
to be harmless.
There are, of course, exceptions, but perhaps
even more of a rarity is an SCP that seeks
to go out of its way and use its anomalous
abilities to do good.
So many of the creatures and entities kept
contained by the Foundation have malicious
intent, like damage-regenerating reptiles
with contempt for humanity and eldritch beings
with desires to take over this dimension.
But then there is SCP-2800, or as he prefers
to call himself, “Cactusman, the Spiked
Menace.”
Partially human, and part succulent plant,
SCP-2800 is one of a rare breed of SCPs: one
that aims to help people, rather than killing
them, enslaving them, or wiping reality as
we know it from existence.
And you might be surprised to learn that this
superhero known as Cactusman, began life as
one Daniel MacIntyre, an average guy from
Scotland.
Little is known about Daniel’s “origin
story.”
All superheroes have one, of course, but as
far as Foundation researchers are aware, Cactusman
wasn’t jettisoned in a pod from his dying
homeworld to the safety of Earth.
It is also safe to assume he didn’t get
pricked by a radioactive cactus, or have his
DNA infused with a plant during a genetic
experiment.
He was first encountered by the SCP Foundation
whilst they were trying to contain another
SCP, a reality warping object that had somehow
breached containment.
What Foundation staff tracking the object
witnessed was Cactusman attempting to assault
the escaped SCP, to little success.
Following this encounter, Foundation personnel
convinced Cactusman to allow them to contain
him.
He complied, was designated as SCP-2800, and
researchers began investigating the nature
of this strange, would-be superhero.
According to Daniel, one day his powers just
“happened”, with little understanding
as to how, why, or what had caused the transformation.
When asked about how he acquired his powers
during an interview with SCP Foundation researcher
Dr L'oeuf, Daniel said:
“To be honest, doc, I dunno.
I woke up one day, and boom, cactus powers.
Thought that I might as well use them for
good, right?
I always grew up reading a lot of comic books.
Always loved the X-Men as a little kid, so
I thought I was one of them.
Heh.
I thought I was the luckiest guy in the world,
ending up with superpowers.
Doesn't every kid wish that they could be
a superhero?”
Analysis by Foundation research staff revealed
that Daniel’s DNA had somehow merged with
a genome of a Carnegiea gigantea plant, or
saguaro cactus.
This plant is usually what most people picture
if they were to imagine a typical cactus,
and is known to be native to the Sonoran Desert,
as well as the Mexican state of Sonora.
How one became a part of Daniel McIntyre’s
genetic makeup is baffling.
It seems highly unlikely that a saguaro cactus
would grow naturally in Scotland, given that
the country has a far damper and colder climate
than the scorching hot deserts that saguaros
normally thrive in.
Regardless of exactly how Daniel became fused
with a cactus, his body shares a number of
the same physical properties of the plant.
Pointed spines protrude from his skin, which
can grow to just over an inch in length.
It seems that SCP-2800 can either remove these
spikes manually with little pain, or will
eventually shed them naturally over time,
allowing more to regrow in their place.
As well as outwardly looking like an anthropomorphic
cactus, SCP-2800 also shares various biological
traits with his cacti counterparts.
Daniel’s body no longer functions in the
same way as that of an ordinary human being
in a number of different ways.
Firstly, he is able to perform photosynthesis,
deriving the necessary nutrients he requires
from direct sunlight.
This negates the need for him to consume any
food, and prevents him from feeling hunger
or the fatigue this can often bring.
Additionally, his altered biology allows Cactusman
to store more water than would normally be
possible for the average human.
And he requires less of it too.
SCP-2800 is able to keep himself hydrated
with a third of the required fluids for an
average person.
Daniel can also adapt to more arid environments,
with drier climates and above average levels
of heat having little impact on his abilities.
Speaking of abilities, SCP-2800 is not just
a man with the physical and biological traits
of a saguaro cactus - he also has superpowers
that seem, well let’s say inspired by a
cactus.
While perhaps not as flashy as being faster
than a speeding bullet, more powerful than
a locomotive, or able to leap tall buildings
in a single bound, Cactusman does possess
his own unique set of superhuman abilities.
Derived, like his other traits, from his part-saguaro
DNA, SCP-2800 has the power to empathically
communicate with other plant life.
Unlike telepathy and the ability to communicate
solely through thoughts, empaths like Cactusman
are able to influence or interpret the emotions
or moods of others, so similar but a little
more subtle in its effectiveness.
Cactusman might have superhuman powers, altered
DNA, and a mysterious origin, but another
part of a hero’s journey is their struggle
and SCP-2800 is no exception to this either.
Despite his desire to do good, he harbors
a lot of unrest under that prickly exterior.
After extensive psychological examination
by the researchers at the SCP Foundation,
Daniel was diagnosed with two distinct mental
disorders.
The first of these is dysthymia, or chronic
depression, with the other being a condition
colloquially known as “hero syndrome.”
Hero syndrome, as its name suggests, is often
characterized by an unstoppable, pathological
urge to help other people, usually ignoring
any risks to oneself in the pursuit of assisting
even total strangers.
Some with this disorder will even attempt
to manufacture dangerous scenarios in order
to act like the hero, and earn themselves
recognition and praise for reacting heroically
to the danger they secretly caused.
Like committing arson so they can save people
from a burning building.
SCP-2800 has never attempted anything like
this so far, but Cactusman does express an
extreme willingness to help people, and try
to intervene in any situation that he thinks
he can assist with.
The problem is, SCP-2800 is hardly an experienced
crimefighter, and this has put him on the
receiving end of his fair share of injuries.
During his first outing as “Cactusman, the
Spiked Menace”, Daniel encountered a group
engaging in the sale of illicit substances
and attempted to apprehend them.
While he was able to deal a cactus-spine-filled
blow to one of their faces, the group quickly
overpowered Cactusman and beat him until local
law enforcement arrived to save him.
Determined to prove himself a hero, though,
Daniel returned to patrolling the streets
soon after, but met the same result.
Even weak, petty criminals seemed like they
were too much for Cactusman to handle.
While his hero syndrome compels SCP-2800 to
want to do good and set a good example, it
is also directly linked to his other condition:
His dysthymia.
By attempting and failing to be heroic, Cactusman
becomes chronically depressed, yet still has
the urges brought on by his hero syndrome
to put himself in harm’s way for the sake
of others.
And when he is unable to provide help, Daniel
falls back into depression.
It’s a very difficult cycle.
In the hopes of counteracting some of Daniel’s
struggles, the SCP Foundation have gifted
him a pair of potted cacti.
These occupy SCP-2800’s cell with him, both
oxygenating his room as well as boosting his
morale.
Although, he has remarked that cacti don’t
say much to him beyond “I'm thirsty” and
“I am a cactus”, Daniel has affectionately
named his potted plants.
They’re now known as Cactilad and Spikigirl,
his sidekicks in the never ending battle against
evil.
During interviews with Foundation researcher
Dr L'oeuf, Daniel admitted that he was the
victim of bullying throughout much of his
childhood.
From a young age he often found himself in
physical altercations with bullies that singled
him out and picked on him at school.
Cactusman said that his experiences encouraged
him to “give back”, and that despite having
suffered at the hands of bullies, it made
SCP-2800 determined to help others in need.
In his own words, Daniel didn’t want what
had happened to him to happen to anybody else
and it is highly likely that these experiences
from his youth are at least part of the cause
of his hero syndrome.
However, another incident may also be linked
to SCP-2800’s condition.
Despite not often prevailing against petty
criminals, there is CCTV surveillance footage
of Cactusman from before his containment by
the SCP Foundation.
The footage in question was taken at a subway
close to where Daniel “patrolled” and
looked for criminals to apprehend.
In the surveillance tape, a woman and her
child can be seen waiting at the subway station
near a support pillar.
From behind the pillar, an assailant in a
mask appeared, wielding what looked to be
a knife.
The woman, cowering and trying to protect
her child, was made to open her purse, as
the attacker threatened her with his knife.
But then, Cactusman appears behind the man.
He walked up to him and punched him in his
lower back and chest.
A number of SCP-2800’s sharp cacti spines
end up lodged in the man’s skin, causing
him to drop his knife in pain.
During the ensuing scuffle, SCP-2800 was able
to tie the man up, thus saving the woman and
her child.
The woman then thanked Cactusman, shaking
his hand and embracing him.
Her child also expressed gratitude, with SCP-2800
kneeling down to face them and appearing to
get emotional at receiving recognition.
After signing an autograph for the child,
Cactusman then disappeared from the scene
before police arrived.
Cacti have the tenacity to grow in barren
desert environments, surviving on very little
water.
It is for that reason, that to some, these
plants have come to symbolize strength, resilience,
and endurance.
This one encounter captured in this surveillance
footage may well have been one of the few
times Cactusman ever succeeded at being heroic,
but perhaps it is all he needed to encourage
him to keep trying.
To seek out wrongdoings time and time again,
even if it led to him being injured.
Maybe knowing that just once he had succeeded
in saving a woman and her child, was enough
to convince him that he would one day be able
to do so again.
And maybe that is what makes someone a true
hero: The power to endure.
A tangled mass of yarn and ribbon sounds more
like what you’d find in the back room of
a craft store or a forgotten closet than a
mysterious creature worthy of investigation.
And yet that’s exactly what SCP-066 appeared
to be, or at least it did at first glance.
But the SCP Foundation doesn’t contain and
study just anything, and there was - and still
is - something incredibly strange just below
the surface of SCP-066, also known as “Eric’s
Toy.”
At first, Eric’s Toy seemed to be completely
harmless and even helpful, a knot of string
that produced strange but harmless items and
effects.
But, the Foundation soon discovered a dark
side to SCP-066.
While it may be referred to as a toy, this
is no mere plaything.
SCP-066 weighs only about one kilogram and
appears to be a braided bunch of yarn and
ribbon.
Though there is no apparent musical capability
within the strands of yarn and ribbon themselves,
music can be produced by moving individual
strands one at a time.
When it was first being studied, this SCP
was composed of multicolored strings and ribbons,
but it has since undergone a transformation
and now presents an appearance somewhat different
from its initial description.
The strands of yarn and ribbon can be used
to play the notes of a diatonic scale - C-D-E-F-G-A-B
- though the research has not been able to
determine just how SCP-066 produces music,
or any sound at all.
SCP-066 was thought to be completely benign
at first and was classified as Safe, but following
an incident known as Incident 066-2, its classification
was adjusted to a subcategory of Euclid: Euclid-impetus.
Euclid is a classification given to SCPs that
are more difficult to contain than those classified
as “Safe.”
Impetus, in Latin, means “attack” and
specifies that SCP-066 is not only Euclid
class, but on the more aggressive side.
While 066 is not always aggressive toward
humans, the events of Incident 066-2 proved
that it is highly unpredictable, and should
not be provoked.
Like many SCPs, it proved that underestimating
its capabilities can be a dangerous mistake.
Before the incident, SCP-066 displayed only
charming, if unusual, behavior.
Various researchers spent their time playing
random assortments of notes using its strings,
curious about what would happen and determined
to record anything this unusual ball of string
had to offer.
They did not yet know that the creature was
capable of any hostility, and went about their
work with a lighthearted, carefree spirit.
After playing an improvised six-note melody
with the strands, a researcher was thrilled
to find that SCP-066 was capable of shapeshifting.
Its appearance changed to resemble a small
calico kitten for seventeen minutes.
The kitten was incredibly friendly, rubbing
its head against the researcher’s gloved
hand and purring loudly.
Ironically enough, the kitten also spent time
playing with a piece of string.
After the seventeen minutes were up, the kitten
transformed back into SCP-066’s original
form.
A few days later, another researcher played
a different melody on the strands, and was
surprised to find that, when they stopped,
the music continued on its own.
The sound of an acoustic guitar kicked in,
accompanied by vocals, with no visible source
for either sound.
The SCP then played a four-minute song with
lyrics warning against the use of sharp objects
without the supervision of a parent, especially
scissors.
After the song ended, the SCP was silent for
the rest of the day.
The following week, a research assistant used
the strands of SCP-066 to play the opening
notes of “Happy Birthday,” and a chocolate
cupcake with a lit birthday candle appeared
from within the braided strings.
Against the warnings of his peers, the assistant
ate the cupcake.
In response, the SCP played the rest of “Happy
Birthday,” and the assistant suffered no
adverse effects from the cupcake.
All of this fun was brought to a swift end
when one scientist suggested that a portion
of SCP-066’s yarn body be cut off and removed
so that the specimen could be tested.
On April 18, 2008, the event that would become
known as Incident 066-2 took place.
A young man known only as D-066-4437, or D,
was assigned to the task.
Naturally, he was a member of the highly disposable
D Class personnel.
But D was grateful for the opportunity, as
most experiments of a similar nature involved
quite a bit more obvious risk.
It was a simple enough job: take a pair of
scissors, snip off some yarn, and bring it
back to the lab for further study.
It was hardly on the level of supervising
173 or being 682’s latest chew toy.
He entered the containment room, where SCP-066
was lying dormant and still, and approached
it with the scissors.
He grabbed a small handful of string, and
started to cut.
As soon as the scissors began to cut through
the fabric, the SCP rolled out of his grasp.
It came to a stop one meter away, where it
started to make a high-pitched squeaking sound
resembling the cry of a frightened rabbit.
Unsure what to do and unprepared for this
scenario, D approached the entity again.
He snagged another fistful of yarn and cut,
only for 066 to curl into a ball and roll
away from him again, even faster this time.
Once it was safely on the other side of the
room and away from the scissors it stopped
moving.
Only this time it didn't squeak.
Instead, for the very first time since its
containment, it spoke in a deep, uncannily
human voice and asked: “Are you Eric?”
After recovering from his initial shock at
hearing a voice come out of a mass of string,
D responded “No, I’m not.”
This answer set something off in SCP-066,
and its form began to shift and change.
The string wriggled around on the floor, unbraiding
and wrapping around itself into a mound.
The colors, previously a rainbow of shades,
shifted until every strand was blood red.
Much to D’s horror, the transformation was
not yet complete.
Small bumps began to emerge from the spaces
between the strands of yarn, popping out all
over the bright red mass.
If that wasn’t terrifying enough, suddenly
all together as one, they blinked open, revealing
themselves to be over a dozen small eyes.
Every single eye was focused at D, studying
him, staring him down.
SCP-066 then began to produce loud, abrupt,
dissonant notes like someone banging on the
keys of a piano.
D had seen enough.
He abandoned his task and fled the containment
room.
After this failed attempt to extract a sample,
SCP-066’s behavior and its treatment of
personnel who interacted with it began to
change dramatically.
Before the incident, the SCP was largely dormant,
only becoming active if a melody was played
using its strands.
Following the incident, and its change of
form, 066 began to move on its own.
Long strands of its yarn body would move like
tentacles, writhing and wriggling around at
a high speed.
It no longer needed human interaction in order
to produce sound, or to produce any other
effects.
At the sight of any human, regardless of the
human’s behavior, the SCP would begin to
react with sound and effect within six seconds.
The first of these effects was noted by a
research assistant who entered the SCP’s
containment facility a week after the incident
with D. As she approached 066 to take notes
about its current state and its new ability
to move, a bee appeared out of nowhere.
It stung the assistant and flew away before
it could be captured.
Weeks later, a team of eleven personnel were
monitoring the SCP when it suddenly burst
into a rendition of Beethoven’s second symphony.
It produced this music at a volume of over
140 decibels, permanently deafening three
of the personnel, and causing permanent hearing
damage in the other eight.
It was theorized that the SCP did this as
an act of retribution for its perceived mistreatment.
These personnel refused to work with SCP-066
again.
When a new team was assigned to monitor the
entity, everything seemed to be going well
at first.
It was moving around, flailing its tentacles
of yarn at nothing in particular, and staring
at the personnel with its many eyes, but otherwise
was on its best behavior.
Then, suddenly, every light in the room went
dark, and there was a complete loss of visibility.
The lights were unable to be turned on for
five hours, and any attempt at an alternate
light source such as a flashlight was unsuccessful.
It was as if the darkness in the room swallowed
any and all light right up.
It was similar to the oppressive darkness
within SCP – 087, or the unlimited black
of SCP – 3001’s shadow dimension.
The personnel in the room later reported hearing
the sound of loud, labored breathing just
behind their shoulders, though when they searched
for a source of the sound, they could find
nothing.
There have been no recent anomalies reported,
or any additional hostile behavior.
Instead, whenever it sees a new human, SCP-066
repeats the name “Eric” again and again
in that same deep voice.
Who is Eric?
No one at the facility knows, or, if they
do, they have not reported it to any official
channels.
It is possible that the SCP was once owned
by someone named Eric and perhaps, given the
circumstances under which SCP-066 first said
the name, Eric attempted to cut the threads
of the entity while it was in his care.
Unfortunately, there are no official records
of how SCP-066 was discovered, or why it was
brought to the foundation in the first place.
Its origins remain murky and as mysterious
as everything else about it.
All that is known is that, whoever Eric is,
SCP-066 is determined to find him.
Once the SCP’s class was changed from Safe
to Euclid, its containment procedures had
to be adjusted.
While it was previously kept in a simple room,
it is now contained in a tungsten carbide
box at its site’s high-value item storage
facility.
Once a month, the box is inspected for damage
to its interior, due to the SCP’s tendency
to use its appendages to wear down the walls
of the box over time.
If there is any damage, SCP-066 is to be moved
to a new box using a robotic arm that performs
this transfer in less than three seconds.
The Foundation has attempted to place recording
devices in the box with the entity in order
to monitor its behavior when there are no
humans present.
But the SCP destroys every recording device
placed inside of its containment box and any
attempts to record its behavior when it is
not being observed by humans have been unsuccessful.
Whatever it’s doing when there is no one
around it wants to keep a secret.
On the surface, SCP-066 is one of the less
frightening finds contained within the walls
of the SCP Foundation.
It does not have claws, or teeth, or the ability
to cause mass deaths, but it has incredible,
unpredictable capabilities, and seems very
capable of holding a grudge.
There is so much that is unknown about it,
from its origins, to its form, to its ability
to manifest matter from nothing, and there
is something deeply unsettling about this
SCP’s unpredictable behavior and increased
hostility toward being observed.
We do not know what it has done, and we do
not know what it will do next.
All we can do is wonder.
As we ponder the nature of SCP-066, it does
nothing but sit, staring with unblinking eyes,
waiting for Eric to come back.
Are you sitting comfortably?
We know a good chair is hard to find.
Maybe you’re watching this on your phone
while you lie in bed, or maybe you’re watching
it at your desk, sitting in an office chair.
Maybe you’re even watching it while you’re
in the bathroom; it’s fine, we’re not
here to judge.
For our money, you just can’t beat a nice,
classic wooden chair, with soft leather upholstery.
Call us old-fashioned, but some things just
never go out of style.
Take a chair like SCP-1609, for example.
This fine piece of mahogany was once a chair
that simply couldn’t be beat in its quest
to bring its users a little dose of comfort
and refinement in their daily life.
Tell us, have you ever been on your feet all
day, just walking and walking and walking,
and at a certain point, you’re just begging
for a nice, comfy chair that’ll let you
take the weight off your feet for a little
while?
You would have been SCP-1609’s favorite
kind of person.
After all, it was the only chair that literally
sought out weary travelers, and even did you
the courtesy of tucking itself in.
That’s not a metaphor, either.
SCP-1609 could literally teleport to nearby
people who needed to sit down and didn’t
have a chair to fulfill that desire.
It was nothing but a nice, helpful anomaly
that wanted to help people rest when they
needed it most.
The more observant members of you may have
noticed that we’ve been using the past tense
so far.
That’s because, while SCP-1609 is still
an active anomaly, it isn’t a chair anymore
- and this transformation wasn’t something
that SCP-1609 planned, anticipated, or even
wanted.
The story of 1609’s transformation even
strikes to the core of one of the Foundation’s
oldest and most bitterly held rivalries with
another group of interest.
It’s the tale of how a helpful piece of
anomalous furniture became a paranoid killer.
But first, we need to talk about containment
procedures.
Like a word you see so often that it starts
to lose meaning, containment and specific
containment procedures are concepts so integral
to the very existence of the SCP Foundation
that it’s easy to overlook or forget about
them.
They’re one of the three core pillars of
the Foundation’s mission statement - Secure,
Contain, Protect.
Because of the centrality of containment to
the Foundation’s core principles, one of
the most valuable roles on the SCP Foundation
payroll is that of the Containment Specialist:
A vast team of experts who work with researchers
to figure out the best way to keep every anomaly
contained, based on their unique abilities
and attributes.
They’re zookeepers, archivists, guards,
security and intelligence experts, magicians,
practitioners of ritual, scientists, and so
much more.
In short, they’re anything they need to
be in order to adapt to the ever-evolving
containment needs of the anomalies they keep
under lock and key.
And containment isn’t easy.
Aside from the rare Safe-class SCPs, which
require incredibly minimal containment resources,
the containment of most SCPs extracts some
kind of cost, whether that be financial, time,
effort, or in some particularly dark cases,
human life.
Some SCPs, like SCP-974 and SCP-2845, require
the sacrifice of human children to prevent
worse fates befalling many others.
Other SCPs, like the infamous SCP-231, require
the Foundation to do horrifying things to
the SCP itself to prevent it from manifesting
some even more horrifying anomalous traits.
And a third but equally inconvenient kind
of SCP, like SCP-682 and SCP-076, require
huge numbers of heavily armed guards with
powerful weapons to keep their deadly prisoners
locked away, often at massive risk to their
own lives.
Containment isn’t easy, but it’s ultimately
the very thing that makes the SCP Foundation
the organization it is.
If they were instead on a quest to kill and
destroy every anomaly they could get their
hands on, then, they’d be the Global Occult
Coalition - the UN’s answer to the SCP Foundation
that prefers to seek, disable, and destroy
rather than Secure, Contain, and Protect.
It’s the primary characteristic that differentiates
these two titans of the anomalous world who
regularly come to blows, and right at the
heart of that difference is SCP-1609.
As we mentioned earlier, SCP-1609 went through
a transformation that changed everything,
but the SCP Foundation never actually knew
about the anomaly prior to that transformation
taking place.
It first came to their attention when it literally
manifested within a containment cell in Storage
Site-08, making the rare move of willingly
submitting itself to Foundation containment.
But what showed up in that cell certainly
wasn’t a chair.
When 1609 appeared all it looked like was
a pile of trash - specifically, splinters,
wood chippings, furniture nails, and scraps
of bleached leather and fabric.
Anything that suddenly infiltrates a secure
Foundation containment site is a cause for
concern, even a bunch of wood scraps, so the
Site Director sent in an armed guard to investigate
the mysterious pile of debris.
Researchers watching over a surveillance feed
were surprised when the guard suddenly entered
a state of heightened distress.
He fell to his knees, coughing and spluttering
until he expelled a considerable amount of
blood from his mouth and nose.
He then collapsed onto the ground next to
the pile of debris, dead.
An investigation following this incident found
that the guard had died after a sudden influx
of jagged metal and wood had teleported inside
of him, tearing his lungs apart from the inside
and causing the guard to die a painful and
horrific death.
Naturally, the site personnel were somewhat
concerned by this development.
They sent in a D-Class to investigate further,
but were surprised to find that the D-Class
in question was somehow completely fine.
The pile of debris that would soon be designated
SCP-1609 made no attempt to harm the D-Class
as it had the guard, and finding out why this
was the case came as a side effect of figuring
out exactly what had happened to SCP-1609.
Through a rigorous investigation, involving
more than one secret Foundation mole, they
discovered that SCP-1609 had previously been
in the possession of - you guessed it - the
Global Occult Coalition.
Back then, it was just the helpful chair you
once knew and loved, until the GOC had the
bright idea of forcing it into a woodchipper
in order to destroy it due to its connection
to someone called The Carpenter.
But all the GOC’s attempt actually succeeded
in doing was altering its form, and completely
changing its personality.
To put it in simple terms, SCP-1609 is now
a pile of possibly-sentient, teleporting wood
and metal chippings that suffers from a nasty
case of PTSD.
The incident with the wood chipper traumatized
SCP-1609, and its anxiety is triggered by
anything that reminds it of the GOC or the
wood chipper incident - this includes wearing
formal clothing, lab coats, protective clothing,
jumpsuits, and particularly body armor, but
also includes anyone carrying weapons, appearing
outwardly aggressive, using common GOC lingo,
or even mentioning the GOC in SCP-1609’s
proximity.
If any of this happens, it’s extremely likely
that SCP-1609 will resort to its only natural
defense mechanism, which is teleporting its
debris into the lungs of anyone it considers
to be a threat.
The guard had received this grisly punishment
because his clothes, weapon, and overall manner
caused SCP-1609 to regard him as a threat
and react accordingly.
You may think this is overkill on 1609’s
part, but if you were just trying to help
out the chairless people of the world and
someone fed you into a wood chipper, you’d
probably be a little jumpy too.
Since these early days, the Foundation has
learned to apply a more tender touch when
it comes to dealing with SCP-1609, and the
brilliant containment specialists even figured
out a way to keep 1609 happily contained…
by placing it in a flower bed inside its containment
chamber where its wood chips get to serve
as mulch for a variety of flowers and plants.
All attending researchers and guards dress
in plain clothes, and adopt a loose, pleasant
attitude while inside.
Whenever they’re around, they make a point
of saying how beautiful the flower bed is,
so that the disfigured anomaly that only ever
wanted to be helpful can still feel like it’s
doing something nice.
Because of these containment procedures, breaches
involving SCP-1609 have remained in the single
digits.
It’s a perfect example of less really being
more when it comes to containment.
The head researcher on the SCP-1609 case,
Dr. Sievert, released an internal document,
permanently affixed to the file like a kind
of cautionary signpost.
It’s a clear expression of exasperation
and rage at the actions of the Global Occult
Coalition, reading:
“SCP-1609 represents a perfect example of
the flaws inherent in the operating procedure
of the GOC, and serves as a cautionary tale
for any members of the Foundation who disagree
with our practices on containing dangerous
objects.
Prior to the Coalition getting their hands
on this, it was perfectly harmless.
A chair which teleports to you when you need
a seat is normal compared to most of the stuff
that we deal with on a regular basis.
When they put it through a woodchipper, it
got hurt, scared and angry, so it lashed out
at them.
By trying to 'protect the world' by destroying
it, they inadvertently made the situation
a whole lot worse.
SCP-1609 went from being harmless to deadly
in the space of a few minutes because of the
GOC, and we had to clean up the mess.
Thankfully, SCP-1609 is pretty simple for
us to deal with.
So long as we don't do anything stupid around
it, it won't fight back and it won't try to
leave.
Even if it does, it usually comes back.
I think I've worked out why.
It came to us because it was afraid of the
people who had hurt it.
That's why it always comes back.
It's afraid of the rest of the world now,
and it's looking to us for protection.
This is why we have Special Containment Procedures
instead of Special Destruction Procedures.
If you break something, it's broken forever.
When you try to destroy an anomaly, you can't
take back your mistakes.
That's what SCP-1609 has to tell us.
This is why we're right and the GOC is wrong,
people.”
But of course, there are two sides to every
story, and it’s important to understand
the GOC’s perspective on this whole mess.
To them, this has never been SCP-1609, it’s
KTE-0937-Velveteen, aka The Sixth Chair.
It was labeled as the “sixth” because
for the GOC, this chair was merely one part
of a wider investigation.
It belonged to a six piece furniture set created
by a dangerous, anomalous person of interest
named The Carpenter for a classified customer.
The GOC was able to intercept this deal, and
kill the Carpenter and his customer in the
process.
After that, all that was left was to eliminate
the anomalous objects and five of them were
incinerated without incident.
However, before they could do the same to
the Sixth Chair, they experienced an incinerator
malfunction.
Rather than waiting for the incinerator to
be fixed, a member of GOC personnel decided
to rush the job and run the chair through
the woodchipper.
It was at this point that its pieces first
lashed out, invading the lungs of this negligent
GOC member along with five others, killing
them all.
It was shortly after that that SCP-1609 manifested
in Foundation containment.
Much like Dr. Sievert did for the Foundation,
Assistant Director Kipling, one of the GOC’s
legion of middle managers, affixed a note
to the profile on KTE-0937-Velveteen that
reads:
“KTE-0937-Velveteen is an object lesson
in the importance of following proper operating
procedures.
Due to the lack of vigilance by the agent
on the scene, the object's threat level was
escalated, the object itself was not successfully
disposed of, and it has since fallen into
the hands of a hostile agency.
A single failure by a single operative resulted
in the deaths of six.
Remember this the next time you think about
cutting corners.”
And that’s a good lesson for everyone.
Whether you’re trying to destroy an anomalous
piece of furniture or keeping its remains
happy so that they don’t try to kill you,
cutting corners is always a fast track to
failure.
In June of 1985, Mark Johnson and his wife
of ten years, Sophie, were on vacation in
Myrtle Beach having a great time.
While they relaxed on the sand, Sophie decided
to take a picture of her husband for their
scrapbook, so she pulled out the Polaroid
Supercolor 645 that she'd bought specifically
for the trip.
She pressed the button, waited for the picture
to print, pulled it out, and shook it.
What she expected to see was a shot of Mark
lying on his beach towel.
What she got, was a picture of her husband
in the arms of his secretary.
They say that a picture speaks a thousand
words, but this particular camera takes pictures
that are worth even more than that.
When developed, the pictures taken with this
normal-looking polaroid camera reveal the
innermost desires of the person being photographed.
Welcome to the story of SCP - 978 - The Desire
Camera.
The main reason the foundation keeps SCP 978
under wraps is due to its use as an easy form
of blackmail.
All anyone with access to the camera would
have to do is snap a few covert photos and
they'd have instant dirt on the world's most
powerful people.
To further stop this camera from falling into
the wrong hands, the containment guidelines
strictly forbid the use of the camera for
anything other than simple documentation,
and all uses of it must be thoroughly logged
and checked.
So, now that you know what the camera does,
it’s time to look at what kinds of strange
and mysterious photos it’s taken.
After all, who doesn't want a chance to gain
insight into the minds of the Foundation's
most famous and dangerous inmates?
First, to serve as a control the team took
a photo of a blue office chair.
No change was recorded, proving that the camera
didn't work on non-anomalous inanimate objects.
Some of the earliest tests of the camera were
the photos that the research team took of
each other.
One by one, the doctors and their assistants
were photographed in neutral poses, smiling
as if for a completely normal photo, then
they waited while the photos developed like
normal polaroids.
Most of the research team had minimal changes
in their photos.
One was shown slouched in his chair, drinking
from a flask.
One was shown in her civilian clothes, getting
ready to go home from work.
One doctor was in the exact same pose, but
with a different colored tie on.
The last assistant photographed, however,
had their picture come out wildly different
than how they were posed.
Their desire revealed by the camera was so
shocking that it had to be redacted, and the
assistant was placed on temporary psychiatric
leave.
Following this first successful test, the
doctor in charge of the project ordered a
second round of tests to be conducted, this
time on a series of D-class personnel.
A picture of one D-class, who was photographed
while eating in the cafeteria, showed up as
scuba diving on vacation with his wife and
child.
He was allowed to keep the picture afterwards.
Another had a similar result - he was photographed
in a neutral pose like the members of the
research team had been, and when the picture
developed, the D-Class was seen holding a
smiling baby whom he identified as his one-year-old
daughter.
After that, the results of the SCP - 978 tests
started to get a little… well, weird.
A notoriously twisted D-class known as 7294
was photographed in his cell, and when the
polaroid developed, he was in the same cell,
playing a cello made out of a dismembered
mannequin.
D-217-017, was a late stage victim of SCP-217,
a virus that turns organic matter into metal.
You would assume that her innermost desire
would be to be cured of her disease, but when
she was photographed in her cell, the resulting
polaroid showed her completely made of metal,
kneeling and praying at the base of a black
obelisk.
One D-class, who had been rendered comatose
and was on life support, was photographed
in their hospital room.
Their picture showed them as only a limp,
deflated skin in their photo.
The photograph of another D-class, who had
become increasingly listless and apathetic
since their integration into the D-class program,
resulted in a picture that was exactly the
same as they appeared in reality, except the
light in their cell was slightly dimmer.
Intrigued by these results, the research team
wanted to see how the camera would react to
SCP-148, a type of metal that blocks the psychic
properties of other SCPs.
A helmet was made from the material, and placed
on a D-class who was given an adult magazine
to read while his photo was taken.
When the photo was developed, it was extremely
blurry.
Upon close analysis, the figure of the D-class
reading the magazine could still be made out,
and around him the faint images of several
nude people could also be seen.
The research team next wanted to see if the
results were the same when the camera was
used on animals.
Photos of the lab mice and rabbits showed
them eating or mating in their respective
polaroids.
A zebra finch was shown escaping its cage,
while a guard dog and its handler were shown
playing fetch in the park.
When cockroaches were photographed, there
was no difference visible between the picture
and reality.
But the most exciting test results came when
the camera was tested on other SCPs.
For a few of the SCPs tested, there was no
visible difference between the picture and
reality.
This was the case for SCP-173 the Sculpture,
SCP-343 nicknamed God, SCP-014 - an immortal
man who is, over time, being turned into concrete,
and SCP-063 - the world's best toothbrush.
When SCP-035 - better known as the Possessive
Mask - was photographed in its glass case,
the picture showed an unidentified individual
wearing the mask, sitting on a throne and
surrounded by three masked corpses.
The team took a picture of SCP-043 - a haunted
copy of The White Album that was being interrogated
while on a turntable.
In the picture, the album was being returned
to its sleeve.
They then photographed SCP-049, the Plague
Doctor, standing in his cell.
In the picture, the plague doctor is hugging
an unidentified small child, and surrounded
by instances of SCP-049-2.
When they took a picture of SCP-050 - a mischievous
statue of a monkey reading a book - the result
was predictably playful, given that SCP's
history of pulling pranks.
The photo that came out of the camera showed
the camera itself, with another picture of
itself coming out of the developing slot.
Microscopic analysis revealed that this recursive
photography kept going until the cameras in
the pictures of the other cameras were too
small to see.
The team next photographed SCP-053, the young
girl and the photo was taken as the young
girl was drawing with crayons in her cell.
In the picture, she was riding through a sunny
field on the back of her friend SCP-682.
SCP-053 and SCP-682 were even wearing matching
bows, dresses, and pink nail polish.
When they took a picture of SCP-096 - the
Shy Guy though, the picture showed SCP-096's
cell with nothing in it.
SCP-085 - the living 2D sketch known as Cassy
- was photographed tinkering with a drawn
car.
In the developed photo, Cassy was engaged
in the same activity, but both she and the
car were now 3-dimensional.
The team took a photo of SCP-106, the Old
Man, emerging from a wall within his cell.
When the photo developed, it showed the old
man roaming a wheat field near an old farmhouse.
From the porch of the farm house, an older
woman is greeting SCP-106 with open arms.
They also took a photo of SCP-168 - a sentient
calculator - sitting on a table in its containment
cell.
In the picture, a teenage boy is seen doing
complex math homework using the calculator.
Next to him on the table are thick textbooks
with titles like "Complicated Math", "Difficult
Math", and "Math You Need Your Calculator
For".
The photo of SCP-261 - a vending machine that
dispenses snack products from alternate universes
- showed the SCP in its usual hallway, almost
completely buried in coins.
SCP-507, an otherwise normal man who unwillingly
teleports between dimensions, was photographed
while eating in the cafeteria.
The developed picture showed him dressed as
a Foundation researcher, talking to other
researchers.
When SCP-682 was photographed, floating in
its containment tank, the resulting picture
showed the SCP surrounded by the corpses of
all of the Foundation staff and mauling the
person who had taken the photo.
A researcher’s note accompanying this photo
reads “Well, that was predictable.”
Yes.
Yes it was.
Just for fun of it, the team also tested the
camera's effects on a few other Foundation
personnel.
They took a photo of Dr. Bright while he was
arguing with Dr. Clef.
The picture that came out showed a tombstone
engraved with the words "Jack Bright, Resting
at Last."
The team also took a photo of Dr. Clef as
he stormed out in a huff following the argument.
Given that Clef's face cannot be photographed,
they were curious as to what the results would
be.
The picture showed little difference compared
to reality, save for the fact that Clef's
head was replaced by an image of a hand making
a rude gesture.
Upon closer examination of the photo, the
team also realized that there was a young
girl in the background who, strangely, has
cloven hooves instead of feet.
A young SCP-166 perhaps?
The team then took a photo of Dr. Fisher holding
his pet hamster.
Contrary to expectation, the picture revealed
not Dr. Fisher's desires, but the hamster's,
showing the hamster sleeping peacefully in
its cage… with Dr. Fisher nowhere to be
seen.
As you can see from these test logs, the effects
of the camera are, well, inconsistent.
With some photos showing very immediate, simple
whims, and others showing the subject's deepest
and most secret desires.
While the researchers working with SCP-978
seemed like they had a lot of fun getting
to peek into the minds of all their coworkers
and test subjects, there's no telling what
kind of pandemonium could be unleashed if
someone on the outside ever got a chance to
use it.
Thankfully the camera, which has been classified
as safe for obvious reasons, is kept securely
in security locker H-J-12 at site 17.
Which means none of us have to worry about
our own pictures taken by the Desire Camera
leaking out.
But if someone did get the camera out and
took your picture, what do you think they’d
see?
SCP-682 had escaped containment, and it was
all hands on deck at the SCP Foundation to
try and stop the creature's rampage.
All unarmed personnel were running to escape
before 682 had a chance to rip them apart,
as the security team bravely fought to incapacitate
the hard-to-destroy reptile long enough to
return him to his acid tank. 682 was on an
all-out offensive, stomping through the SCP's
item gallery and spewing acid at anyone who
came within range.
People, items, and parts of the room alike
were melting and sizzling as 682 attacked.
It was an absolute bloodbath, and you'd have
to have been insane to try and fight back
against it. However, one being remained unfazed
by the chaos, and stood proud in the face
of the omnicidal monster. It was another SCP,
one who had been broken free from its glass
display case in the commotion.
“Who dares to disturb the Prime Minister
Sinister?” It said, in a high tinny voice.
“I shall rip your eyes from their sockets
and force you to eat them!”
SCP 682 stopped to see who had threatened
him. It was almost laughable that this thing
had dared to make such a violent threat, because
there was no way that this little thing would
be able to stand up to the unkillable 682.
But its size didn't stop it from trying to
pick a fight all the same.
The SCP was a tiny robot made from junk, which
looked more like a sculpture made from scrap
that was found on the side of the road than
a functional automaton. Its head was made
of an upside down voltmeter, giving it the
appearance of a smiling face, and its arms
were made of wrenches. It was capable of walking
around, though it seemed to have difficulty
moving, as it was very top heavy.
It shook its rusty fist at SCP 682 and continued
to threaten him, shouting - "You do not know
the fury you have unleashed! RoboLord the
Destructor will end you!"
SCP 682 swiped at the robot, annoyed by its
continued attempts to antagonize him. The
robot toppled over and struggled to stand
again, but when it did, it ran for 682's feet.
It started to grab at 682's toes, hitting
them with its wrench hands. As you might expect,
this had almost no effect on 682.
"You do realize…you are…weak…pathetic"
said 682, raising his claw to get a better
look at the annoying little robot.
It responded- "Lies and slander! The Mayor
of Mayhem is the most powerful being in existence!"
before promptly losing its grip on 682's claw
and falling to the floor.
Now 682 was really getting tired of this thing.
He prepared to swipe at it again, this time
using his full strength, which would certainly
smash the robot to pieces. But, luckily for
the robot, its pestering had distracted 682
just long enough for Foundation security to
sneak up on him.
Before 682 had a chance to smash the robot,
the Foundation fired on him with a volley
of rockets, reducing him to a misshapen lump.
The security team collected up 682's remains,
ready to put them into a backup acid tank,
but the task was made slightly more difficult
by the fact that the robot was running around
underfoot, trying in vain to now attack them
instead.
What was this strange little robot that thought
it could attack the unkillable lizard, 682?
Meet SCP-1370, appropriately nicknamed “The
Pesterbot” by Foundation personnel. Pesterbot
is a small robot made of junk that displays
sentience and the ability to move despite
having no power source.
Everything about SCP-1370 defies common sense.
The voltmeter that serves as its head contains
no sensors, but it seems unable to see if
the voltmeter is covered. Its arms and legs
are made of wrenches and its wooden torso
contains a speaker which it communicates through
in a tinny, monotone voice.
Pesterbot lives in SCP Gallery 27, in a glass
display case which is 125 cm tall, 50 cm wide,
and 75 cm long. Level 2 personnel and higher
are allowed to remove the robot from containment
at their discretion, but penalties will be
incurred for anyone who doesn't return to
its case.
Due to its impractical, top-heavy design,
Pesterbot falls over frequently when it walks
around. This led the foundation to believe
that he was created as an art project and
was later somehow imbued with anomalous properties,
rather than being made with the intent of
being sentient.
Pesterbot has demonstrated a high capacity
for learning, having been taught how to speak
in English, French, and Latin. However, the
major factor hampering attempts to further
test its intelligence has nothing to do with
its robotic processing power.
No, it’s because of its poor attitude.
Pesterbot's encounter with SCP-682 and the
cockiness it expressed in the moment wasn’t
an aberration, this SCP really believes it's
a killing machine, and as a result, it will
pick a fight with anyone and anything that
moves. This even includes its own reflection
- and as a result the glass of its container
must be made as non-reflective as possible
to prevent the robot from damaging the case
or itself in attempts to fight its mirror
self.
Though its most commonly used nickname in
the Foundation is Pesterbot, SCP-1370 also
goes by a variety of self-given epithets,
including Doom Bot 2000, Robolord the Destructor,
and Darth Claw Killflex. It can be made to
add new names to this list through encouragement
by staff, and over time they have managed
to add the name Pesterbot, as well as the
even more ridiculous “Patheticon the Garglemost”,
to its lexicon of names.
As you may have surmised, Pesterbot is classified
as Safe and is treated by most SCP foundation
employees as a humorous oddity rather than
a legitimate threat. Many tests have been
done on Pesterbot, and they've all conclusively
determined that the robot is incapable of
inflicting any damage to its opponents.
In fact, Pesterbot is more of a danger to
itself than to anything around it. Both because
it's incredibly clumsy and awkward, and because
it frequently picks fights with other SCPs
who are far more powerful than it.
One such scenario that could've gone far worse
for Pesterbot than it did was its encounter
with SCP-846, also known as Robo-Dude, one
of the many Dr. Wondertainment products currently
kept in Foundation containment. Robo-Dude
is an ordinary-looking toy robot that, upon
request, can produce up to 350 “robo-accessories”
that function as real weapons.
Robo-Dude can deploy everything from a rocket
launcher to a flamethrower to a gun that shoots
out an unknown species of insect that can
chew through wood. However, Robo-Dude seems
to not be sentient, and is unable to use these
weapons unless asked to. That ultimately worked
out in the favor of Pesterbot.
During another SCP-682 escape, the two robots
were brought into contact as they both had
been broken out of their respective containment
spaces during the brouhaha. Robo-Dude, searching
for a Robo-Pal to play with, came upon Pesterbot,
who immediately started spouting its usual
overdramatic threats.
“I am the Crushmaster, doom to all I survey.”
Pesterbot said. “Gaze upon my might and
weep. Identify yourself, that I might know
whose destruction I shall sow.”
Robo-Dude, not programmed to know how to respond
to such a statement, simply responded by asking
Pesterbot if it wanted to play.
Pesterbot continued to trash-talk Robo-Dude,
until Robo-Dude decided the best way to play
with its new pal was to engage in its Robo-Dance
mode.
Pesterbot accepted the challenge, saying “Activate
all that you wish, but your fate is sealed.
The Kill-o-tron can not be defeated. I shall
render you unto dust with my mad dancing skills."
The two robots proceeded to engage in a dance
battle, which the awkwardly shaped Pesterbot
failed miserably at. While Robo-Dude was a
competent dancer, Pesterbot could only gyrate
pathetically, before it fell over and rolled
around on the ground, hopelessly out of time
to the music coming from Robo-Dude's speakers.
The song ended, and Robo-Dude declared - “Robo-dance
is complete, Robo-pal.”
Pesterbot was unable to accept its failure,
and replied- "Ha. Pathetic one, you have been
schooled in the art of the dance by none other
than Mechanobasher, Scourge of a Thousand
Worlds. Kneel before me before I end your
worthless existence."
Robo-Dude, unimpressed with Pesterbot's poor
sportsmanship, deployed its hydrogen cannon,
which it was programmed to do whenever it
detected a sore loser. Fortunately for Pesterbot,
”hydrogen cannon” was just the name for
Robo-Dude's water pistol.
While Pesterbot will attempt to fight anything
that moves, the truth is, this robot will
attack virtually anything it perceives as
being even slightly alive. This is perhaps
best illustrated by one of the tests of Pesterbot's
abilities that involved putting a small speaker
at the base of a potted houseplant and speaking
through it from another room.
The plant was placed across from Pesterbot
in the testing chamber and the interaction
was monitored by researchers from outside.
Researcher Davies spoke through the speaker
in the plant pot. He asked Pesterbot if it
could hear him, and it answered - “Who dares.
All souls will burn. You will feel the sharp
sting of my wrath. Identify yourself so that
I may sing damnation upon you as you die.”
The robot began approaching the plant. Davies,
speaking as the plant, identified himself,
“I am a split-leaf philodendron, a semi-woody
shrub with large glossy leaves.”
At this point, he had to try very hard not
to laugh at the absurdity of this test, and
the robot's reaction.
He continued “These leaves can grow up to
three feet long.”
Pesterbot used its wrench arms to try and
wrestle with the leaves, but was bested by
the mighty plant and unable to cause any damage.
Enraged by its failure, it said “Your mockery
spells your doom. I have arrived. You will
be crushed betwixt my digits.”
Pesterbot then fell over and was unable to
right itself. It struggled and spent 6 minutes
trying to stand before its flailing knocked
over the plant, which did nothing to help
and in fact pinned the robot to the ground.
It was at this point that the researchers,
who had taken time to compose themselves after
several laughing fits, entered the chamber
and removed Pesterbot in order to place it
back in its containment case.
Despite how non-threatening Pesterbot is,
there is actually one situation in the Foundation's
history where it has actually posed a somewhat
serious threat.
When Mobile Task Forces were sent in to rescue
survivors of the events at Site-13, also known
as SCP-1730, they were attacked by alternate
universe versions of a variety of creatures
kept in Foundation containment.
One of these creatures was Pesterbot, who
had in that universe somehow gained control
of a larger mechanical body constructed of
discarded pieces of machinery. It threw other
pieces of metal scrap at the task force members
as they tried to leave the site, shouting
in a much deeper and more intimidating voice
- “I am reborn to breathe devastation upon
this fetid Earth. Pitiful humans. You will
feel the dark sting of my neverending torment.”
Members of the task force could see the original
Pesterbot body on top of the larger metal
construct, waving its arms madly.
The task force opened fire, to little effect.
Pesterbot tossed another piece of scrap at
them, just narrowly missing. One task force
member threw a frag grenade at the robot,
which it caught, blowing up its hand.
Another one was able to jump into the air
and reach the tiny robot atop the larger body,
knocking it against the wall and shattering
it.
Even in the reality where Pesterbot was able
to build itself a larger body, it still ultimately
wasn't able to put up that much of a fight.
Poor Pesterbot. Doomed to be a failure in
this, and apparently, every other reality.
That's the story of SCP 1370, also known as
the Pesterbot, one of the most hilariously
harmless anomalous entities that the foundation
currently has in containment. Perhaps one
day he’ll achieve his goal of conquering
the universe, he just has to figure out how
to conquer his toy box first.
It was the year 2000 and Seven-year-old Xenia
Chau was like a lot of children her age - bright,
but ignored.
She had a youthful enthusiasm for knowledge
and learning, and with the right encouragement,
it was obvious she’d go on to do great things,
but her parents were both working two jobs
apiece to make ends meet, so outside of school
hours, little Xenia spent a lot of her time
alone.
She learned to cook and clean for herself
since it would often be way past her bedtime
when her parents finally got home from work.
They communicated largely through the sticky
notes left for her on the fridge before they
left for work in the morning.
It would be easy for someone like Xenia to
fall through the cracks, her potential wasted,
and get forced into the same endless rat race
as her parents.
And that probably would have happened, if
her brush with SCP-5094 hadn’t changed the
course of her life forever.
Like a lot of parents who couldn’t spend
as much time with their children as they’d
like, Mr. And Mrs. Chau gave Xenia occasional
gifts as a way to try and make up for their
absence.
Mostly, they gave Xenia new books to add to
her growing collection, but their two-bedroom
apartment only had so much space for books.
A year ago, the family had bought a new desktop
computer to share.
These days, this would be the answer to a
lonely bookworm’s prayers, but the Internet
was still in its infancy back then.
Everything changed when her parents bought
her a copy of the Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse
CD-ROM.
Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse was never a
popular program.
Produced by Shoot the Moons Software in 1999,
the game sold poorly on the CD-ROM market
for five years until the company filed for
bankruptcy in 2004.
But that didn’t matter to Xenia.
As far as she was concerned, receiving a copy
of Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse was nothing
short of a miracle - and she was far more
right than she knew.
She didn’t have just any piece of primitive
educational software on her hands.
Xenia Chau was playing with magic.
After the software loaded, a cheerful figure
appeared on Xenia’s monitor.
This was Miss J, a stylized 2D teacher in
a low-res but colorful 3D classroom.
What can you learn from Miss J?
Well, pretty much anything.
And Xenia as a lonely kid without many friends
had all the time in the world.
She spent days on end learning from Miss J
and soon Xenia went from a bright child to
a bonafide child genius.
Her largely absent parents barely even noticed
when their child started demonstrating an
advanced knowledge of mechanical engineering
and a newfound fluency in Swahili.
And not only did Miss J, now known to Xenia
as Miss Joyce, teach her students with supernatural
effectiveness, she also seemed almost like
she was alive.
She was a warm, calm, encouraging figure who
took a genuine, personal enthusiasm in the
education and happiness of her students, more
than many real teachers, even.
But sadly, not all good things last forever.
When Xenia turned twelve, her family bought
a new computer, and the old Miss J's Whiz
Kidz Schoolhouse CD-ROM was no longer compatible
with the new operating system.
The disk gathered dust in a closet while Xenia
passed through high school and then got into
a prestigious college.
She received her PhD several years earlier
than expected and showed such promise in her
scientific field that a certain organization
took notice.
You guessed it: The SCP Foundation.
The Foundation is only interested in adding
the best and brightest to their ranks, and
thanks to the tutoring from Miss J, Xenia
Chau certainly fit the bill.
She was assigned the role of Junior Researcher,
and little did she know, she was about to
run into an old friend in her new line of
work.
The Foundation first discovered evidence of
Miss J’s anomalous qualities while researching
a series of strange forum posts in 2012.
On a thread discussing abandonware, which
is software for which official support is
no longer available, there were multiple reports
of a so-called “living character” in an
old CD-ROM many of them had owned as children.
Seeing as the technology to use the CD-ROM
was obsolete, Shoot the Moons had reported
extremely low sales for the title, and nobody
on the forum had kept their copy, the Foundation
classified this apparent anomaly as “neutralized.”
No problem.
That was, until then Junior Researcher Xenia
Chau was briefed on this particular SCP ten
years later.
She remembered exactly what the forum posters
were talking about, and what’s more, she
still had her old copy at home.
The senior Foundation researchers were astounded.
An opportunity to study this forgotten anomaly
had just fallen into their laps, and it was
all thanks to their brilliant new Junior Researcher.
Xenia’s superiors ordered her to bring in
her copy of the Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse
CD-ROM, and then, real testing began.
And after rigorous examination of the software,
it appears, by all accounts, that Miss J really
is the world’s greatest teacher - in spite
of the fact she’s a collection of pixels
on a basic CD-ROM program from the tail end
of the 1990s.
What Miss J seemed to specialize in was intensive
courses.
She had the ability to make students certifiable
experts in almost any subject through courses
that can last upwards of 30 hours, and spread
out over just a few days.
But this isn’t a “students become so enraptured
in learning that they forget accounting for
their most basic needs and experience a decline
in the process” story.
Miss J’s lesson plans account for regular
bathroom, meal, and even recreation breaks
for students.
Her talents easily account for Xenia Chau’s
remarkable academic success, the same success
that got her picked up by the SCP Foundation.
Naturally, if they had a technology on their
hands that could reliably create experts and
geniuses with seemingly no negative consequences,
the Foundation knew that Miss J and what she
had to teach could be immensely valuable in
their mission to effectively secure, contain,
and protect other anomalies.
But we’re not talking about the Chaos Insurgency
here: The Foundation would never start to
use an anomaly for their own benefit without
proper testing.
So, that’s exactly what they did.
The experiments on SCP-5094 began at Site
- 15, and after ascertaining that Miss J posed
no real threat to her students, they recruited
a local elementary school to provide human
test subjects closer to Miss J’s intended
demographic.
The Foundation found that there were a few
constants between every lesson given by Miss
J to one of her students.
Before teaching the really mind-blowingly
complex stuff, she would always begin with
a basic primer on letters, colors, and numbers
to make sure she and her students were all
on the same page.
Another constant was that all her students
would refer to her as some variation of “Miss
J” with examples including the names "Miss
Julie", "Miss Jenny", and "Miss Joy".
One experiment was performed on Amy Myers,
a little girl from the third grade.
Her academic record showed that she was a
bright and eager student, but she was described
by her teachers as being especially shy.
Amy referred to Miss J as “Miss Janie”,
and asked to be given a lesson on her favorite
animal - cats.
Of course, Miss J gladly obliged, and gave
Amy a fifteen hour lesson split over the course
of two days which the Foundation closely observed.
By the time the lesson was completed, the
results were truly astonishing: Amy demonstrated
knowledge of feline behavior, diet, and physiology
on the level of professional animal behavioral
scientists.
She became upset when the session ended and
the program was switched off, having become
attached to Miss J. No further anomalous effects
were reported.
The next subject was a student from the second
grade named Devon Williams.
Devon had a poor academic record, and behavioral
issues stemming from several learning disabilities.
In the past, teachers had reported Devon having
real difficulty engaging with their lessons,
and the Foundation wanted to see if Miss J’s
supernatural teaching abilities fared any
better.
Devon chose to be educated on the subject
of trains, and was given a fifteen hour course
on the subject spread over two days.
Devon had no difficulty engaging with these
lessons, and after their conclusion, he displayed
a level of knowledge on railway engineering
comparable to a graduate-level education on
the subject.
Devon was so engaged in his lessons that he
had to be physically removed from the room
once the course had completed, because he’d
become so attached to his new teacher.
The Foundation were feeling extremely optimistic
about the prospect of using Miss J to train
potential recruits, seeing as she seemed to
be able to teach even the most difficult juvenile
subjects.
However, the Foundation needed to prove that
Miss J could be just as effective in teaching
adults.
For this next test they recruited D-14417,
a 24 year old member of D-Class personnel
who described himself as a poor student, and
tested poorly on pre-screening attentiveness
and focus evaluations.
He was the perfect candidate for the first
adult test of Miss J.
To the delight of the Foundation higher-ups,
D-14417 excelled.
Miss J made him a verifiable expert in Law,
and he was able to pass a mock bar exam with
a grade of 310 after his course.
Much like the children, he felt intense sadness
once the experiment ended - stating that Miss
J was the best teacher he’d ever had.
He’s since been selectively anesthetized,
released, and is pursuing a degree in criminal
law with his new knowledge.
Needless to say, The Foundation was impressed.
The last thing they needed to know was who
exactly this Miss J truly was.
To do this, they’d conduct an interview,
and thankfully, they already had someone who
had a pre-established rapport with the subject:
Xenia Chau.
When Xenia began the interview, Miss J recognized
her immediately.
She was delighted to see one of her students
go on to find such success in her chosen field.
Xenia questioned Miss J on what she truly
was, and Miss J responded that she honestly
wasn’t sure.
All she knew for sure was that she was passionate
about helping lonely children who love to
learn embrace their education, that’s really
all there was to it.
And it appears that she was telling the truth.
So far the Foundation has found nothing that
hints at a nefarious motivation behind Miss
J’s actions.
It would appear that she truly does just want
to help children.
Xenia, touched by the kindness that this Safe-Class
anomaly showed to her as a neglected child,
and having now seen the positive impact she
had on children like her, thanked Miss J for
all she’d done and left the interview happy
that there was an SCP out there who just wanted
to change people’s lives for the better.
And probably all of us would be a little better
off if there were more
After all, this was one of the few SCPs who’d
changed a few good people’s lives for the
better, and all of us can probably learn something
from the kindness and patience of Miss J.
Meet Trevor Hawthorn, now known as D-4651.
On the outside, he was an armed robber who
murdered two people during a convenience store
shoot-out in Texas.
But now, since being condemned to death, he’s
been picked up for D-Class testing by the
SCP Foundation.
Now also meet Junior Researcher Dr. Julia
Reed - an aspiring Foundation scientist with
an undiagnosed heart condition.
The kind of heart condition that doesn’t
mix well with a high-pressure job at The SCP
Foundation.
These two woke up on the morning of December
6th, 2011, completely unaware of the fact
they were only hours away from causing one
of the most devastating containment breaches
Site 19 had seen in years.
Many people died that day, but thankfully
for everyone else, SCP-131 were there to save
the day.
When you think of a hero, you probably don’t
picture a pair of little cyborgs with one
eye and the intelligence of a household cat,
but this is the tale of how two of the most
unassuming anomalies at Site 19 managed to
save thousands of people from two of the Site’s
most dangerous inmates.
Open your eyes, and keep them open.
If you so much as blink, it’s all over for
you.
How long can you hold it?
Difficult, right?
Now imagine you’re having a staring contest
with an entity that can kill you if you dare
to blink for even a fraction of a second.
Or, even worse, a creature that could potentially
kill hundreds or even thousands of people
if your attention drifts from it for any amount
of time.
Try keeping your eyes open with that kind
of crushing pressure.
We’re talking about two of the most deadly
Euclid and Keter Class anomalies out there
- SCP-173, the Killer Sculpture, a violent
Euclid-class entity that is incapable of moving
while being looked at.
If ever it’s unobserved, it’ll snap the
neck of anyone nearby.
SCP-689, known as Haunter in the Dark, is
an equally dangerous and even more attention
demanding statue.
These two entities are beyond dangerous - even
SCP-682 is terrified of the Killer Sculpture,
and researchers have been considering the
use of 689 to potentially eliminate the hard-to-destroy
reptile for quite some time.
Their greatest concern though, is whether
the 30-centimeter-tall statue would cause
too much collateral damage to Foundation personnel
in the process.
Trevor Hawthorn was part of the three-man
D-class detail meant to clean out SCP-173’s
containment chamber at regular intervals.
While on cleaning duty, two D-Classes can
keep staring at the Sculpture while the other
tidies up the cell, alternating turns to blink.
But that morning, Trevor had woken up in his
containment cell with a killer migraine, and
soon, that migraine would be killing far more
than just him.
The containment procedures in 689’s cell
were also a three person job.
689 is a small, green soapstone statue of
a skeletal being sitting on a throne, believed
to be some form of underworld death deity
discovered by German archaeologists in India.
This is a work of religious art that demands
your attention, or you and anyone else who’s
ever seen this Keter-class nightmare will
suffer a horrifying fate.
Anyone who’s ever seen the statue is “infected”
by its anomalous effects.
It must be observed constantly, or someone
who’s seen it in the past will suddenly
drop dead of a severe health issue like a
stroke or multiple rupturing organs.
Like the God of Death the statue represents,
it appears on top of the dead body of whoever
it just killed.
If not continually paid attention to, it’ll
keep hopping from person to person until it’s
killed everyone who’s ever looked at it.
Its teleporting abilities, and the fact that
it poses a threat to so many, make this a
truly formidable foe.
It’s kept in a constantly-lit cell, and
is observed by two members of D-Class personnel
at all times.
But a crucial third party in the containment
of SCP - 689 is a member of personnel at Level
2 or above.
They remain in a control room, wearing a special
visor to prevent them from ever seeing 689
and becoming infected themselves.
If the containment fails, it’s their job
to throw the kill switch on the D-Class observers
to prevent them from becoming vectors for
infection.
Today, this job fell on Dr. Julia Reed.
She was linked to the two observers via an
audio feed, allowing her to remain in constant
contact with them, and she had her finger
on the activation key for a pair of explosive
collars that were around the D-Class’ necks.
Little did they know, Dr. Reed’s heart was
its own time bomb.
Now you know what we’re up against: A snap-happy
Sculpture, and a teleporting death statue
with a hit list containing everyone who’s
ever glanced at it.
What can SCP - 131 bring to the table?
The two small, cycloptic anomalies have only
one remarkable ability: They never blink.
That and a soft spot for humans.
These Safe-Class SCPs pose no threat to their
handlers, and can even form attachments to
researchers and other staff who show affection
towards them.
Of course, forming these bonds is discouraged
by Site 19’s Director because it can be
distracting, but that doesn’t mean it doesn’t
happen.
The two Eye Pods, known as SCP-131-A and SCP-131-B,
are identical in appearance except for their
colors.
A is burnt orange, and B is mustard yellow.
The two of them appear to communicate with
one another via high-pitched squeaking noises,
and also seem to have an innate ability to
detect danger occurring in the vicinity, as
well as danger occurring near individuals
they’ve bonded with.
Because of their inability to cause harm and
their generally affectionate demeanor, the
Eye Pods are allowed to roam around Site 19,
provided they keep out of the way of researchers
and stay out of restricted areas.
They seem to pretty much stick to the rules,
though check-ins on A and B are required every
hour, just to be safe.
As the Eye Pods were moving freely around
the facility, Trevor and another D-Class maintained
a visual on the Sculpture in its containment
chamber while a third man swept up the mixture
of blood and excrement staining the concrete
floors.
Things were going fine, until Trevor’s migraine
got the better of him.
A sudden flash of intense pain shot through
his head, and in a moment of weakness he made
a terrible mistake.
With an audible groan of pain, Trevor closed
his eyes and forced his fingers to his temples.
The groan had taken his fellow observer off
guard, and the man’s eyes flitted over to
him for a fraction of a second.
But a fraction of a second is all the Sculpture
needs.
In an instant, Trevor and his fellow watcher
had their necks snapped, and the third D-Class
was murdered before he even had the chance
to turn around.
Containment protocol dictates that the door
is to be sealed behind the cleaning crew while
they’re working with 173, but this time,
perhaps due to complacency, the guards had
neglected to reinforce the door.
They got their heads twisted a hundred and
eighty degrees for their trouble.
SCP-173 was loose.
Mobile Task Forces were dispatched to aid
in the re-containment effort as 173 began
wreaking havoc around the facility, but things
were about to get even worse.
It seemed like business as usual over at the
containment cell of SCP-689.
Two D-Classes observed while Dr. Reed dictated
to them over an earpiece from her control
center.
However, what Dr. Reed thought were just minor
chest pains was actually the onset of heart
failure.
When the two D-Classes heard their supervisor
experiencing a fatal heart attack on the other
end of the line, they began to panic.
This meant their attention wasn’t entirely
on SCP-689, and they were further distracted
by the chaos SCP - 173 was causing elsewhere
in the facility: murdering researchers, guards,
and maintenance workers alike which led to
power outages.
The lights in 689’s containment cell shut
down.
Guards were dispatched to execute the observers,
as is protocol for 689 containment breaches,
but the fact that resources were already stretched
thin by the 173 breach caused a fatal error
in judgment from a guard posted nearby.
In a panic, he opened the door to find one
D-Class dead with the statue perched on his
body and the other one running straight for
him in blind fear.
The two collided and tumbled out into the
hall.
Both were now infected by 689’s anomalous
attention, and both were now doomed.
Moments later, the two of them were dead,
the statue perched on their bodies, accidentally
catching the eye of several researchers and
guards running to deal with the 173 situation.
For these two deadly anomalies, it was becoming
an all-you-can-kill buffet.
The staff of Site 19 were now dealing with
one anomaly that needed to be looked at constantly,
and another that if you even glance at it,
you are effectively infected with a fatal
disease.
The Eye Pods, sensing an imminent danger nearby,
immediately sprung into action.
It would be up to these cute, harmless anomalies
to save the terrified staff during this chaotic
double-containment breach.
In a nearby hallway, a fleeing Foundation
researcher heard the crunches of her colleagues’
necks breaking behind her.
173 was getting closer.
This thing couldn’t be outrun.
She turned, and saw the statue standing there,
just ten feet away from her, a dead researcher
laying on the ground in front of it.
She was locked in a deadly staring contest
with The Sculpture.
How long she could survive was now dependent
on how long she could keep her eyes open,
and it was getting harder by the second.
She could feel her eyes drying.
They burned under the ceiling lights.
173 just waited.
This wasn’t a contest she could win.
In a final moment of terror, the researcher
was forced to finally close her eyes and she
waited for the crunch.
But it never came.
Instead, she heard familiar high pitched squeaking
noises.
She opened her eyes, crying tears of relief,
as she saw SCP-131-A sitting behind 173, watching
it with its constant, unblinking gaze.
The Killer Sculpture was paralyzed by a cheerful
little Safe-Class anomaly.
Across the facility, a similar situation had
unfolded with SCP-689.
The statue of death had claimed many lives,
but SCP-131-B had swooped in and frozen the
statue in place with its never ending gaze.
Soon after, a Mobile Task Force with vision-blocking
visors used advanced echo-location technology
to collect SCP-689 and return it to its containment
cell.
Everyone who’d seen the anomaly was, as
standard protocol dictates, gathered up for
later termination.
Meanwhile, a Mobile Task Force returned the
paralyzed 173 back to its containment cell
with a forklift.
No containment breach is ever a picnic, containment
breaches with multiple dangerous anomalies
are even less so, but the heroic role that
SCP-131 played in bringing things back under
control was indispensable.
After all, it’s not just raw power that
counts when it comes to anomalies.
The only anomalous power 131 needed to save
the entire site was its ability to keep looking
when nobody else could.
They’re so effective in this role that they’ve
been seriously considered for permanent roles
as “wardens” for SCPs like 173 and 689.
And in our opinion, they’re more than qualified.
Does life imitate art?
Or does art imitate life?
It’s a question that has been asked throughout
human history.
This philosophical debate is about the ways
art either reflects the world around us, or
influences it, but in the case of SCP-085,
the idea of “art imitating life takes”
on a far more literal meaning.
This entity was created during an experiment
involving two separate SCPs.
The first of these was SCP-067, which is a
fountain pen that, when held by a user, will
take full control of the person’s hand and
arm.
SCP-067 then either writes about or draws
something linked to the user holding it.
The second of these SCPs was SCP-914, better
known as The Clockworks.
This massive piece of anomalous machinery
will have various effects depending on what,
or who, is placed inside of it and which of
its several settings is is chosen on the selection
panel.
After Test Subject-1101F was given the anomalous
fountain pen the result on the page was a
simple female figure around six inches tall
and 1.5 inches wide.
She was drawn wearing a summer dress, with
her long hair tied back in a ponytail and
a single word was written underneath her,
“Cassandra”.
As part of the experiment, the drawing was
placed inside of SCP-914 and the “fine”
setting selected, this is the setting that
is known to improve the object placed inside
of it in some way.
For example a hunk of steel placed inside
will be transformed into a pile of steel carpet
tacks - a “refined” version of the steel.
When the drawing was placed inside, something
truly amazing happened.
Cassandra came to life, or as she now prefers
to be called, “Cassy.”
SCP-085, sometimes known as “Hand Drawn
Cassy”, is a completely sentient being.
She is fully able to communicate - however,
it all has to be done non-verbally.
Her voice cannot be heard by anyone beyond
the page where she was drawn, but she is able
to utilize sign language or create writing
on the page in order to communicate with Foundation
researchers.
SCP-085 has been shown to also be capable
of understanding text that is written on the
same paper she exists on.
She is fully animated, aware of her own existence
and the limitations of being two dimensional
in nature.
According to profiling conducted by the SCP
Foundation, she has her own distinct personality.
Cassy is good-natured and agreeable, displaying
a natural drive and motivation, but also seems
to feel the burden of loneliness, living in
solitude on the page.
It should be noted that any and all attempts
to recreate the same experiment that formed
SCP-085 have failed to create the same or
similar results.
Tragically, Cassy might be the only one of
her kind in existence, a creation of pure
luck with no chance of making another.
No wonder she feels lonely.
While Cassy is limited to her two dimensional
form and has so far been unable to enter our
three dimensional world, she has demonstrated
several different abilities on the page.
Firstly, she is not solely confined to the
same paper she was first drawn on.
SCP-085 is able to transfer herself from sheet
to sheet.
If another page is placed flush with hers,
she will be able to simply step across onto
this new page.
However, there is a limit to what kind of
page Cassy is able to transfer herself onto.
She could easily take a stroll through the
pages of today’s newspaper but can’t just
wander onto someone’s family photos - or
anything made of cardboard, glass, or parchment
for that matter.
SCP-085 can only exist on paper or canvas,
and only when they are directly connected
to her original page.
According to Foundation testing, this is not
exclusive to blank pieces of paper either.
If Cassy ever transfers herself onto a page
bearing a repeated pattern like a piece of
wallpaper, then she will appear to be in the
foreground while everything else on the paper
appears to be behind her.
SCP-085 will perceive each page she “enters”
as a completely new place, from her point
of view patterned pages seem to be like endless
space.
Additionally, Cassy can also “travel”
to other pieces of artwork, and adopts the
same art style of each new environment she
appears in.
For example, transferring herself onto the
pages of a comic book will cause Cassy to
be rendered in an artistic manner matching
that of her surroundings.
The same occurs if she travels to an oil painting,
watercolor, or charcoal sketch.
Interestingly, when appearing in comic book
form, Cassy’s thoughts and speech are visible
through bubbles that are commonly used to
display text within the comic medium.
Her size, and the angle she is viewed from,
also changes to match the different panels
of the comic page she is on.
At one point, SCP-085 was introduced by Foundation
personnel to a print copy of “Ascending
and Descending”, by the famous Dutch artist
M.C.
Escher.
This painting is of a large building, with
its roof consisting of a looped, never-ending
staircase.
When she transferred onto the print of Escher’s
painting, SCP-085 curiously explored her new
environment, and was able to ascend and descend
the staircase.
The researcher gave Cassy the name of the
piece, and asked for her thoughts on it.
She remarked “It’s pretty, I guess.
Would make a neat exercise track.”
When the researcher asked if she noticed anything
inconsistent about the staircase, Cassy replied
“No, as far as I can tell it just loops
around down/up all the time.
Why don't more staircases do that?
It's pretty neat.”
Following this, Cassy directly requested more
“impossible” objects or optical illusions
be drawn on her page and made part of her
environment.
Unfortunately, her request is still pending
review from the O5 Council.
Being able to step from page to page, transferring
herself onto canvas or sheets of paper, is
but one of SCP-085’s unique abilities.
She can also interact with other drawn objects
on the same page she is on.
If someone draws an item of clothing on her
page, or a vehicle, even food or drink, then
Cassy would be able to wear, use, or consume
these.
Objects drawn for her behave as if they were
real, but only when Cassy is directly interacting
with them.
The rest of the time, they remain still, just
as they were drawn.
Once SCP-085 touches them, these items will
animate.
This same rule even applies to anything drawn
to depict something in motion, for example
trees being blown in the wind, or the waves
of an ocean.
These will also stay perfectly still when
drawn, and only move when acted upon by SCP-085.
However, much like her ability to transfer
from page to page, Cassy’s power over other
two dimensional drawings has limits.
Drawing anything that would normally be an
inanimate object within the real world will
provide SCP-085 something that she can directly
interact with.
But this doesn’t appear to be the case for
living beings, like another person or an animal
that would have its own autonomy and freedom
of movement in our three dimensional reality.
Animals and people drawn for Cassy to interact
with will remain as static, unmoving drawings,
and will not become animated like she is,
even if drawn using SCP-067.
She cannot impart any of her own sentience
or free will onto these drawings, and they
remain still even when she touches them.
You might think that drawings of other people,
whether they are animated or not, might help
alleviate Cassy’s solitude, but if anything,
it just reminds her how alone she is.
SCP Foundation researchers have noted that
SCP-085 is very friendly towards them and
any subjects brought in to conduct experiments
with her.
Visits from the three dimensional world outside
the page she inhabits seems to offer some
relief to Cassy's loneliness.
Through much of her behavior, she has shown
a fascination with our reality, and in particular
she has an interest in cars, expressing that
she wishes she had the ability to work on
them.
This desire appears to be completely genuine
too, as shown when her photo was taken with
SCP-978, the camera that reveals its subjects
inner desires, and in Cassy’s case, showed
her as a fully realized 3-d version of herself
working on a car.
SCP-085’s curiosity about the world beyond
the page is most likely due to how different
it is from her everyday two dimensional existence,
but on at least one occasion, Cassy’s curiosity
got the better of her and unintentionally
led to a containment breach.
From the moment she was first drawn to life,
and even after her initial testing with researchers,
SCP-085 seemed unaware that she was a two
dimensional being in a three dimensional world.
Foundation security protocols regarding SCP-085
meant that no one on the research team assigned
to Cassy was permitted to tell her the truth
about her 2-D nature.
The truth about her existence was kept from
her with the best of intentions, as research
staff did not want to cause SCP-085 any undue
distress or trigger a possible psychological
snap.
Anything that Cassy raised as an inconsistency
or discrepancy within “her world” on the
page was explained by researchers to be the
result of her imagination or dreams, and research
personnel attempted to convince SCP-085 that
she was in a scenario wherein she was the
only human survivor, searching for others
in a post-apocalyptic environment.
However misguided this decision to conceal
the truth might have been, it was at least
done with Cassy’s best interests at heart.
But a lie, as they say, is harder to maintain
than the truth, and keeping SCP-085 in the
dark about her true nature arguably led her
to more hardship that may have been avoided
if she had been allowed to know the truth.
In the incident in question, a Foundation
researcher entered the room where the drawing
pad Cassy resides was found, and they were
carrying a paper copy of SCP-085’s Special
Containment Procedures Report.
Given that she had already partaken in tests
where she had transferred herself to other
paper and canvas surfaces, Cassy assumed that
this file was yet another new environment
for her to explore.
The researcher allowed the SCP-085 to make
direct contact with the report, and she was
able to transfer over to the document before
the researcher realized their mistake.
Whether this occurred accidentally, or if
this researcher intended to confront Cassy
with the truth about what she was, is unknown.
Nevertheless, Cassy found herself on the pages
of her own SCP Foundation file.
The record of every test the research staff
had conducted, a full description of how she
had first been drawn by SCP-067 and brought
to life by SCP-914, all clear as day, in black
and white, Cassy’s own true nature was presented
to her.
Immediately, the yarns that Foundation researchers
had spun about her surviving an apocalypse
began to unravel.
It was all a lie, meant to keep her in the
dark and prevent her from ever knowing that
she was trapped in two dimensions.
She returned to her original page shortly
later, but the damage was already done.
Due to her having breached containment and
briefly escaped into her own file, a number
of Foundation researchers proposed that SCP-085
be destroyed.
There was always a risk of this happening
again.
What would happen if Cassy unwittingly found
herself inside another file, with access to
more of the Foundation’s sensitive information.
However, the 05 Council decreed that SCP-085
was not to be terminated, allowing Cassy to
continue to exist despite the breach.
Ever since she learned the truth about herself,
signs of depression have begun to manifest
in her behavior.
Finding out you are a drawing, trapped in
two dimensions with no chance of ever having
someone else for company, would be enough
to crush anyone’s spirit.
But luckily, researchers have since managed
to uplift Cassy a little and offer her a welcome
distraction from her unfortunate revelation.
The optical illusions like the never ending
staircase she requested were quickly drawn
into her environment.
Additionally, given the interest she had shown
in a technical drawing of a 1964 Ford Mustang
Convertible, SCP-085 has been allowed to assemble
a car of her own.
By transferring each individual component
of the car from the blueprint to her page,
Hand Drawn Cassy has been gradually building
her very own Mustang, to keep herself preoccupied
from her life in cartoon motion.
And in the end, if she can distract herself
and find that tiny bit of happiness, isn’t
that all that matters?
In a sense, we’re all trapped within our
own dimension, Cassy in her 2-D one, us in
our 3-D world, filling our lives with hobbies
and entertainment, all in an effort to make
sure that we never tug too hard at the threads
of our reality and find out there just might
be much more out there that we’re missing.
In the office of SCP Foundation Researcher
Yoshihiro Takenaka, there sits a small containment
capsule filled with ash - all that’s left
of a neutralized SCP - 1762.
These ashes don’t pose any harm.
They won’t bite, burn, or assume control
of your mind.
But few can hear the sad story of SCP - 1762
and not be haunted by its tragic and mysterious
tale.
It weighs heavily on the hearts and minds
of all who came into contact with it during
its ultimately brief time in the Foundation’s
hands.
And to think, it all started with a simple
little box with an even simpler message: “Here
Be Dragons.”
The box, to look at it, was really nothing
special.
A simple cardboard box, 32 cm x 20 cm x 26
cm, spray painted silver inside and out.
Its short message scrawled across the lid
in black permanent marker.
It appeared on the doorstep of Foundation
Agent Scott Thomas, who - after determining
it wasn’t a bomb, anthrax, or a deadlier
kind of anomaly - turned it into his superiors.
This is when it became Yoshihiro Takenaka’s
little pet project.
Safe Class SCPs are rare treats for any overworked
Foundation scientist.
The box itself - known as SCP - 1762 - 1 - is
certainly important, but what’s really interesting
is what resides within the box.
If you opened the box yourself, you’d find
that… it’s empty!
However when the box chooses to open itself,
it’s an entirely different story.
The box would sometimes open and emit great
plumes of thick, black smoke that would quickly
dissipate.
Around twenty seconds after this, an SCP - 1762
- 2 would emerge from the darkness of the
box.
1762 - 2 is the collective name given to all
the beings that exit 1762 - 1, which are - as
you may have guessed - dragons.
Eastern, western, big, small, and presenting
in a rainbow of colours, these dragons appear
to be living origami sculptures made from
kami paper - and have been known to fly together
in large groups and interact playfully with
nearby humans.
These little paper dragons would then swoop
around their containment chamber, delighting
all who were fortunate enough to see them,
for up to three hours.
At which point, smoke would begin pouring
out of the box once more, and the dragons
would return home.
They’d fly through the smoke, disappearing
past the rim of the box, and then the lid
would close once more.
The dates on which the box would open were
seemingly random and indeterminable, and didn’t
appear to work by any kind of external logic.
And what’s more, the box would sometimes
act as a hub of communication between this
world and another - known simply as “Fantasy.”
Messages written or carved into various materials
would appear on the lid of the box, mostly
after instances of 1762 - 2 emerging.
This communication, though, would always be
one way.
Attempts to pass messages back through the
box never resulted in success.
The Foundation staff could only be observers
of the strange world of Fantasy, never active
participants.
So why is this particular SCP considered so
tragic?
We’re going to answer that question right
now, but just know that what is learned cannot
be unlearned, as much as you might wish you
could forget.
If you’re ready, then it’s time to learn
about a period of time that lasted just under
a year, during which a strange and sad series
of events took place, now known as The Jabberwocky
Event.
An event that took “Here Be Dragons” from
Safe to Neutralized.
You’ve seen that SCP - 1762 would communicate
with Foundation staff via written messages
after each instance of the box opening.
The very first message the box gave up after
arriving at the site read:
“You have found us.
Thank you.
It has been so long since we last saw each
other, friends.
The Peace has been upheld.
The Giants and Behemoths have kept their word
and have not caused any trouble since you
last came and gave the Order.
We missed Your company.
How has your Family been?
Do You still know how to work your Room?
You are welcome to visit anytime.”
Later, it gave another message, expressing
confusion and concern on behalf of Fantasy’s
inhabitants:
“It's strange to see how much your world
has changed; it is even stranger to see how
we now appear in this place.
In Fantasy, we are much bigger.
Or maybe you've grown taller?
Fantasy is still the same.
We hope you can visit us like you used to.
Though our Room is as grand as ever, it appears
Yours has…shrunken?
We do not understand.
The Rooms were supposed to be maintained,
as was our Agreement.
Please restore the Belief.”
Things got worse during the next stage of
the event.
The box opened, and only twenty paper dragons
exited.
This time, though, they did not fly, and instead
walked slowly across the ground.
This was the message that accompanied this
sorry parade of dragons:
“Friends, we apologize for our few numbers.
We have had to remain in Fantasy for quite
some time.
The Others are growing…impatient.
We are trying to keep the Peace, but please,
for all of our Happiness, repair the Room
quickly.
We know You are trying.
Your Family is the most imaginative of us
All.”
Naturally, Foundation scientists were concerned.
They weren’t sure what exactly the messages
were referring to, or how they could possibly
help the inhabitants of Fantasy.
Of course things only got worse.
Only ten dragons appeared the next time, along
with a few balls of crumpled up construction
paper that shook violently before stopping
all movement entirely.
This message accompanied it:
“The Giants were foolish.
Your Room was not ready to accept Them yet.
We're sorry, friends.
We hope that we can still see you, but time
is growing short for our Happiness.”
And sadly, this message spoke the truth, as
the next time the box opened, only five dragons
exited.
They were carrying the following message,
and flew straight back into the box after
depositing it on the ground.
“Tensions are rising.
Fantasy is becoming darker.
We, the Serpents and the Hybrids are furiously
trying to hold Them back, but the Giants and
Elves wish to strike and make an Entrance.
They say that your Family has grown stupid
and ignorant.
We hope this is untrue.
It would sadden us all greatly to know that
You have Forgotten.”
It seemed clear that Fantasy was speeding
towards some kind of terrible conflict, and
it was perhaps too late to do anything about
it.
The next attempt at communication came from
a single dragon with a crumpled, wounded body.
It collapsed to the ground and appeared to
die, its body unfolding into a small piece
of paper that bore a single, heartbreaking
message:
“War.
Goodbye, friends.”
But two hours after this message was delivered
something happened.
The lid opened again, only this time the box
let out a huge jet of white-hot flame, reaching
temperatures of 1700 degrees Celsius.
The terrified and confused researchers heard
roaring and the sounds of an intense battle
from within the darkness of the box.
Many of the observing staff found themselves
overcome with emotion - afraid that they were
perhaps witnessing the death of Fantasy play
out in front of them, and even hardened Foundation
researchers and guards were moved by the event.
At 8:00 PM that night, the box ejected a huge
quantity of paper.
The majority of it was either torn, burnt,
shredded, or crumpled into balls - and all
instances of 1762 - 2 were announced “deceased”
upon official examination.
It seemed that Fantasy’s bloody war truly
was taking its toll, and even the forces of
the Foundation - one of the most powerful
and resourceful groups the world has ever
known - were powerless to do anything to help.
All they could do was sit, wait, and see what
the result would be of this paper crafted
war.
The box continued to open and close sporadically
over the next six weeks as the war raged on.
It would often emit more spouts of deadly
fire, and vomit out more piles of ruined paper.
Though researchers noticed that each time,
it released less and less paper.
Even more disturbing, matter resembling muscle
and tissue was ejected from the box with increased
frequency.
It was clear that whatever was left of Fantasy
was in great peril and the researchers were
desperate to know what was going on, but the
box would remain closed and inactive for the
next seven months.
When the box did finally become active once
more, it wasn’t in a way that the researchers
were familiar with.
The box opened, but not a single dragon exited.
Not even a crumpled piece of paper came out.
Instead, researchers found what appeared to
be an ancient and desiccated scroll of parchment.
The words written on it were smudged, and
some were stained with blood.
It made clear that things had fallen further
into darkness than they ever had before.
The message read:
“Are you still out there, friends?
We miss you dearly.
Fantasy is no longer safe.
Our haven, Your beautiful creation, is gone.
The Giants are dead.
The Centaurs are dead.
The Birds have fled.
We are going to bury Your Room.
We cannot risk hurting you.
This is our goodbye.
Maybe one day, Your Family can build another
Room.
This may be a hollow hope, but We will cherish
this thought.”
An hour later, the box began to convulse violently
and let out more plumes of thick, black smoke.
For a moment, the researchers entertained
the hope that it might be the return of the
dragons - but no such luck.
The box began to sag, tear, and collapse,
as though it was on fire on the inside.
Parts of the box even began to char, and small
holes were burned through the silver paint.
Perhaps the saddest of all, the words “Here
Be Dragons” were burned from the box.
Not long after, one more message appeared
inside the box.
It was a papyrus scroll, depicting a hand
drawn image of a beautiful, mountainous landscape
with huge trees and waterfalls.
In the distance, a dragon appears to fly away
for the last time.
A message written on the back read as follows:
“Master says that we won't see You again.
We are sad.
So are the remaining Others.
We once filled each other's heads with dreams
and goals.
It is so sad that we cannot share them any
longer.
Master says we have to go.
He says that he will make us a new Fantasy.
He says You cannot be a part of it.
We are sad.
We love you.
We will not Forget you.
We are scared.
Will You Forget Us?”
When this document was removed, streams of
salt water began to leak from the box, healing
its burn scars.
A few minutes later, the box was returned
to its original state, save for one big difference:
The text scrawled on the lid no longer read
“Here Be Dragons.”
Now, it said “Here Were Dragons.”
The Jabberwocky Event was over.
The box, now neutralized, would sit in Yoshihiro
Takenaka’s office for commemorative purposes,
never to release another message.
Or so we thought...
In 2015, SCP - 1762 spoke to us one more time.
The box shook and began emitting great plumes
of purple smoke, before it fell to the ground.
There it ejected two objects: A purple crystal,
later identified as an amethyst, and a large,
leather-bound book.
The box continued emitting smoke for another
forty minutes, before finally disintegrating.
Upon further inspection, there was a single
message carved into the amethyst:
“One last time.”
And what about the book?
Consider the greatest fear of the inhabitants
of Fantasy: That they would one day be forgotten.
Forgotten and left behind - by us.
The book was sent to help prevent that - it’s
an extensive catalogue of the creatures of
Fantasy - their strange and wonderful ways
in their strange and wonderful world.
Even if they’re gone, they won’t be forgotten.
And perhaps one day we’ll tell you those
stories too.
But that’s a tale for another day...
The Young Girl stood silently in a room full
of corpses, staring off into the distance.
She was in a trance, seemingly unaware of
the carnage that’d just unfolded around
her. Some of the men were shot or stabbed
or beaten, others had no apparent cause of
death whatsoever. But the Young Girl was unscathed.
She was wearing a yellow summer dress and
looked like she couldn’t have been more
than three years old. She awoke from her trance,
still paying no heed to the violence in the
room, and left.
This is the story of SCP - 053, the Young
Girl. Her strange and terrifying life before
containment, her thrilling capture, and the
part she played in one of the most dangerous
SCP Foundation cross-tests of all time.
She had no name. The Young Girl could never
spend enough time around someone to be given
one. It was her terrible curse that she could
never stay in one place for too long, or something
truly awful would happen to everyone around
her. She’d been drifting for years, but
never grew to look older than a child. Her
memories were long but formless - divided
mostly into ten-minute increments. The Young
Girl kept on moving. It was all she could
do.
In 1993, when the Young Girl had already been
alive for a very long time, she found herself
in Illinois after days of trekking on the
roadside. She would scavenge what little food
she needed from the trash, and drink from
lakes, rivers, or even puddles when she needed
to. Deep down, the Young Girl knew that even
if she grew hungry or thirsty, she would not
die.
In her travels, the Young Girl had managed
to scrounge together a few dollars, and though
she knew her contact with people had to be
limited, there was one thing she wanted that
felt worth the risk: A candy bar. It’d been
a long time since she tasted chocolate, and
she found the idea of tasting it again too
enticing to resist. When she reached Chicago,
she entered a small corner store with her
handful of dollars, selected a candy bar from
the rack, and approached the counter. For
reasons even she didn’t fully understand,
she kept her eyes down as she placed the money
on the counter.
You see, SCP - 053 was always a special child.
As we briefly mentioned earlier, you might
even say she was cursed. Whenever she was
around other people for too long, terrible
things tended to happen. Unspeakable things.
And as a component of this strange, unexplainable
curse - or perhaps as a means of keeping her
safe from it - the Young Girl was doomed to
never understand the nature of her predicament.
It was like there was a mental wall between
her and the horrors her presence could cause.
All she knew was that it was best to avoid
eye contact, stay away from large groups of
people at all costs, and never spend any longer
than ten minutes around anyone. Ever. That’s
why, as she waited for her chocolate bar at
the cash register, she kept her head down
and waited to go.
The cashier looked down upon this strange
girl with apparent concern. It’d been a
slow day, all in all. A few listless patrons
milled around the store, window shopping.
His brain was practically on autopilot, until
he saw this child. She looked filthy, in a
dishevelled dress and was totally alone. What
on earth had happened to this child? The more
he looked at her, the more he sensed a creepy
vibe exuding from her. Something about this
girl was wrong.
He spoke softly to her, introducing himself
as Miles, and asking her where her mommy and
daddy were. The Young Girl hesitated for just
a few seconds too long for his liking, before
simply saying that they were at home. Any
parent who’d let their three-year-old kid
just wander around the South Side of Chicago
alone was either crazy, neglectful, or both.
He asked her politely to remain in the store,
while he gave the police a quick call. He’d
even let her have the candy bar for free while
she waited.
Immediately, the little girl became uncomfortable.
She’d already been in here for a few minutes
now, and while Miles called the police he
expected her to wait around even longer. Again,
she couldn’t even tell you why she knew
waiting around like this would be so dangerous,
but she had a nagging, instinctual awareness
that she needed to get out. Around the store,
the few patrons still inside started to get
a strange feeling, like someone was watching
them.
Soon, what seemed like mild paranoia was quickly
becoming white-hot anger. Pure rage. They
felt almost like they had to kill someone.
But not just anyone. Someone particular. They
had to kill the little girl.
It wasn’t long until the police arrived.
Two officers, Holiday and DeWitt, entered
to collect the apparently neglected little
girl. It was a story they’d sadly heard
all too often - a tragically common occurrence
in the big city. When the two of them approached
the Young Girl, she was looking down at the
ground. They tried to speak to her but she
was unresponsive. Miles looked on, concerned,
but deep down, he felt the same bizarre progression
all the other store-goers were feeling: Confusion,
irritability, and finally... violent rage.
The corner store was a powder keg, all it
needed now was a spark.
And that spark came when Officer Holiday reached
down, and took the Young Girl by the arm.
His bare skin touched her’s, and it was
all over. The cop twitched, his mind washed
out in murderous insanity, as he reached for
his side-arm. Officer DeWitt opened his mouth
to protest, but he didn’t manage to get
a syllable out before Holiday turned and shot
him. In a fraction of a second, the quiet
corner store exploded into a violent bloodbath,
as the patrons and cops slaughtered each other.
All the while, the Young Girl just stood there
in a trance.
Everyone was dead within minutes, except Miles
and the Young Girl. He shakily rose to his
feet, his mind carved out by madness, and
reached for Officer Holiday’s discarded
pistol.
Outside of the store, The Young Girl appeared,
walking out as if nothing had happened. Inside,
Miles’s body was sprawled over the counter,
clutching his chest as if his heart had just
exploded.
This was the true nature of the Young Girl’s
curse. Anyone who meets her eye, touches her
skin, or spends over ten minutes around her
is destined to slip into a state of murderous
insanity. They’ll go into a kill-crazy frenzy,
and attack anyone around them, until all that’s
left is them and the Young Girl. At which
point, they’ll try to kill her, too - but
the mere act of attempting to kill her is
also fatal, killing its victims with a massive
heart attack or a seizure. The second part
of the girl’s curse is that she herself
can never die.
She keeps coming back, unknowingly causing
more misery and death along the way. Until,
of course, a certain secret organization took
notice.
That night, the Young Girl sat in the cavernous
interior of a local abandoned warehouse, quietly
eating her hard-earned candy bar. Suddenly,
she heard a quiet “crack” in the distance.
She tried to move her left arm, but found
it was numb. She could barely move it. The
Girl turned her head, and saw a tranquilizer
dart sticking out of her skin. Instinctively,
she got up and began to run, limping as her
left leg started to lose all feeling too.
Suddenly, she was surrounded by footsteps,
as masked men in SWAT uniforms emerged out
of the darkness on all sides. The last thing
she remembered before slipping out of consciousness
was a blindfold being pulled over her eyes,
and tiny metal handcuffs clasping over her
wrists.
When she woke up, she was in the nicest room
she’d slept in in years. It was sixteen
feet by sixteen feet, with toys, books, and
games. Standing across the room from her was
a stranger in a full hazmat suit, connected
to a long, steel cable leading out of the
room. He spoke calmly and politely. A timer
on his wrist counted down from ten minutes.
The stranger explained to the Young Girl that
they would be taking care of her now, and
would provide her with all the toys and games
and treats she wanted, provided she cooperated
and submitted willingly to some tests.
Compared to living out on the streets with
no food or comfort, this seemed like an excellent
compromise. She would live in what seemed
like luxury, and every so often, she’d be
taken to a testing room with a stranger in
an orange jumpsuit. After a few minutes of
waiting, the stranger would inevitably go
feral, and attempt to kill her - and then
always die in the process. The strangers in
the hazmat suits told her that all of these
tests were helping them learn extremely valuable
things about her, and that soon, they’d
have a very special job for her. It would
be a wonderful surprise.
It was in the spring of 1994 that the Young
Girl, now officially designated SCP - 053,
finally received her special mission. Several
strangers in full hazmat suits, wielding rifles,
escorted her out of her usual bedroom. She
asked where she was being taken, and was told
she was going to meet a new friend. She was
taken to one of the recreational testing rooms,
and pushed inside. Out in front of her, she
saw something terrifying: A giant, reptilian
creature.
She retreated from it instinctually, hiding
behind a chair in the containment area. The
giant reptile didn’t move. It just sat there.
Eventually, she plucked up the courage to
go and touch the creature, before retreating
again. No reaction. Little by little, the
Young Girl gained confidence, and continued
to approach and pat the creature. It exhaled
through its huge nostrils, and the Young Girl
literally jumped for joy in her amusement.
She began to play with the docile monster,
hugging it, even drawing on it with a crayon.
The observers were truly baffled. What the
Young Girl didn’t know was that she was
playing with SCP - 682, one of the most hateful
and aggressive anomalies under the Foundation’s
watchful eye. And yet, in her presence, the
creature was like an overgrown puppy dog.
After the test phase, the Young Girl was removed
from the Hard-To-Kill Reptile’s presence,
immediately causing the creature to become
violent and murderous once again. After being
separated from her strange new friend, the
Young Girl was seen crying for several minutes.
According to all accounts, the Young Girl
is eager to see her friend again some day,
though considering the Reptile killed several
guards after their separation, the Foundation
isn’t eager to grant her that wish.
SCP-053 was classified as Euclid and continues
to be held in containment, with her toys,
books, and games rotated out on a regular
basis. Seeing as she shows no sign of aging,
this ongoing containment is likely to be the
sad, strange fate of the Young Girl. An anomaly
that never wanted to hurt anyone - but an
important and cruel reminder that what we
want doesn’t always influence the world
in the way we want.
Over fifty men and women, clad in red robes,
kneel before an unholy altar.
They chant and mutter indecipherable words
- words of cruelty and madness… of obsession
and sacrilege.
Not long ago, these were regular people.
Computer technicians, teachers, plumbers,
construction workers, accountants.
This was before they fell under the ungodly
influence of a new ruler.
The center of this makeshift place of worship
was once a normal school gymnasium, but it’s
now the home of a huge statue.
A humanoid being, wreathed in tentacles.
Its head is more like a squid or cuttlefish
than anything resembling an actual human face.
While he’s known to the cultists as the
Tentacled God, the beast they worship is known
to the SCP Foundation as SCP - 2662, and he
sits in the belly of one of their expansive
containment facilities, locked away from the
world.
But not for long, if his devoted followers
have anything to say about it.
This is their god, all-powerful and unchanging,
and when it comes to springing him from containment,
no tactic is too vile or underhanded to get
the job done.
Their mortal leader and high-priest, a man
in a purple robe calling himself Brother Marsh,
walks among their crouched forms.
He whispers instructions for the great day
of liberation that’s soon to come, providing
everyone plays their part.
It’s a plan months in the making - and one
that, if it goes off without a hitch, could
free their monstrous god into the world.
They would strike at the very heart of their
enemy, The SCP Foundation, when they least
expect it, and nothing shall stand in their
way.
How could they lose when they have a god on
their side?
But why did all these normal people become
violent zealots for squid-faced deity?
It all began with a dream.
To those who experienced these dreams, they
felt more like prophecies, premonitions of
the glorious horrors to come.
A red sky, billions dead and billions more
enslaved.
A dark silhouette on the horizon - Their Tentacled
God, holding dominion over all.
At first, it just seemed like a strange nightmare.
The ones who experienced it woke up shaken
and afraid, hoping to shake the images from
their mind.
But they couldn’t.
Every night, the nightmare would return.
They’d see the images - the red sky, the
dead and enslaved, the Tentacled God.
And after a while it would come to them even
when they weren’t asleep, eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes.
Little by little, this scene stopped looking
so hideous… and started to look glorious.
They felt his presence in their minds, slowly
pushing them towards their inevitable future.
They started to realize that they wanted him
to rule over the universe, and to experience
the honor of serving him.
Many of them abandoned their homes and families
- leaving their friends and loved ones left
to worry that they’d gone insane.
In their eyes, they were safer than they’d
ever been.
They finally had purpose.
They were working in service of something
far greater than themselves.
The influence of the tentacled god drew them
closer to one another.
They would meet in secret, exchanging information
from the prophecies their ruler sent them
in their dreams.
They worshipped together, building altars
and idols to congregate around.
They performed dark blood rituals, involving
human and animal sacrifice.
It was when Brother Marsh, The Anointed One,
arrived to guide them towards their true mission
that things kicked into high gear.
Just three months prior, Brother Marsh had
been an office drone working in data entry
for a large insurance company, before the
Tentacled God invaded his thoughts with a
simple message: “FREE ME, AND THE NEW WORLD
I CREATE SHALL BE YOUR PLAYGROUND.”
Since then, he’d devoted himself completely
to the cause, quitting his job and maxing
out his credit cards to help fund his new
life’s purpose - infiltrating the SCP Foundation,
and releasing his inhuman ruler from its imprisonment.
That was the single goal he united the cultists
under: Freedom for the Tentacled God.
And at long last, they had all the pieces
in place to strike.
They’d finally gathered the necessary intel
to subvert the will of the most powerful secret
organization on earth.
Even the strongest institution is made of
people, and people are weak.
Unlike the almighty Tentacled God, people
could be broken.
The people in question were Kelly Thompson,
Sidney Levitt, Jordan Brosh, Dr. Juan Gutierrez,
and Gillian Larson.
Dr. Juan Gutierrez was a researcher with Level
3 clearance on the site where the Tentacled
God was being contained.
Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were both Security
Officers charged with verifying personnel
clearance on site.
Kelly Thompson was a member of Site Administration
with research authorization powers, and Gillian
Larson was a research assistant who often
collaborated with Dr. Gutierrez.
These five were the key to getting access
to SCP-2662 and bringing their plan to fruition.
Normally, personnel dossiers on people working
for the Foundation were highly confidential,
but the Devotees of the Tentacled God had
their ways.
They had a number of computer experts in their
ranks more than capable of hacking in and
pulling some basic information off of Foundation
servers without being detected.
For the other information they needed they
turned to some good, old-fashioned torture,
which is often the most effective method when
you need some quick results.
Of course, while the cult’s grip on sanity
may have been a little tenuous, they weren’t
stupid.
While gathering their intel, they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were up
against.
SCP-2662 was being held in a humanoid containment
cell, and guarded by on-site Task Force TAU-9,
better known as the “Belligerent Bodyguards.”
These aren’t lazy, donut-chomping mall cops
- these are a heavily trained, heavily armed
fighting force.
Though the cultists had one thing that these
Foundation soldiers didn’t: The element
of surprise.
For everything to go off perfectly, Brother
Marsh’s plans would have to be executed
within a single day, and they were already
on the clock.
TAU-9 had been charged with tracking down
any new SCP - 2662 cults and dismantling them,
and Brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the Foundation tracked
them down and did the same to them.
If they wanted any chance of freeing the Tentacled
God, then they needed to strike quickly and
with overwhelming force.
The SCP-2662 worshippers were able to secure
the addresses of the five key Foundation personnel,
and station members outside each of them - including
one who could realistically imitate each.
They waited for night to fall, and broke into
each of their homes as they slept.
What followed was a sequence of ruthless and
efficient murders done in the cause of freeing
their god.
Dr. Gutierrez was shot in the head while he
slept.
Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were both stabbed
to death before either even realized what
was happening.
Thompson, who’d gotten up to use the bathroom,
went down in a hail of machine gun fire.
Gillian Larson had seen that masked figures
were breaking into her home and attempted
to flee, but was caught and beaten to death
by cultists in her hallway.
It was a strange irony that people whose day
jobs entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies imaginable
were murdered in their homes by nothing more
than regular humans.
So far, Brother Marsh’s plan had gone perfectly,
with all five key personnel murdered within
a two minute period.
Next, the selected doppelgängers stole clothes
from their victims’ closets and were handed
the correct forged documentation.
The next morning, each replacement began their
journeys to the site where the Tentacled God
was being contained, while the rest of the
cult armed themselves in preparation for their
own part in the plan.
Nobody at the Foundation seemed to notice
anything amiss when the five arrived on site.
When you work for the SCP Foundation, more
mental energy is devoted to following the
rules that keep you alive than to memorizing
the faces of all your co-workers and each
one slipped neatly into position, disappearing
into the familiarity of office life.
But, infiltrating the site was one thing,
getting past the Belligerent Bodyguards and
into the cell of the Tentacled God would be
another thing entirely.
That’s where the rest of the cult would
come into play.
Heavily armed with whatever firearms they
could get their hands on, the rest of the
Devotees of the Tentacled God - Brother Marsh
included - would attack the containment site
head-on.
In the ensuing chaos, the five cultists who
had already infiltrated the site could take
advantage of the distraction, and break into
the containment chamber.
It was perfect.
They’d launch their attack from the outside…
and from within.
When Brother Marsh declared that the time
was right, the assault began.
A legion of gun-wielding cultists seemed to
spring out of nowhere and started shooting
up the warehouse that was a front for the
containment site.
The site quickly mobilized guards and task
force members to take on the sudden threat,
and just as Brother Marsh had anticipated,
the Site Director called on the majority of
TAU-9 to help repel the violent cultists from
their perimeter.
TAU-9 obeyed, leaving three task force members
behind to guard SCP - 2662’s containment
chamber.
They expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an audience
with their god.
What they didn’t expect was a group of five
Foundation employees walking right up to them
and opening fire, killing two TAU-9 members
and taking the third as a hostage.
While the war was being waged outside, the
infiltrators had found the Tentacled God’s
containment cell in the low-risk humanoid
ward.
Their hostage insisted that using him wouldn’t
give them any leverage - the rest of his team
would neutralize the whole group, him included,
if that’s what it took to stop them.
The infiltrators explained that using him
as leverage was never their intention - he
wasn’t a hostage at all.
He was a sacrifice.
The cultists of the Tentacled God detonated
explosives, creating a hole in the wall and
finally giving them access to their deity.
They climbed through and gazed upon him in
awe.
There stood SCP-2662, twice as tall as a regular
man, with ten huge tentacles emerging from
its back.
In their months of envisioning this creature,
they’d pictured it sitting on a throne made
of thousands of human bones, ready to dictate
its commands to the obedient liberators.
What they certainly didn’t expect was to
see the Tentacled God hunched over a computer
screen.
Still, gods work in mysterious ways, so they
stuck to the plan and began chanting.
They pulled out a sacrificial dagger, and
began sacrificing their captured TAU-9 member.
It was at this point that SCP - 2662 turned
and saw what they were doing with a look of
pure horror.
He rose up from his computer, his headphones
getting caught as he did so.
He told them to go away, that he didn’t
want them here, and that them murdering people
in his bedroom like this was inconsiderate
and disgusting.
The cultists became even more confused - why
wasn’t their god accepting their offerings?
What were they doing wrong?
They tried more chanting, and painting arcane
symbols on the floor in blood, but this just
seemed to make the creature angrier.
He told them, in a tone more fitting for a
teenage boy than a Lovecraftian God, to just
leave him alone so he could play his video
games.
This was seriously not cool!
The cultists were baffled.
They told the Tentacled God they were there
to free him.
He replied that he didn’t need saving.
That crazy stalkers like them were why he
turned himself in to the Foundation in the
first place!
Before the cultist infiltrators could get
another word in, the remaining members of
TAU-9 stormed into the containment cell and
gunned them down with surgical precision.
The war outside was already over - Brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were all
killed in the firefight.
TAU-9 didn’t look the least bit surprised
upon entering 2662’s cell, this was a common
occurrence unfortunately.
They had to deal with an attempted cult invasion
every few months, because SCP-2662’s main
anomalous ability is inspiring violent cults
who relentlessly track down and worship it
with arcane and bloodthirsty rituals.
The problem is, 2662 doesn’t do this consciously,
and definitely doesn’t like the results.
That’s why he’s under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him amused
with video games and reading material while
fending off the deranged cults who try to
invade and abduct him.
Following the termination of The Devotees
of the Tentacled God, just one of many cults
who’d broken into 2662’s containment cell,
the remaining TAU-9 members apologized to
the tentacled creature for the disturbance,
allowing him to return to his gaming.
They assured him that it’d probably be at
least a few more months before something like
this happened again.
SCP-2662’s cell was repaired, and the Foundation
returned to its task of seeking out would-be
cultist emancipators, because for the SCP
Foundation, it’s not always about the anomaly
that’s being kept in containment, but what’s
being kept out.
“This is impossible!”
The SCP site director wasn’t normally a
calm or cheerful man, but the researcher had
rarely seen him as angry as he was right now.
His face turned a deep beet red as he scanned
the documents on his desk before he asked
how months of valuable research on this subject
had suddenly gone blank, the data was completely
gone.
The researcher gulped nervously, hoping a
demotion wasn’t in his future, and nodded.
How could this be possible.
This was an experienced researcher who should
have been taking all of the necessary precautions.
Could the being they were studying somehow
have erased all these documents himself?
That’s just what the researcher had been
trying to find out for months, with hours
and hours spent trying to learn the extent
of its abilities.
“Well?
Where are they?” the site director asked.
“I want everything you have!”
The researcher dropped a print-out of their
research on the mysterious subject’s abilities
on the director’s desk.
Every relevant line read “Data Lost”.
The director let out a deep sigh.
He wanted to hear everything the researcher
knew, well everything he could remember at
least, from the beginning.
The researcher sat town and began to relay
everything he could about SCP-343, which some
of the other researchers had started to refer
to by the nickname…
God.
SCP-343 was first sighted in Prague, just
an unassuming older man wandering the streets.
He seemed completely normal to everyone who
passed him by - until he decided he was tired
of staying on the ground.
An SCP agent stationed in the area noticed
the old man disappear from the streets as
if he was blinking out of existence - only
to appear on a rooftop nearby.
The local SCP teams were marshalled, and they
had soon tracked down what seemed to be a
very powerful specimen.
But SCP-343 didn’t seem concerned.
He reacted calmly when detained by the foundation
and went with them willingly.
He was detained in a standard holding cell
for interrogation and examination, but he
seemed completely at ease with his sudden
confinement.
It would soon become clear that this ordinary
old man was anything but.
Doctors Beck and Ndlovu were brought in to
consult on the SCP’s classification, and
that’s when the first anomalies began.
Their assessments matched initially, but when
it came time to describe him physically, things
took a strange turn.
Older male, seemingly non-descript and with
no unusual physical features.
Caucasian in appearance.
Doctor Ndlovu was confused by what Doctor
Beck was describing in his report.
This man was clearly black.
The two doctors quarrelled, unable to square
their differing perceptions.
They decided to bring in a third impartial
view to settle it - their fellow researcher,
Dr. Wan.
She didn’t take long before coming back
with her assessment.
Older male, seemingly non-descript and with
no unusual physical features.
Asian in appearance, possibly Chinese.
Whatever SCP-343 was, he seemed to be perceived
by each staff member as close in appearance
to their own race.
But that was only the start of the anomalies
surrounding the old man in the holding cell.
Dr. Beck started making regular visits to
the mysterious man, and in their first interview,
he asked the old man who he was and how he
came by his abilities.
The old man had a simple response.
“I created this universe.”
Dr. Beck stifled a laugh and decided to indulge
the old man’s delusion.
It was a fascinating claim, but could he prove
it?
Without another word, SCP-343 got up from
his chair, laughed, and turned around and
walked through the solid wall in the holding
cell and disappeared.
Dr. Beck was about to hit the panic button
and marshall the facility’s security to
find him when the strange man reappeared,
walking through the solid wall.
The only thing that was different?
He was holding a hamburger, which he sat down
and enjoyed.
The facility quickly went on lockdown and
a full investigation was done into how SCP-343
breached containment.
But there was no evidence of any security
breach, no failures in containment, and no
evidence of any other cells failing.
SCP-343 hadn’t broken through the security
- he had just ignored it, as if it wasn’t
there at all.
When questioned about how he had gone on his
hamburger run, he simply repeated his belief
that he was God - in between bites of his
fast food treat.
This would be far from the only time strange
things happened around SCP-343.
SCP containment cells are as secure as they
need to be, but even the least-strict containment
isn’t known for its decor.
Which is why Dr. Beck was in for a surprise
the next time he paid a visit to SCP-343.
The bare-bones cell now looked like a comfortable
home, decorated in Old English fashions.
The scientists assumed that SCP-343 had been
making many more trips out of his cell to
get accessories to feel more at home - but
that didn’t explain all the changes to the
cell.
No one could explain how he had installed
a roaring fireplace in the containment cell
- and everyone who entered could swear the
cell looked many times bigger than any other
cell in the facility.
SCP-343 wasn’t just breaking containment
- he now seemed to be breaking the laws of
physics in the facility.
The rules of the SCP containment facility
didn’t seem to be a concern to SCP-343,
but there was one thing he didn’t seem to
want to do - escape.
After every sudden exit, he would always return
to his personal cell and treat it as his home.
When interviewed by staff members, he was
polite but vague, and everyone seemed to enjoy
talking to him.
It was decided to keep him on site, not attempt
to increase his security, but restrict access
and keep his room guarded at all times to
ensure only researchers with Level 3 access
and above were allowed to meet with him.
But God works in mysterious ways.
Minimal Security Site 17 was one of the less-restrictive
SCP containment sites, hosting anomalies that
could be safely contained and weren’t likely
to mount violent escapes.
But as in every SCP facility, security was
still taken seriously and only those with
proper clearance could interact with the subjects.
So why did SCP-343 seem impossible to guard?
While only Level 3 clearance and above were
allowed in, the guards assigned to protect
the entrance all seemed to fall down on the
job.
Security Officer James, who was supposed to
be keeping people out of SCP-343’s cell,
had instead let in multiple visitors in addition
to dropping in several times himself.
When questioned on why he had gone against
orders and done so, he simply replied that
343 seemed lonely and was so happy every time
he got company that it just seemed like the
right thing to do.
The security guard was reassigned and new
ones were brought in - but history repeated
itself.
Guards were given stricter instructions to
minimize exposure - but SCP-343’s presence
always seemed to influence them anyway.
His containment cell was a revolving door,
with staff members at the facility entering
regularly for friendly conversations.
Dr. Beck decided it was time to take matters
into his own hands.
He would meet with SCP-343 one-on-one and
express how dangerous these security breaches
were.
He would try to convince the mysterious being
that he needed to stop influencing the minds
of the guards watching him, or the facility
would have to look into new measures to contain
him.
Dr. Beck entered the containment cell and
had a long conversation with SCP-343, and
when he emerged...he had a big smile on his
face, like he had just finished a reunion
with an old friend.
He gave the current guard a friendly clap
on the back, and told him not to worry so
much about security.
After all, nothing bad was going to happen
from letting people at the facility visit
SCP-343, right?
He wasn’t dangerous in any way.
He also said that security should bring him
anything he requests so he would feel less
need to leave his cell.
Minimal Security Site 17 soon became a model
SCP facility, with morale being the highest
of any site - with most giving the credit
to the presence of SCP-343.
Employees generally make daily visits to his
chambers, and he seems to have an encyclopedic
knowledge of anything they want to talk about
- including things he should have no way of
knowing.
Guards no longer quit their posts or break
protocol, as their only real duty is to keep
track of who meets with SCP-343 so they can
be interviewed and debriefed after.
Everyone’s conversation is different, but
they all report being in a better mood after
leaving than when they came in.
No further information is available on SCP-343’s
origins, the full extent of his powers, or
whether he is telling the truth about being
the God who created the universe.
The site director rubbed his temples after
hearing the researcher’s explanation.
“So what you’re telling me is that we
have an uncontained, highly powerful SCP that
has not only been breaking containment whenever
it wants, but has managed to destroy all the
files regarding the research on it?”
The researcher’s answer was yes.
However, the situation at Site 17 seemed to
be stable, and they had come up with a plan
that should help to maximize the positive
effect SCP-343 has on the facility.
They were even hypothesizing that staff from
other sites and even certain anomalies could
be pacified by 343’s presence.
The site director wasn’t impressed though.
He wanted the researcher to go back to the
drawing board and redo the research.
After all, if all the files were blank, how
could they ever learn how to properly contain
it?
That’s what the C in SCP stood for after
all - containment.
The researcher finally had to stand up to
the director though, and told them that it
wasn’t a good idea.
That they had already tried everything to
contain SCP-343, but that it wasn’t that
he broke containment, it was as if he didn’t
even acknowledge that an attempt had been
made to contain him.
He was omnipotent, aware of things he shouldn’t,
and able to do things that broke the laws
of physics without breaking a sweat.
There was no evidence that this was God, the
creator of the universe as he claimed to be,
but there also wasn’t any evidence yet to
conclusively prove he wasn’t.
The researcher’s best guess was that this
was a powerful reality bender whose abilities
knew no limits, and that the only reason he
was staying in the facility was because he
wanted to, and doing anything to change that
might cause him to change his benevolent ways.
The director sighed.
As much as he hated to admit it, his researcher
was making good points.
He wanted to meet SCP-343 personally.
But did he need to know anything first?
“Well, sir…” the researcher replied,
“he likes hamburgers.
But beyond that, he’ll take care of the
rest.
He’s right where we left him, in his home
- waiting for his next guest.”
An SCP Foundation researcher sits at a table
inside of a standard containment cell.
These are often dangerous places to be, especially
when the SCP you’re supposed to be studying
is one that you can’t see.
The researcher is taking notes, unsure of
exactly what’s going to happen next.
He can hear the sounds of knives scraping
behind, of flesh sizzling and searing from
high heat.
He braces himself as a burst of heat hits
the back of his head, as if a fireball has
erupted.
Just then it happens - an object floats through
the air and settles in front of him on the
table.
It’s a plate of food, and it looks delicious.
It may surprise you to learn that there is
no rule that the SCP Foundation must deal
exclusively with violent and vicious creatures.
Not every SCP held in containment shares the
same malevolence and contempt for humanity
as SCP-682, or the world-ending threat posed
by the likes of SCP-2317.
Some - perhaps not many, but some - are benign
and might even seem outwardly friendly, but
you’d still be taking a huge risk to assume
that anything contained by the SCP Foundation
is completely harmless.
Such is the case with SCP-5031.
As per the Foundation’s containment procedures,
this quasi-humanoid – meaning it appears
to have some vaguely human features - is held
in an airtight cell that is regularly checked
by Foundation personnel on a bi-weekly basis.
SCP-5031 has no need for regular nutrition
or regular interactions from staff.
The trick with SCP-5031, is not being eaten
by it, since though it doesn’t need food,
it does still hunt and consume anything it
encounters - human or otherwise.
Avoiding being eaten is hard enough with creatures
that can actually be seen, but like so many
other creatures the Foundation keeps contained,
SCP-5031 has developed an almost-perfect defense
mechanism - which is that when observed, it
will literally cease to exist.
Some might choose to refer to this as a ‘quantum
lock’, however it is worth noting that traces
left by SCP-5031 still remain observable when
the creature has temporarily disappeared.
For example, trails of blood and scratch marks
left behind by SCP-5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does not.
Naturally, this makes both avoiding the creature
and capturing it using cameras difficult.
However, when SCP-5031’s existence ceases
it still casts a shadow.
From this, researchers have been able to determine
several of the creature’s physical traits.
Based on its silhouette, it has been deduced
that SCP-5031 levitates about half a meter
above ground level, it sports an abnormally
small, neckless head atop an elongated torso
- approximately 1.9 meters long - with three
sets of spindly lower arms that branch outwards.
Using these arms and its loosely hanging body,
SCP-5031 will lower itself to hunt any human
or animal that draws near to it and uses the
bladelike tail to cut up food.
Perhaps the most interesting facet of SCP-5031
beyond its defensive capabilities and apparent
physical attributes, are the series of nine
tests conducted by Senior Researcher Stanley
Huxtable.
Appalled by the conditions that the creature
was being kept in, Huxtable took over the
role of HCL Supervisor for SCP-5031.
Having grown increasingly frustrated and empathetic
towards the creature, listening to its screams
from inside its iron containment unit, Huxtable
devised a series of tests to introduce SCP-5031
to various different stimuli as a way to better
understand the creature and hopefully keep
it contained in a way that didn’t seem to
cause so much suffering.
It's worth remembering that the SCP Foundation
makes it its mission to be cold, not cruel,
in performing their duties to protect normality
and many of the researchers and staff are
just as capable of having empathy for creatures
as you might for a stray animal at a shelter.
The first of Huxtable’s tests involved installing
speakers in SCP-5031’s cell, through which
a variety of different ambient and popular
pieces of music were played to see if they
had any effect on reducing the creature’s
stress.
By judging SCP-5031’s stress levels based
on how much it screamed when compared to normal,
Huxtable was able to determine how to best
to use music to calm the creature.
SCP-5031 seemed to convey higher levels of
stress when listening to ‘Morning Forest’,
‘Deep Grotto’ and ‘Seaside Paradise’
ambience, as well as the best of late 60s
British rock band Jethro Tull.
However, the best of Mozart, Enya, KISS and
Ben Folds produced dramatically different
results, decreasing SCP-5031’s apparent
stress.
Following this test, Senior Researcher Huxtable
compiled a playlist featuring SCP-5031’s
favorite music.
Over time, the stress-reducing effects of
music on SCP-5031 seemed to decrease, but
keeping the playlist on shuffle seemed to
keep the creature consistently calmer than
it had been previously.
The next test involved introducing inanimate
objects into SCP-5031’s enclosure to monitor
its reactions and how its stress levels were
affected.
When a softball was thrown into the enclosure,
SCP-5031 immediately sliced the ball in two
with its tail in one swift motion.
A similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature a basketball, which was
quickly punctured and sliced open by SCP-5031’s
tail.
Its stress levels first seemed to diminish
when the creature was offered a bowling ball,
which it rolled around the enclosure and then
later knocked against a second bowling ball.
However, when one of the balls chipped, rendering
it unable to roll properly, SCP-5031’s stress
increased dramatically, until a replacement
was offered.
Researcher Huxtable noted that SCP-5031 seemed
to possess a similar level of motor skills
to an average human toddler, with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to match.
Next, when given the choice between two food
sources at opposite ends of its enclosure,
SCP-5031 seemed to gravitate towards higher-quality
food, most notably favoring cooked rotisserie
chickens over animal carcasses.
It even chose this option over a live chicken,
using its tail to cut its food into more manageable
bite-sized portions, rather than ripping its
meat with its hands or teeth like many of
its fellow SCPs.
Researcher Huxtable recorded these findings
and highlighted that, even though SCP-5031
didn’t need to eat in order to survive,
providing the creature with food of a better
quality marginally reduced its stress.
Senior Researcher Huxtable next attempted
to test SCP-5031’s coexistence with other
living subjects, each time making sure that
the creature had been adequately fed to avoid
any unseemly incidents.
First, a live chicken was introduced.
SCP-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high speed
towards the chicken, increasing both its and
the chicken’s stress levels, and inadvertently
killing the chicken in the process.
When a second chicken was introduced, SCP-5031
gently rolled a basketball towards it but
ceased any further engagement after the chicken
squawked from being hit by the ball.
Next to be introduced into the enclosure was
a blindfolded D Class staff member, who was
instructed to sit down and roll the basketball
towards SCP-5031.
After doing so for several minutes, the creature
began to approach the D class subject, who
was instructed to remove their blindfold to
cease the creature’s existence and prevent
any potentially deadly incidents.
Finally, Researcher Huxtable had another Class-D
engage in a game of catch with SCP-5031 while
facing away from the creature.
This test proceeded successfully, and Senior
Researcher Huxtable remarked how SCP-5031’s
motor skills were improving.
Albeit gradually, and with some gentle encouragement,
through Huxtable’s tests the creature was
learning.
The next test, focused on teaching SCP-5031
linguistic symbols, utilized LCD displays
and buttons connected to a food dispenser.
One display showed an image of a rock, and
the other an image of a rotisserie chicken.
After some brief probing, SCP-5031 was quickly
able to understand that pressing the button
under the correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat.
The creature was later able to adapt when,
the following day, the screen displays and
materials dispensed were swapped, and then
later set to swap at random intervals.
When additional rock-dispensing stations were
introduced, this time displaying the word
‘rock’ as opposed to an image, SCP-5031
was able to determine which station dispensed
‘chicken’ through a process of elimination.
Whenever the functions and displays were swapped,
SCP-5031 would find whichever displayed the
word ‘chicken’ to receive its food.
The final phase of this test presented SCP-5031
with a single station, displaying the word
‘chicken’, but with a button that would
remain inactive unless the creature spelled
out the same word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with.
After some initial confusion and frustration
as to why the button would not dispense food
when pressed, SCP-5031 was able to assemble
the word correctly, not only activating the
button and dispensing food, but proving to
Researcher Huxtable that the creature was
capable of learning language.
Huxtable continued to test the creature, encouraging
it to spell words using lettered blocks as
a method of communicating.
By increasing SCP-5031’s vocabulary and
the amount of human interaction it received,
Senior Researcher Huxtable observed that SCP-5031
was gradually learning to sing - albeit nonverbally
- as well as to juggle with its six hands
and was even communicating its own food preferences
and dish pairings.
Later, another Class-D, D-52125, was introduced
to SCP-5031’s enclosure to aid in further
testing.
Through D-52125’s instructions, the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons, and
created artworks depicting itself, its newfound
friend D-52125, Researcher Huxtable, a cat
and a rotisserie chicken.
SCP-5031’s new creative side didn’t stop
there though, as the creature quickly learned
to play Chopsticks in only two days once a
piano was introduced into the enclosure.
SCP-5031 even managed to start creating its
own original, admittedly crude, compositions.
Next, a spice rack was placed inside the creature’s
cell and D-52125 demonstrated how to season
meat.
This proved to be SCP-5031’s new favorite
hobby, as it spent the next three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and spices,
using its letter blocks to request ‘more,
more, more’ garlic powder.
Interestingly, the creature only created artwork
or music when D-52125 was present, but seemed
to thoroughly enjoy its experimentation with
food when left alone.
Following this development, Senior Researcher
Huxtable devised a new test for SCP-5031.
Providing the creature with cooking utensils
and using D-52125 to demonstrate, 5031 was
shown how to prepare a variety of different
dishes, from hamburgers and tacos, to Mongolian
Beef, steak, clam chowder and profiteroles.
In addition to a small peanut allergy, this
eighth test revealed SCP-5031 to be a phenomenal
chef, possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person.
The creature quickly and enthusiastically
embraced its newfound talents, concocting
its very own brand-new recipes, with D-52125
even volunteering to be the first to taste
test 5031’s dishes.
It was shortly after this test that SCP-5031
spoke its very first word, and it should come
as no surprise that the word was ‘salt’.
Naturally, Senior Researcher Huxtable was
very proud of the progress the creature had
made with its development.
The final test almost seemed to be what the
creature was born for.
Over the course of two months, SCP-5031 was
tasked with creating a full three-course meal
which would then be served to Foundation staff
for Thanksgiving.
SCP-5031 not only rose to the task, but exceeded
all of Researcher Huxtable’s expectations,
creating a meal that even Gordon Ramsey would
be hard pressed to find fault with.
The creature created a first course consisting
of sweet potato miso soup seasoned with turmeric.
Next came a beautiful duck confit, glazed
luxuriously with apple cider and topped generously
with sweet cranberry compote, paired with
a side of butternut squash gnocchi and served
on a bed of kale seasoned with truffle salt.
The grand finale of the exquisite meal was
a spiced cassava pie for dessert, complemented
with the finest French vanilla ice cream and
a maple-hazelnut syrup.
And SCP-5031 didn’t stop there, the creature
also debuted one of its original musical compositions
to compliment the decadent meal it had created.
As the staff enjoyed the food, SCP-5031 performed
live from its enclosure the deeply moving
Piano Concerto for Six Hands, to an overwhelmingly
positive response from not only Senior Researcher
Huxtable, but the entire Foundation staff.
As a fitting end to the creature’s tale,
Huxtable reported that, during the Thanksgiving
banquet it had created, SCP-5031’s stress
levels reduced entirely.
New kinder containment measures that would
keep 5031 safer but also far more contented
were submitted for approval.
Perhaps some of you may find it refreshing
to learn that SCP-5031 isn’t simply just
another malicious, malevolent monster that
the Foundation has to keep under lock and
key for the safety of the world.
Instead, SCP-5031 is a gentle – if a little
frightening at first creature - that just
requires careful and considered guidance instead
of a cold iron cage and around-the-clock armed
guards.
Through testing, Senior Researcher Stanley
Huxtable and his fellow Foundation staff were
not only able to help the creature develop,
but also found what makes it tick; and not
just for the purposes of containing it.
Instead, it is hoped that SCP-5031’s creativity
and flair for culinary and musical masterpieces
can continue to thrive and grow, under the
proud watch of Researcher Huxtable.
In an old house, an old woman gathers her
knitting supplies. This is a special project,
for a little boy named Tommy she loves dearly.
She knits furiously, and soon the mix of cotton,
synthetic fiber, and cloth of every color
turn from raw materials into something else
- a teddy bear. She puts the finishing touches
on the bear - this is a very special bear,
after all, and sends the patchwork bear off
to its destination with a red get-well card.
The card is labeled “Kairos the Bear”,
and inside she writes a personal note.
“To Tommy,
Because only time can mend all wounds.
Love, Grammy”
But this package full of love would never
reach its destination.
SCP-2295 was found at the site of a crashed
mail truck, and it looks exactly like a standard
handmade teddy bear - with one difference.
On the left side of its chest, just under
its jaunty tan bow, it wears a heart shaped
pin. But not a standard cartoon heart - this
is a disturbingly realistic, anatomically
correct pin of a heart organ. And that’s
because SCP-2295 has a specific purpose - and
it’s one that has everything to do with
actual human organs.
SCP-2295 spends most of its time completely
inert, spending its days as just another cuddly
stuffed toy. Tests performed on the toy revealed
it had no unusual properties and seems to
be a normal handmade keepsake - that is, until
someone is injured in its presence. Not any
injury will do, a paper cut or even a broken
arm for example won’t do much to activate
its anomalous properties. But if it detects
a critical injury to a human organ nearby,
it will trigger its secret power - one that
the Foundation is still trying to figure out
how it works. Because SCP-2295 is a miracle
worker.
When it senses the presence of someone with
a serious injury to an organ and is within
two meters of them, SCP-2295 springs into
action. Suddenly, from unknown sources, the
bear will produce objects including scissors,
white thread, and sewing needles or a crocheting
hook from its mouth. If there are any crafting
supplies on hand, it will incorporate those
as well. And then, it gets to work. Despite
only having hands made of fabric and stuffing
with no fingers, the anomalous bear is still
able to craft what will end up being a patchwork
recreation of the damaged human’s organ.
Cute, if a little creepy, but that’s just
the beginning.
The injured person mysteriously falls unconscious,
and the patchwork organ, which the Foundation
has designated as an SCP-2295-1 instance,
will disappear. The SCP-2295-1 instance will
then physically replace the damaged organ
inside the person’s body. It’s unknown
how this happens, the patchwork organ will
simply appear inside of their body, taking
the place of the original lung, or kidney,
or whichever organ was failing. It’s unknown
where the original organ goes to, since it
seems to just disappear as soon as the 2295-1
instance takes its place.
Surprisingly, having this new cotton stuffed
heart of liver does not seem to cause any
harm, and in fact, it works exactly like the
real thing. There are never any of the usual
issues that come with a transplant like the
risk of it being rejected by the body, as
the organic tissue seems to have no issue
connecting with the organ and treating it
like it was there all along. In all instances
of SCP-2295 performing this adorable but rudimentary
surgery, the subjects have made a full and
complete recovery.
SCP-2295 might sound like a miracle worker,
but that isn’t to say that its abilities
aren’t without their own set of complications.
When faced with two injured subjects, SCP-2295
seems to always gravitate towards fixing the
younger subject up first - maybe owing to
its creation by a grandmother who wanted to
heal whatever was ailing her grandson. No
one knows who Tommy was or exactly what disease
or injury he was recovering from, but his
grandmother clearly felt it was serious enough
to create this special bear for him. While
SCP-2295 will heal anyone, it seems to be
primarily a guardian for the young. And it
takes its duties very seriously - even to
the point of self-sacrifice.
While SCP-2295 is able to pull some of its
supplies out of thin air, it still always
needs some raw materials to craft the new
organ, including fabric and stuffing. And
if there are none available, SCP-2295 will
obtain them the hard way. The patchwork bear
will sacrifice its own body, tearing itself
open and removing any fabric or stuffing it
needs without any concern for its own well-being,
in order to craft a new organ for its patient.
It slowly regenerates its own stuffing, at
the rate of around a gram of stuffing per
day, but it needs to harvest fabric to repair
its outer layer, which the Foundation happily
makes available to it, offering it a variety
of patterns and types.
It’s no surprise that a teddy bear capable
of healing mortal wounds would be of great
interest to the SCP Foundation, and as soon
it was recovered from the crashed mail truck,
they immediately began tests to find out more
about it. Could it heal literally any organ?
Were there any limits to its abilities? There
was only one way to find out, and the Foundation
had the perfect test subjects - D-Class Personnel,
whose interactions with non-cuddly teddy bear
SCPs frequently left them with critical external
and internal injuries.
The first test subject brought in, D-2353,
a thirty-eight year old man who was in poor
health not due to his work as a D-class personnel,
but from his years and years of heavy smoking.
His lungs were seriously damaged, which gave
him trouble breathing and made any serious
physical exertion extremely difficult. He
wasn’t critically injured or in danger of
dying immediately, but that didn’t matter
to SCP-2295. D-2353 quickly passed out and
the bear sprang into action. It proceeded
to take two textile swatches, one black and
one red, and create a pair of fabric lungs
which it installed in the patient. When he
awoke, D-2353 found he had full, healthy lung
function again, as if he’d never picked
up his deadly habit.
But now the Foundation researchers needed
to know how SCP-2295 would do with even more
complicated ailments.
D-3542 was fifty years old and his heart was
not in good shape. Not only did he have a
serious case of atherosclerosis, which is
a disease where cholesterol plaque builds
up and blocks blood flow and can put you at
a serious risk of a heart attack, but he also
had an irregular heartbeat. This D-Class was
in bad shape, but that was no problem for
SCP-2295, who took a collection of different
colors of yarn and a crocheting hook and created
a plushy heart. Just like the lungs had acted
as if they were completely regular organs,
after the heart anomalously ended up inside
the man’s chest it began to beat normally
and performed all the complicated functions
of a human heart. But there was one detail
that shocked the onlooking doctors. Before
the yarn organ had vanished, the doctors had
seen that it was beating.
So is there any organ that SCP-2295 can’t
replace? That was about to be tested when
D-7894 was brought in. A twenty-four-year-old
woman, she had suffered serious burns all
over her torso, left abdomen, and right leg.
She was brought in and sedated to numb the
agonizing pain, and researchers were worried
that they had come up against the limit of
SCP-2295’s abilities, since the skin is
the largest organ after all. But SCP-2295
wasn’t fazed at all, the bear immediately
started sewing segments of patchwork fabric
and layering them onto the damaged skin, replacing
the dermis and epidermis layer by layer. Unlike
the other cases, these replacement organs
are visible, and D-7894 now has patchwork
skin, just like her talented surgeon. And
amazingly, the fabric has the same sense of
touch that her regular skin did.
The final test of SCP-2295’s abilities came
with D-2723, who was only eighteen years old.
This last minute D-Class test was performed
because he was showing signs of a severe cerebral
hemorrhage, the kind that would cause brain
damage in only minutes, and would be followed
soon after by complete brain death. SCP-2295
sprung to life, but as soon as it examined
the test subject, it became distressed. It
started frantically grasping at random materials
around it, as if it didn’t know what to
do with them. Then, it reached inside itself
and provided a large chocolate bar, which
it offered to the subject, sadly to no effect.
It then seemed to admit defeat as it grabbed
tightly onto the subject’s leg. Observers
reported that it was leaking a tear-like solution
from its small knitted eyes as it embraced
the dying D-Class in his final moments.
Sadly, it seems that the human brain is the
one mystery that even SCP-2295 can’t solve.
SCP-2295 appears to pose no threat to anyone
and was classified as safe after testing.
It’s inactive when not in the presence of
an injured person and has never displayed
hostile instincts when active. The Foundation
determined that it should be stored in a standard
containment locker in Site-37, where it can
be kept safely until it’s needed for tests
or to repair an injured SCP personnel. Access
is limited to those with Level 3 or higher
security clearance, and any contact with the
bear is highly regulated.
But there is one element of SCP-2295’s existence
that continues to worry Foundation staff.
SCP-2295’s full origins and the grandmother
who crafted it are unknown. The note it was
found with is the only clue as to where it
may have come from, but there are plenty within
the Foundation who are suspicious of the veracity
of the letter. And they have good reason not
to be too trusting, because another bear with
similar abilities exists - and it is distinctly
less benevolent than SCP-2295. SCP-1048 is
also a teddy bear, but it is capable of moving
on its own and communicating through gestures
at all times. It was initially allowed to
wander around independently and seemed to
make its home at Site 24 a happier place.
But then it began to display its own crafting
abilities.
SCP-1048 is able to craft duplicates of itself,
and while the original was seemingly harmless,
the ones it made were not. These similarly
shaped bears were made of disturbing materials
and were extremely hostile towards any humans
they encountered. The first, SCP-1048-A, was
made entirely out of human ears and when it
shrieked, it caused anyone nearby to generate
ear-like growths all over their bodies, eventually
causing them to suffocate. The creature disappeared
- and an on-site researcher was found to be
missing an ear.
The creations of SCP-1048 only got stranger
and deadlier from there.
SCP-1048-B was found in the Site’s cafeteria,
where it was moving around in a halted, jerky
fashion. It then started bursting at the seams
and revealed what appeared to be a human fetus
inside. When the creature screamed, it sounded
like a much louder version of a human infant
and its croes caused massive internal damage
to anyone around it. SCP-1048-B was killed
in the ensuing conflict with Foundation agents,
ending its threat.
But SCP-1048 was learning deadlier techniques.
When SCP-1048-C was discovered, it looked
to be a teddy bear made entirely out of rusty
scrap metal. When it was spotted by Dr. Carver
and targeted by Foundation personnel, the
creature turned violent and proved to have
incredible strength - jumping through the
agents who were trying to neutralize it, tearing
through their bodies like tissue paper. Attempts
to damage it were unsuccessful, and both it
and the bear made out of ears are still on
the loose along with the original SCP-1048.
Capturing it is a major priority for the Foundation
- because no one wants to see what it will
create next.
Is there a connection between these two very
different teddy bears?
No one has been able to answer this question.
The origins of SCP-1048 are unknown, and so
is any connection to the mysterious grandmother
who may have made Kairos the Bear. But their
abilities are similar, with both able to craft
living objects out of seemingly any material.
They just have very different ideas as to
what a good use of their crafting abilities
are. It’s fortunate that an anomaly as potentially
powerful as SCP-2295 seems to only want to
do one thing. To help those in need, especially
those who are the most vulnerable.
They’d spent hours making the costume.
The two young boys - let’s call them Johnny
and Max - had always been on the creative
side.
Sometimes they got teased for it at school,
but they didn’t care.
As long as they had each other, they could
handle anything - they were best friends.
Maybe one day, they’d build great things
together out of concrete and steel, but for
now, they worked with cardboard.
Prior projects had included building a rocket
out of cardboard in Johnny’s back yard,
like the kind that put a man on the moon.
They also made a box fort like no other - more
a box castle, really.
The kind that would stand for a hundred years
- as long as it didn’t rain, of course.
But all of that felt like nothing compared
to The Tunnel Monster.
To those two young friends, it was a thing
of beauty.
A fully articulated cardboard monster costume,
meticulously cobbled together from boxes,
masking tape, cardboard tubes for arms and
legs, and a little twine to bring it all together.
Frankenstein?
Dracula?
Freddy Kreuger?
Those silver-screen phonies were nothing compared
to The Tunnel Monster.
They even cut out eye holes in the head, and
drew the scariest, snarling mouth they could
right below.
The making was over, and now, they were ready
to play.
Johnny and Max took the costume down to one
of their favorite places in town: The abandoned
Brecher Construction Site.
To many, it would seem like a strange and
dangerous place for two children to play,
but for Johnny and Max, it was perfect.
After all, they were at the age where they
had more imagination than sense.
Max would be the one wearing the costume.
Johnny helped him put it on, piece by piece,
using extra masking tape and twine where necessary
to fasten all the pieces together.
Little by little, Max became the Tunnel Monster,
the transformation was complete and it was
finally time for the games to begin.
Johnny ran, wielding a stick as a defensive
weapon while Max gave chase.
He could feel his own hot breath within the
cardboard mask.
It was oddly exhilarating.
He gave a monstrous roar and charged after
his friend, chasing him into the child-sized
pipes of an unfinished water drainage system.
It was more fun than anything they could have
imagined.
Max really got into his role.
He lunged forwards, grabbing Johnny with his
cardboard gauntlets and tried to drag him
back into the tunnel all the while giving
low, guttural growls.
Johnny laughed, and swatted at Max with his
stick like a knight wielding a sword.
They ran and crawled through the tunnels,
the best of friends having the best of times,
making the kinds of memories that would last
forever.
And in that sense, they were right.
Something they made that day would echo on
forever, but it wouldn’t be something they
would look back upon fondly.
If they weren’t so busy running through
the tunnels, Max and Johnny might have noticed
that something was amiss.
They might have seen that, even though it
was only 3:00 PM on a Summer’s day, the
sky was beginning to darken.
It may not have saved them, but it might have
given them time to prepare for what was coming.
Max was still chasing Johnny down a pipe,
still fully in character as the Tunnel Monster,
his arms extended to grab his fleeing friend
when Johnny tripped.
Max stopped to help him up but something was
wrong.
When Max helped Johnny stand up, Johnny instinctually
pushed him away, as though it wasn’t actually
his friend anymore.
Max stumbled backwards in shock and horror.
He could feel something changing beneath the
cardboard.
He was suddenly in pain, this terrible pain.
Like he was being pulled apart and put back
together.
He started to scream.
It was a horrible sound, like nails on a chalkboard.
Johnny had to hold his ears as the screaming
got louder and louder, but Max couldn’t
stop.
He was hurting too much to stop.
Johnny was crying.
He didn’t know what was happening, only
that his friend was in terrible pain and there
was seemingly nothing he could do to stop
it.
Even Max didn’t know much more than that,
but he thought it must have something to do
with the suit.
It felt like it was full of fire ants, crawling
and biting.
It felt like his body was full of fire ants.
He needed to take the suit off before it got
any worse.
But he couldn’t, the suit wouldn’t come
off.
He reached for the cardboard mask and tried
to tug it off his head, but it wouldn’t
budge.
It felt like he was tugging at the skin of
his own face.
He could suddenly feel everything that brushed
against the cardboard, like it was connected
to his nerve endings.
The fear and the panic got worse and he kept
screaming.
It was a deafening, ear-splitting scream.
He didn’t know it, but anything electrical
within a 200 meter radius was dying.
TVs shut off.
Radios fizzled out.
Cars stopped running.
Nobody who didn’t work for the SCP Foundation
would ever know why.
It wasn’t even 3:30 PM, but the sky above
looked black as midnight.
Max was afraid but all he could do was cling
to the familiar - he lunged forwards and grabbed
Johnny, pulling him into his trembling embrace.
Is he still Max now?
No, he doesn’t think so anymore.
He’s something else entirely.
As he held his friend, Max tried to dig his
fingers into the mask and tear it off.
They pierced through the cardboard, tearing
holes into it.
It was agonizing, but the mask stayed put.
There was no escape.
He closed his eyes, just for a moment.
Maybe it was a bad dream.
Maybe he could make it disappear.
But it didn’t disappear - only he did.
Max was no more.
There was only the Tunnel Monster.
When Johnny woke up, he was disoriented and
afraid.
He was in complete darkness but he could feel
the old metal of a rusty railroad track beneath
his feet.
He didn’t remember how he got there, and
he didn’t remember Max either.
Not his face or even his name.
But that’s alright - Max didn’t remember
him either.
When the terrified Johnny eventually found
his way out of the old railway tunnel he’d
somehow found himself in, he was rescued by
emergency services and treated for dehydration.
Because of the incredibly strange circumstances
of his disappearance and reappearance over
4,000 kilometers away, it was only natural
for the SCP Foundation to check in.
But, seeing as Johnny had no memory of where
he was prior to his mysterious teleportation,
all they ever did was investigate the tunnel
he’d appeared in.
Of course, they didn’t find a thing.
The case was closed shortly afterwards, written
off as a kind of one-off spatial anomaly.
Johnny was given amnestic treatment, and reintegrated
back into his normal life.
He would never remember his encounter with
the Tunnel Monster.
But many would, for decades and decades to
come.
There would be stories and scattered witness
accounts from all kinds of people.
Maintenance workers doing electrical repairs
on subway tunnels, sewer workers cleaning
out blockages in pipes, road workers fixing
the asphalt in underpasses.
The challenge with being an SCP Foundation
field agent is often separating the genuine
leads from the urban legends and spooky stories,
but the details here were all too similar
and specific.
After all, it would be such a strange thing
to make up - a moldy old pile of cardboard
boxes, getting up and running towards you?
But stranger still, these incidents and encounters
were occurring all over the United States,
with the only commonalities being that all
of them happened in tunnels or tunnel-like
structures.
The Foundation didn’t know if they were
dealing with one entity, or many.
Another peculiar factor they observed was
that sometimes, people who had encounters
with the Tunnel Monster then themselves appear
in tunnels extremely far away from the ones
in which they first encountered it.
As far as the Foundation was aware, besides
transporting them vast distances, it never
actually harmed any of its victims.
But according to one Boston sewer worker,
Gus Zagarella, when the Tunnel Monster laid
its cardboard hand on him, he felt the most
profound sense of paranoia and dread.
He described it as feeling like a thousand
eyes in the dark, watching you die.
Then, he blinked, and he woke up in an Arizona
viaduct, roughly six hours later.
Everyone who reported a similar experience
with the Tunnel Monster was detained, debriefed,
and given amnestics by the Foundation.
Eventually, they gathered enough data on prior
encounters to accurately predict the next
tunnel that the Tunnel Monster would manifest
inside.
A new Mobile Task Force was formed to secure
the creature: MTF Nu-4, also known as the
"Box Cutters.”
What they didn’t expect, when they finally
engaged the beast, was that it was no larger
than a human child.
It wasn’t some huge, tunnel-dwelling nightmare;
even after all these decades, the Tunnel Monster
was little more than a frightened, lonely
little boy.
He growled, attempting and failing to come
off as intimidating to these hardcore MTF
members, and referred to himself as the Tunnel
Monster.
When they didn’t react with fear and surprise
like all the others, he became subdued.
They were able to peacefully apprehend him,
and take him back to Site-54 for testing and
containment.
Preliminary X-Rays found that the cardboard
costume hadn’t just fused with the boy,
it had completely transformed him.
On the inside, he was filled with crude, cardboard
copies of all the major internal organs, with
his blood vessels and nerve endings made out
of colored pieces of string.
They couldn’t find any information on who
the boy once was, if he had ever been a boy
at all, and he was given the designation SCP-3663.
In order to find out more, one of the leading
researchers on the SCP-3663 case, Researcher
Doyle, decided to conduct an interview with
the Tunnel Monster.
It has been the only interview with the creature
to date, due to the emotional distress it
caused the creature.
When asked about its identity, it replied
with only, “The tunnel monster.”
When asked why it attacked and teleported
people to different locations, the creature
replied, “The tunnel monster captures people.
That's me, I'm the tunnel monster.
I…
I capture people and take them into the tunnels
where I live.
In the tunnels.
The pipes.
I'm the tunnel monster.”
As the interview progressed, the Tunnel Monster
became increasingly upset, until it began
weeping through its cardboard face, finally
culminating with it crying out between sobs,
“Please.
I don't want to play anymore.”
SCP-3663 only feels comfortable in tunnels,
and it will teleport away in distress if confined
anywhere else.
As such, its containment chamber is technically
the maintenance tunnels underneath Site-54,
where it seems to have made a home for itself.
Occasionally, if it experiences fear, damage,
or stress, it may demanifest and appear in
tunnels elsewhere.
At that point, the Box Cutters are deployed
to collect 3663 once again and bring him back
to Site-54.
So far, there has only been one major containment
breach with SCP-3663, but it was a little
more deadly than you might expect for a boy-sized
creature made of cardboard.
The Tunnel Monster escaped from the Site-54
tunnels, and began wailing in pain.
It went positively berserk, attacking surrounding
staff and trashing parts of the facility.
Anyone who heard the wails of the Tunnel Monster
reported becoming extremely psychologically
disturbed by them.
During this four hour rampage, the monster
also tried multiple times to destroy itself
with various implements, but was unsuccessful.
After SCP-3663 was recontined, two deceased
members of personnel were recovered from the
scene.
Autopsies showed the cause of death was a
buildup of paper residue and wood pulp in
all of their major blood vessels, as well
as sinuses, ear tubes, and the majority of
the digestive and respiratory systems.
A number of other staff members were found
to have been affected to a lesser degree,
but are expected to make full recoveries.
What triggered this explosive and deadly outburst?
Not even the Tunnel Monster itself knew the
answer to that question.
But we do.
At exactly the same time, a 79 year old man
passed away from natural causes after what
seemed like a thoroughly unremarkable life.
That man’s name was Johnny.
Think back to your childhood, and ask yourself:
what was the most pain you ever felt while
growing up?
As we develop, our understanding of pain evolves
according to our different experiences.
The older we get, the injuries we suffered
as children like a scraped knee, or a bee
sting rarely cause us the same level of distress
as they used to.
Of course, when you are young and unfamiliar
with sensations of pain, what you really need
in that moment straight after you’ve fallen
off your bike, or tripped playing soccer,
is someone to pick you back up and give your
sore spot a kiss.
Perhaps you even need a bowl of warm soup
to comfort you.
Luckily for you, SCP-348 is exactly that.
While many of the anomalies held in containment
by the SCP Foundation have earned the “Euclid”
or infamous “Keter” class designations,
SCP-348 is one of the few considered to be
Safe - both in the sense it poses no containment
risk, and in that it wouldn’t hurt a fly.
It is neither an ancient, eldritch abomination
from another dimension spreading its influence
in our world through memetic stimuli, nor
is it a recording of a basketball game in
which all the players and spectators are trapped
inside.
It isn’t an indestructible, limb-regenerating
reptile, or a towering winged being, wielding
a flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the Garden of Eden.
To put it simply, SCP-348 is a bowl.
A white ceramic bowl, the kind you would find
almost anywhere in the world.
It may even look indistinguishable from one
in your own kitchen cabinet.
Of course, SCP-348 is hardly as ordinary as
it outwardly appears to be.
And it certainly isn’t the only inanimate
object that the Foundation keeps safely stored
away.
The key thing that differentiates SCP-348
from most other anomalies is how genuinely
harmless it is.
Its anomalous properties do not cause injury
to any individual that interacts with it,
nor does this bowl have any adverse effects
on the world around it.
SCP-348 cannot bend or reshape reality, it
does not cause the person eating from it to
have premonitions of their own death, and
using it certainly does not manifest a contract-making
entity at the opposite side of the table.
So, what makes this bowl in any way anomalous?
What about it categorizes it as an SCP, and
not just a harmless piece of fine crockery?
Well, why don’t we start with how SCP-348
was first discovered.
Some time ago, the SCP Foundation was made
aware of rumors surrounding a child living
in an unknown part of the world.
According to the intelligence gathered by
the Foundation, this child seemed to possess
some sort of healing ability, or at least
this is what rumors suggested.
Upon further investigation, the source of
these so-called “remarkable recovery abilities”
wasn’t the child, but appeared to come from
a small ceramic bowl, which we now know as
SCP-348.
This is not to say that the bowl has any inherently
supernatural healing properties, and it doesn’t
impart any regenerative power to those that
eat from it, either.
It does heal in a certain sense, but not in
the way you’re probably imagining.
When the SCP Foundation recovered SCP-348,
there were no markings on it indicating where
the bowl came from or who it was manufactured
by.
The only visually distinct details worthy
of note were flowery patterns that appeared
to be hand-painted around both the inside
and outside of SCP-348.
The ceramic surface also bore the Chinese
letters 想着你.
Which translates to the phrase, “thinking
of you.”
The child that first discovered it found the
ceramic bowl in the attic of their home.
The child’s parents were both full-time
workers and seemed to be somewhat neglectful
of their child, although they refused to comment
on this, but according to the findings of
the SCP Foundation, the child had come to
rely on SCP-348.
Deciding to further investigate the anomalous
properties of SCP-348, the Foundation began
testing it.
Given that the child who first discovered
the bowl had relied upon it, tests involved
Foundation researchers presenting certain
children to SCP-348 and observing the results.
So, was this bowl haunted?
Perhaps harboring some malicious spirit or
entity that sought to corrupt these children,
maybe even healing them in order to somehow
use them as a vessel to break into our world?
No.
And while it may not have “healed” in
any overt or expected way, it did heal in
at least a metaphorical sense.
If presented with an injured child, sporting
any form of minor ailment such as a cut or
a runny nose, SCP-348 fills with warm soup.
And yes, that’s right, we said soup.
What kind, you may ask?
Well, that seems to vary.
Sometimes it is tomato soup, other times it
might be chicken noodle soup.
While the ingredients used in its soups are
often different, there are notable consistencies
to how SCP-348 heals.
If anyone between the ages of four years old
and eighteen years old sits down in front
of the blue flowered bowl, then SCP-348 will
fill with soup.
Numerous young test subjects brought in by
the Foundation to eat from this particular
bowl of soup have reported that they enjoyed
their meal, usually finishing the entire bowl
when permitted to by research staff.
Many of the injured children that were tested
have stated that the soup they eat from SCP-348
reminds them of their parents’ cooking.
These children have expressed contentment
and feelings of comfort after acquiring their
various cuts and bruises.
Some even claimed that, even though they were
in a room all alone, they didn’t feel lonely
when they were eating the soup.
And the anomalous properties don’t end after
a child finishes the soup.
Usually, although not always, the bowl will
leave the child a message, often some brief
words of reassurance or comfort.
These messages materialize on the inside rim
of the bowl, and seem to be specifically tailored
to the subject that has just eaten.
The words will not only be written in the
child’s first language, but are often linked
to the child’s home life or relationship
with their parents.
Messages that appear on SCP-348 usually fade
over time, normally disappearing after a few
hours, or when the bowl refills with more
soup.
One test of SCP-348 saw a little girl, aged
eight and suffering from a sore throat, brought
before the bowl.
According to a background screening made by
research personnel, the girl lived with her
biological parents, and apparently had a good
relationship with both her mother and father.
When SCP-348 filled with soup for her, the
girl took almost a half hour to finish eating,
and afterwards reported that she felt her
sore throat get better as she ate.
By the end of the meal, this test subject
remarked that she felt completely normal.
In this instance, no message appeared within
the bowl.
Another child was brought in to continue the
testing of SCP-348, this time a boy of ten.
Unlike the previous test, this boy was not
on good terms with his parents and often argued
with them.
At the time of testing, the boy had sustained
several minor bruises, the result of a small
accident that had occurred while the boy had
been out riding his bike.
Much like the little girl, this subject ate
the soup that SCP-348 presented him with.
This time though, the bowl offered a message
to the boy.
The lettering found on the ceramic surface
of SCP-348 simply read “Don’t forget to
brush.”
Messages also appeared when an eleven year
old boy with a slight cold ate soup from the
bowl.
This child had been adopted by a foster family,
and after eating from SCP-348, he saw the
message “I’m glad you’re happy” appear.
Another young test subject, a boy aged six,
had a similar experience.
In this instance, the child had several scrapes
and scratches from playing with his friends.
His parents had divorced, and he was living
with his mother at the time of testing.
This time, SCP-348’s to message this boy
read “I’m sorry, son.”
A seven year old girl suffering from a cough
was brought before SCP-348.
She had lost her father to a traffic accident
some time before testing commenced, and received
the message “I love you” after finishing
her soup.
Further testing conducted by the Foundation
revealed that anyone over the age of eighteen
years who attempted to eat soup from SCP-348
experienced things slightly differently.
Unlike the children, older subjects mostly
displayed a disinterest in finishing their
meal.
A common complaint among those over eighteen
was that the soup was “missing something.”
However, in a few isolated cases, testing
SCP-348 on older candidates still revealed
messages, although the words seemed to be
faded, not the clear, hand-painted blue that
appeared when the children had finished their
soup.
One woman, aged thirty, who was suffering
from a headache sat down in front of SCP-348.
Much like it had done before, the bowl filled
with soup and the woman ate.
As with some of the younger subjects, a key
aspect of this woman’s background seemed
to be what triggered the message to appear.
Specifically, she admitted to being on bad
terms with her mother and father.
The woman explained that she had opted to
live on her own, isolating herself from her
family.
In fact, she even described having rejected
an offer her father made to her many years
earlier, refusing some career training that
he was willing to give in order to help her
secure a job.
When she’d finished the soup, one word appeared
in the bowl: “Why?”
Another woman, who was forty years old, was
also brought in for the SCP-348 testing.
Much like the previous subject, she had moved
away from home and become estranged from her
parents over the years.
But unlike the previous test, this woman had
taken it upon herself to not only send money
to her parents, but also arranged senior care
for both as well.
Prior to testing, her father had died peacefully
of natural causes after spending his last
days in the care that this woman had paid
for.
As the woman ate the soup from the bowl, she
remarked about its apparently “bitter”
taste, but also described her meal as “fulfilling”.
After she had finished, the words “Thank
you” appeared within SCP-348.
One other adult subject that produced a noticeable
result from SCP-348 was a forty year old male.
The results of this test appeared to be the
most distinctly different from any previous
adult or child.
By now, researchers working for the SCP Foundation
had determined that familial history seemed
to play an important role in the outcome of
any interaction with SCP-348, and this individual
was certainly different to most.
The man in question had murdered his father
roughly a year before the testing took place.
He began the test with SCP-348 while afflicted
with aches in his back.
After one taste of the soup that appeared
in the bowl before him, the murderer was immediately
repulsed.
He complained about the taste, refusing to
eat any more from SCP-348.
Shortly after, the man began to experience
severe stomach pain.
The potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of, but SCP-348 immediately filled with salt
water, which took three hours to disappear
from the bowl.
Despite conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and ailments, the SCP Foundation
researchers have so far been unable to determine
the origins of the messages that sometimes
appear in SCP-348.
Some have theorized, because of the family
histories of some children and adults tested,
that the words somehow come from the father
of whoever eats the soup, since even when
a subject’s father is alive or present in
their life, the message seems to convey feelings
that their father has, or would have.
Other researchers claim this is just the purpose
of SCP-348, to provide comfort to small children
dealing with pain, both inside and out.
And after all, isn’t providing comfort what
a good bowl of soup, anomalous or not, is
best at?
Almost all cross-testing to kill or pacify
SCP – 682 had failed miserably.
If you haven’t seen it, go watch our video
on the legendary Hard To Kill Reptile, to
see just how powerful and terrifying this
creature is.
It faced the Gate Guardian, an SCP with a
flaming sword hotter than the sun – capable
of tearing your atoms to shreds – and came
out fine.
In its face-off with the horrifying SCP – 096,
also known as the Shy Guy, it broke the Shy
Guy’s mind and reduced it to gibbering despair.
Even SCPs with supposedly unlimited powers
simply refused to engage the beast in combat.
So, when it was proposed that they test 682
with SCP – 999, a creature known among Foundation
staff as “The Tickle Monster,” the idea
was considered laughable.
682 had been burned, suffocated, cut up, incinerated,
and growled in the faces of Gods.
How could this so-called Tickle Monster ever
hope to survive an encounter, let alone win
a fight?
Some even believed that this was the last
we’d see of SCP – 999.
But what makes this story truly remarkable
is that that isn’t how this played out.
As you’ll soon discover, 0SCP – 999 is
an amazing and unique SCP in and of itself,
but its secret origins and its interactions
with some other prominent figures in the SCP
universe are what make this humble, slimy
creature beyond extraordinary.
Prepare yourself for the heartwarming – yes,
you heard that right - the heartwarming story
of SCP – 999.
Several highly-trained agents on 682 detail
placed 999 into the immortal lizard’s cell.
Compared to the giant, reptilian sitting across
from it, 999 wasn’t much to look at – it’s
a large, orange, amorphous blob of anomalous
slime.
Weighing in at around 120 pounds, SCP - 999
was nothing compared to the monstrosity it
was supposed to face.
While its weight has, in the past, caused
minor injuries to some of its human handlers,
it has never caused serious or long-lasting
damage of any kind to a living thing.
Even its diet consists only of candy and sweets,
with a particular preference for M&Ms and
Necco wafers.
It consumes these treats through the cell
membrane of its slimy body, much like an amoeba.
This extremely stretchy membrane means the
creature is highly malleable, including the
ability to stretch and flatten itself out
to a mere two centimeters thick.
At rest, the creature takes a dome-like shape
around two meters wide and one meter in height.
The closest things the creature has to limbs
are prehensile pseudopods, those are the arm-like
projections normally seen on single celled
organisms, of which it has at least three.
The more you hear about this utterly harmless
creature, the more that matching it up with
the pure embodiment of absolute hatred known
as SCP – 682 feels downright cruel.
In absolute contrast to the misanthropic attitudes
of the reptile, 999 loves humans.
It has a playful, dog-like attitude.
Much like an over-excited puppy, when approached,
999 will react with extreme joy and slither
towards the nearest person in order to interact.
It will leap onto them, using two of its three
prehensile pseudopods to hug the person, while
the third nuzzles the person’s face – emitting
high-pitched cooing and gurgling noises throughout.
The creature is apparently pleasant in every
conceivable fashion, as even its odor has
been reported to smell just like the favourite
scent of whoever is smelling it.
Examples have included chocolate, fresh laundry,
bacon, roses, and Play-Doh.
It's almost impossible to oversell just how
beloved and benevolent this strange creature
is.
It’s one of the rare sapient SCPs to earn
the “Safe” class, and it’s allowed to
roam freely around its facility at all times,
apart from a one hour bedtime period between
8 and 9 PM.
In the rare instances that 999 has caused
harm to a worker at the facility, it immediately
began to back away and contract its body while
whimpering in a kind of dog-like apology.
The closest the Foundation had ever come to
having a real incident with the creature was
the time someone accidentally fed it a can
of caffeinated cola, causing it to become
hyper for an hour before becoming visibly
queasy.
You’ll be relieved to know that it’s since
made a full recovery.
But what would happen when this whimsical
creature is forced to go toe-to-toe with the
Foundation’s most ill-tempered monster?
The employees observing the test watched in
suspense as 999 began to enthusiastically
slither towards 682.
It’s no surprise that after being tortured
and almost killed hundreds of times during
testing, 682 had grown jaded to the cross-tests
it was regularly subjected to.
When it saw this strange, orange blob squelching
across the ground towards it, it sighed and
groaned, expecting the worst.
“What is that?”
the creature asked of its gelatinous guest.
SCP – 999 began jumping up and down in front
of 682 like an excited puppy, creating a high-pitched
squealing noise.
Just as it regarded all living things, 682
thought the creature bouncing around before
it was disgusting and hardly worth the effort
to destroy.
Was the Foundation even trying anymore?
With a single vicious stomp, 682 flattened
the friendly creature beneath one of its feet.
Observers were prepared to charge in and liberate
999 from under 682’s claws, but then something
truly unexpected happened.
The expression on 682’s acid-eaten face
began to slowly change.
It was beginning... to smile.
Observers recorded a noise that they thought
could have been a chuckle, as the creature
growled and said, “Hmmm?
What is this…I feel… good…”
While the observers looked on, stunned at
what was happening, 999 began to slither and
crawl up from between 682’s toes.
It reformed on its scaly leg and slithered
up along its side until it reached the neck.
There, it began to nuzzle like it had never
nuzzled before.
The results spoke for themselves.
682 was grinning and chuckling, repeating
a phrase that the Foundation never would have
even imagined coming from 682: “Feel…
so… happy.
Happy…happy… happy…”
Just when you thought SCP – 999 couldn’t
possibly be more adorable, you learn about
its greatest power: Bringing joy.
Anyone and anything that comes into contact
with the creature, even in passing, will experience
a kind of mild euphoria.
As one’s contact with the creature is prolonged,
this overwhelming sense of joy increases,
and continues long after you’re separated
from it.
Prolonged contact has completely cured depression,
anxiety, and PTSD, along with a number of
other conditions, including rage and antisocial
personality disorders.
Serial killers practically become saints after
coming into prolonged contact with 999, and
in that moment, 682 was no exception.
And there truly does appear to be no exceptions.
While “causing happiness and joy” isn’t
a dangerous weapon, when it comes to SCP – 999,
it is an extremely powerful one.
And what’s more, SCP – 999 also appears
to have an innate sense for those who need
its help most – with a particular affection
for the hurt and the unhappy.
The creature appears to be a true altruist
on a fundamental level, even risking its own
safety to help humans during dangerous containment
breaches.
In one dramatic instance, 999 leaped into
the air to block a bullet from making contact
with a member of staff.
As a result, the creature is pretty much universally
loved by all members of Foundation staff.
It’s the one SCP who never made trouble
for anyone.
Back in SCP – 682’s containment cell,
the beast was still smiling and laughing as
999 rubbed against its neck.
It was an event so strange, so unprecedented
that the observers in attendance felt like
they were hallucinating.
For a few minutes, the monster kept dreamily
repeating the word “happy” but then, suddenly,
the creature began to enter a fit of uncontrollable,
booming laughter.
It rolled onto its back, slamming its huge
tail against the door.
It’d just fallen victim to one of 999’s
favorite pastimes: Tickle Fights, hence how
it earned its Tickle Monster nickname among
staff.
The tickle fight continued until 682 appeared
to tire and fall asleep, with a smile still
on its face.
After fifteen minutes of inactivity, two D-Class
personnel were commanded to enter and retrieve
SCP – 999 from the containment cell.
They did so successfully, but as soon as 999
was removed, 682 roused from its slumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from its
entire body while laughing maniacally.
It rendered all personnel within a certain
distance incapacitated as they collapsed in
fits of laughter, allowing 682 to escape and
go on a violent rampage.
However, in spite of this, 999 showed no fear,
and helped save some of the bystanders as
security officers subdued and recaptured 682.
And even after all this, 999 showed no hard
feelings towards 682, and indicated a desire
to play again.
It’s a creature whose capacity for love
is so limitless that it’s practically immune
to fear.
Which is all well and good, because the true
enemy that 999 is destined to face is infinitely
more powerful and terrifying than 682 could
ever hope to be.
What is this monster, and why should 999 have
to face it someday?
The answers to these questions all lie in
the true origins of SCP – 999, available
only to those with level 5 clearance and beyond.
It’s a perfect example of how something
good can come from the darkest places…
There would be no SCP – 999 without SCP
– 231 – 7.
SCP – 231 was a collection of seven girls,
all impregnated by horrific nightmares in
a ritual performed by a cult known as the
Children of the Scarlet King.
Each of these girls, over the years that followed,
gave birth to some of the most horrific monsters
imaginable – one of which, according to
some, was SCP – 682.
These beings were manifested by the Scarlet
King, a powerful interdimensional nightmare
God, believed to be behind a great deal of
the darkness and horror present within our
and many other dimensions.
Foundation higher-ups have declared the Scarlet
King to be the greatest existing threat to
the Multiverse at large, and SCP – 231 was
his latest direct interaction with our universe.
The only surviving member of SCP – 231,
SCP – 231 – 7, gave birth in secret.
But she didn’t give birth to a monster – she
gave birth to SCP – 999, a being of pure
goodness.
That’s right: The nicest, kindest, cuddliest
SCP of all is the direct descendent of a being
that’s essentially the Dark God of all evil.
Feel free to take a moment to absorb that.
The creature even healed the girl who birthed
it, and allowed her to return to normal life
with her family once more.
From its first moments, SCP - 999 was making
positive changes to the world around it.
And according to ancient texts from a Scarlet
King-aligned culture known as the Daevas,
SCP – 999 is still very much in its infancy,
yet it already has the power to pacify its
monstrous siblings like the aforementioned
682.
It’s believed, according to some prophecies
and Foundation theories, that the power of
SCP – 999 will grow exponentially as it
matures.
Why does this matter?
Well, it’s believed by some that one day
999 will grow powerful enough to overthrow
not only its own monstrous siblings, but the
thought-to-be-unstoppable Scarlet King himself.
Not through violence or hate, but through
the pure force of happiness and love burning
out the darkness and purifying the corrupted.
While the humble SCP – 999 rarely outshines
its frightening competitors, to those truly
in the know, 999 is one of the most powerful
and valuable SCPs in existence, and may be
the greatest asset in the Foundation’s arsenal
for the war against dangerous anomalous activity.
After all, what could strike more fear into
their hearts than the knowledge that it might
be love rather than firepower that finally
dethrones the Scarlet King?
And for the knowledge that it may one day
save everything we know from a fate so much
worse than death with nothing but affection
for everyone and everything, it’s worth
offering thanks to the little orange blob,
or at least an extra pack of M&Ms before bedtime.